hey everyone welcome to simply learn's
youtube channel in this session we will
be learning the data structures and
algorithms full course but before we
begin let me tell you guys that we have
daily updates on multiple technologies
so if you're a tech geek in a continuous
hunt for latest technological trends
then consider getting subscribed to our
youtube channel and don't forget to hit
that bell icon to never miss an update
from simply learn
now without further ado let's get
started with the agenda for today's
session first we will understand what
exactly is an algorithm followed by that
we will understand what are data
structures once we are done with the
fundamentals of algorithms and data
structures we will continue with
pointers in c programming language
later we'll start with our first data
structure that is the arrays in data
structure next we will understand a
little more detail about arrays where we
will understand the two dimensional
arrays and multi-dimensional arrays in
data structure next we will dive into
the linked list and data structure after
that we will understand linked lists in
a much more detail by understanding the
variety of linked lists that is the
singly linked list doubly linked list
circular linked list
after that we will get started with
stacks in data structure after stacks we
will understand queues and dqs in data
structure
followed by that we will understand our
linear search algorithm next we will
continue with three data structures and
after that we will understand an
algorithm based on tree traversal
after we understand the tree data
structure and its traversal we will get
started with binary trees and binary
search tree
next we will have recursion after
understanding recursion we will again
start with trees where we will
understand avl trees in data structure
followed by that we will learn the
bubble sort algorithm
next after understanding the bubble sort
algorithm we will get started with
insertion sort next we have selection
sort merge sort quick sort algorithms
once we are done with the sorting
algorithms we will get started again
with the data structures where we will
dive into graphs
once we are done with the graphs we will
understand the relevant algorithms which
are the kruskal's algorithm backtracking
algorithm and then we will understand
the spanning tree in data structures
once we are done with spanning trees we
will understand the breadth first search
algorithm and depth first search
algorithm later we will understand the
gradia algorithm and finally we will
wonder the session by discussing prem's
algorithm so all the agenda pointers
that we discussed in the agenda will be
explained in detail theoretically as
well as practically so make sure that
you stick to the end of this tutorial to
understand every data structures and
algorithms concept that you ever need in
detail and with perfection so without
further ado over to our experts we will
discuss what is an algorithm but before
we begin let me tell you guys that we
have daily updates on multiple
technologies if you're a tech geek in a
continuous hunt for latest technological
trends then consider getting subscribed
to our youtube channel and don't forget
to hit that bell icon to never miss an
update from simply done
now without further ado let's get
started with the agenda for today's
session
first we will get started with what is
an algorithm
followed by that we will look into the
characteristics of algorithm
next we will learn how to write an
algorithm
moving ahead we will look at algorithm
analysis and algorithm complexities
after that we will discuss the
advantages and disadvantages of
algorithms and finally we will see some
differences between algorithms and
programming
i hope i made myself clear with the
agenda now let's get started with the
first point that is what exactly is an
algorithm
so how does algorithm work in real life
so we'll have a use case here
on my screen we have a lady and she is
shreya shreya wants to make some tea and
for that she is following some steps so
the first step is she'll take a pan and
fill it with water and place it on a gas
tub
followed by that the second step is
she'll make sure that the water comes to
a nice boil and then she adds some tea
leaves and sugar
followed by step 2 we have step 3 where
she'll allow the leaf to be fully
expanded and she'll add some milk after
that
next we have the stefo where she will
wait for the tea to come for a good
decent boil
next we have step 5 where she'll turn
off the gas and she'll take the pan off
from the stove and the tea is ready to
get filtered and lastly we have the step
6 where she is all set with the t
so in computer science an algorithm is a
method or set of rules that we must be
following to perform some specific
calculations or other problem solving
operations
as a result an algorithm is a collection
of rules or instructions that govern how
a work needs to be conducted step by
step to achieve the desired results to
accomplish a task
we first provide some input and then
follow a sequence of steps to acquire
the required outcome of the input
so that is the fundamental definition of
an algorithm and we also had a use case
and now we will move ahead and
understand the characteristics of
algorithms
so basically we have six characteristics
of algorithm so the first one is it
should be clear and unambiguous the
second one is that it has to be well
defined inputs and the third one is that
it has to be having well defined outputs
as well the fourth property of an
algorithm is its feasibility followed by
that
finiteness and finally we have language
independence
now we will look into each one of the
characteristics in detail so first we
have clear and unambiguous so this
statement is the one which states that
the algorithm should be straightforward
simple and easily readable
each one of its steps should be distinct
in every way and lead it to a single
conclusion
so the next one is it should be having
well-defined inputs so this means that
an algorithm should indicate what output
can be expected as well as the input
should be properly well-defined now we
have the third one similarly we should
also have well-defined outputs so the
well-defined output characteristics of
an algorithm means that the algorithm
must clearly indicate what output can be
expected as well as the output should
also be well defined followed by the
third characteristic we have the fourth
characteristic that is the finiteness of
algorithm so the finiteness of algorithm
says that the algorithm must be finite
and it must not result in infinite loops
or similar situations
so followed by the fourth one we have
the fifth characteristic that defines
about the feasibility of an algorithm
so feasibility of an algorithm states
that the algorithm must be really simple
generic and practical
it must be able to be executed with
resources available
now the last characteristic of the
algorithm is being independent of the
language
so it means that the algorithm should be
defined in such a way that it is
completely independent of the language
it must be simple instructions that can
be implemented using any programming
language
so these were the six major
characteristics of algorithm now let's
move ahead and understand how to write
an algorithm
writing an algorithm does not have any
hard and fast rules
next algorithms are never created to
support a specific programming language
as we all know algorithm should be
capable enough to support the
conditional statements such as if if
else switch etc
an algorithm should be capable enough to
execute some of the conditional
statements such as if if else switch etc
and also it must be capable to execute
the iterative statements such as for
loop while loop do while loop etc
we usually create algorithms in a
step-by-step manner however this isn't
always the case
after the problem domain has been well
defined algorithm writing is a procedure
that is carried out
we build an algorithm to find a solution
to a problem a problem can be resolved
in a variety of ways let's look at an
example of how to write an algorithm
consider the following scenario we need
to create an algorithm to determine the
largest number among the three given
numbers x y and z
as a result the initial solution to the
problem can be written in this manner so
we begin with reading all the three
numbers and in the second step we will
have a condition that says if x is
greater than y we will proceed to step
four else we will proceed to step five
next in step four we establish a
condition that if x is greater than z
then x is the largest of the three
numbers otherwise z is the largest
if y is greater than z z will be the
greatest number otherwise y will be the
largest number amongst all the three in
step five
and the procedure will be terminated
let's have a look at what the next
solution has to offer
in this algorithm we begin by reading
all the three variables then compare all
the three numbers in the third step to
determine the largest number which is if
x is greater than y then there is
another if else statement that states
that if x is greater than y then x is
largest otherwise z is the largest
then this if else statement which says
that if y is greater than z then y is
greater otherwise z is the greatest of
the three numbers so this is how we have
multiple solutions to the same problem
so after discussing these solutions we
will move ahead and understand algorithm
analysis
the algorithm may be studied in two
levels first before it is made and then
after it is created the two analysis of
an algorithm are as follows the first
one is priori analysis and the second
one is the post analysis so first we
will talk about the priori analysis
priori analysis refers to the
theoretical analysis of an algorithm
performed before its implementation
before implementing the algorithm other
parameters such as processor speed might
be considered which does not affect the
implementation component next we will
talk about post analysis
a practical analysis of an algorithm is
called as posterior analysis and it
utilizes any computer language to build
the algorithm the purpose of this
analysis is to determine how much time
and space the algorithm takes to operate
now after being understood the algorithm
analysis we will be able to comprehend
the algorithm complexity two methods can
be used to assess the algorithm
complexity the first one is time
complexity which states that the amount
of time required to finish an
algorithm's execution is known as its
time complexity
followed by time complexity the other
one is the space complexity which is
calculated by the quantity of space
required to solve a problem and produce
an output of space complexity of an
algorithm
let's take a closer look at these
complexities
now we will begin with time complexity
of an algorithm the big o notation is
used to express an algorithm's time
complexity the asymptomatic notation is
used to depict temporary complexity of
big o notation
the time complexity is mainly determined
by counting the number of steps required
to complete the task
let's take a look at an example to
understand this time complexity in a
much better way
if we want to find out a multiplication
of n numbers we can do it by executing a
loop from 1 to n then calculating
multiplication when the loop ends then
multiplication holds the n numbers
multiplication and last we return the
calculated multiplication
the loop statements time complexity will
be at least n and when the number of n
increases the time complexity will also
increase
while the code's complexity that is
returns multiplication will remain
constant because its value is unaffected
by the value of n and it will obtain the
result in every single step
next we will discuss about space
complexity which is expressed with big o
notation just as time complexity
these four items are stored in space
complexity it initially saves program
instructions then stores constant values
then stores variable values and finally
it keeps track of function cells jumping
statements and so on
the sum of auxiliary space and input
size is used to calculate space
complexity the extra space or temporary
space used by an algorithm is referred
to an auxiliary space after learning
about algorithm complexity we will look
at some of the algorithms pros and cons
so let's start with the advantages of
algorithms firstly algorithms are easy
to understand
next algorithms are step-by-step
representation of a solution and lastly
the problem is broken down into smaller
bits or steps in an algorithm making it
easier for the programmer now an
algorithm also have various drawbacks
one of which being it takes long time to
write hence it is time consuming
second con of the algorithm is
algorithms make it harder to demonstrate
branching and looping statements
so followed by the advantages and
disadvantages of algorithms we now enter
into the final segment where we discuss
the differences between algorithms and
programming so the first difference is
that
an algorithm is a type of programming on
the other hand a program is more
directly associated with the computer
performing one or more tasks but an
algorithm is more of a notation a
technique for solving a problem
now let us discuss the second difference
an algorithm can be decoded or run by a
human whereas the program is only run or
decoded by a set of compilers of the
computer
now the third difference
basically an algorithm is a design of
the solution to the problem
here we can only analyze the solution
but we can never run it
but whereas on the other hand
programming is completely a different
ball game here you can directly
implement a certain phase or an entire
program and test the programs and get an
output
so the fourth and the last difference
between an algorithm and programming is
an algorithm is written using natural
human vocabulary
whereas programs are written using any
programming language such as c c plus
plus java python etc
we live in an information age which
means data and information are the heart
of everything we do the id sector in
which we work requires a lot of data and
information which is widespread and can
be stored anywhere as a result the
question arises as how do we store this
data so that we can retrieve it quickly
for the further use so hello everyone
welcome to the simply learn youtube
channel in this session we are going to
discuss an introduction to data
structures but before we begin let me
tell you guys that we have daily updates
on multiple technologies so if you are a
tech geek in a continuous hunt for
latest technological trends then
consider getting subscribed to our
youtube channel and don't forget to hit
that bell icon to never miss an update
from simply learn so without any further
ado let's get started with the agenda
for today's session
first we look at the definition of data
structures after that we will understand
why we need data structures later we
will discuss the different types of data
structures finally we will look at the
importance of data structures hope i
made myself clear with the agenda now
let's get started with our first concept
that is what are data structures data is
an information that has been translated
into a form that is efficient to
movement or processing in computing
as it relates to trades computers and
transmission media data is an
information that has been converted into
binary digital form the term raw data
refers to the data in its most basic
digital format after defining data let's
look at what data structure entails a
data structure is a data organization
management and storage format in
computer science that allows for
efficient access and modification or a
data structure is an algebraic structure
about data that contains a collection of
data values their relationships and
their functions or operations that can
be applied to the data
we will now understand why exactly we
need data structures now that we have
already defined what is a data structure
so let us have a look at some of the
data structure characteristics the first
one is each data structure allows data
to be stored differently following that
the data structure allows for more
efficient data search and retrieval then
specific data structures are chosen to
solve specific problems last but not the
least it enables the management of large
amounts of data such as large databases
and indexing services such as hash
tables
let us now look at some real-world
examples of data structures
first and the foremost we have the
dictionary assume that we're looking for
the word simply learn in the dictionary
and we know it begins with the letter s
so we can search for this word beginning
with the letter s and then this is an
example of array data structure as a
result this dictionary can also function
like an array data structure
following by that we have a music player
example if you have a playlist with
three songs the second song will play
after the first and the third will play
after the second so these will be played
without any interruption because all
these three songs are linked with each
other using linkless type of data
structure so followed by linked list the
next example we have is the data
structures
the stack of books analogy is a perfect
example of the real-time working of the
stack data structure subsequent to that
assume there is a line of people at a
ticket window and the person who comes
first gets the ticket
this particular movie window queue is an
example for the real time implementation
of queue data structure
last but not the least google maps
google map is the graph data structure
in which all the cities and states are
connected if we want to go from one
place to another there may be many ways
to do so so we can use some algorithms
to find the shortest path
as a result the google map is a perfect
example for the graph data structure
working analogy
following that we will look at some
different types of data structures in
this tutorial
so the first type is the linear data
structure
the elements in the linear data
structure are arranged subsequently one
after the other they are simple to
implement because the elements are
arranged in specific order followed by
the first type the second type is the
non-linear data structure which we will
be discussing a bit later
so in linear data structures we have
four different types the first one is
the array data structure memory elements
are arranged in a continuous order in
arrays
and arrays elements are of same type the
software program also determines the
type of elements that can be stored in
arrays so followed by arrays we have
linked list link lists are completely
similar to data structures data elements
in linked list data structure are linked
together by a series of nodes
furthermore each node contains the data
items as well as the address to the next
node
the third data structure is the stack
data structure elements in a stacked
data structure are stored using lifo
principle in other words the last
element
stored in the stack is remote first in
stack operations can only be performed
in one end namely the top
and the last data structure is the queue
data structure
unlike stack queue data structure
operates in the fifo principle which
states that the first element stored in
the queue is remote first in a queue
insertion and deletion are carried out
from opposite ends
now we will discuss the second type of
data structures which are the non-linear
data structures
the non-linear data structure is the
second type of data structure non-linear
data structures do not have elements in
any order as opposed to the linear data
structures instead they are arranged in
hierarchical order with one element
connected to one or more others
so the first one in the non-linear data
structures is the tree data structure a
tree data structure is built using nodes
and edges each element in the tree data
structure is called as node or vertex
each vertex or node is connected to the
other nodes or other vertices using
edges and the second one in the list is
the graph data structure a graph data
structure is completely like a tree data
structure
it also has the vertices and edges each
vertex in a graph data structure is
connected using edges the only
difference between a tree and graph is
that in tree you can have n number of
vertices but in graph you will have only
two vertices
after discussing the graph data
structure we will move ahead into the
last segment of this tutorial that is
importance of data structures so the
first one data structures are widely
used in almost every aspect of computer
science both for simple and complex
computations
next data structures are used in all
areas of computer science including
artificial intelligence graphics big
data operating systems and much more
after that the data structures are an
essential component of many computer
algorithms because they allow
programmers to manage data efficiently
lastly a proper data structure of
selection can improve the efficiency of
a computer program or algorithm hi
everyone i am weber kandalwal and i
welcome you all to simply learn's
youtube channel
in this session we will learn about
pointers
we shall begin our session by learning
what a pointer is and its syntax
after that we will learn about different
ways to access variables
then we will discuss types of pointers
then we will dive into its use cases we
will discuss about point arithmetics
pointer to a pointer array of pointers
and some concepts like call by value and
call by reference
post that we will discuss its advantages
and disadvantages
finally we will take a glance at what is
our key takeaways from this session
but before we begin make sure you have
subscribed to our youtube channel and
clicked on the bell icon so you never
miss an update from simply learn
so without any further ado let's get
started with what are pointers
a pointer is a variable that points to
an address of another variable
it is declared using a star symbol also
called asterisk
and then we allocate a memory of a
variable to it
we can access a variable's address using
the ampersand symbol in the same manner
as the pointer declaration let's write a
code
we will declare a variable a equals 5.
and a pointer ptr
then we will assign this variable is
value to pointer ptr
now let's write a print statement to
directly access the variables value
using variable name
let's write another print statement to
print the value of a using pointer
let's try and execute this program
as you can see we have successfully
accessed variables value using both
variable name and pointers
let's get back to our slides
now let's discuss different types of
pointers
first of null pointer
void pointer
while pointer
and dangling pointer
let's discuss these in details
first up null pointer
it is a kind of pointer that points to a
null memory
as you can see in the figure here is a
pointer which is pointing to a null
memory
to get a better understanding let's try
a simple program in the code editor
let's write a code first we will declare
a pointer where
and we will assign its value to null
now let's try to print the statement
let's execute this
as you can see since this pointer points
to a null or nothing that's why it
doesn't print anything
let's get back to our slides next
void pointer when a pointer is created
with data type void then this pointer is
called void pointer
if we want to print the variable's value
then we have to typecast this pointer to
avoid any error
for better understanding let's get back
to the code editor and try it with a
simple code first we will declare an
integer variable a is equals to 5
and avoid pointer ptr
now we will assign address of a to
pointer ptr
let's write a print statement to print
this pointer
let's run this program
as you can see we are getting an error
that's because we can't print a void
variable
in this we have to typecast this
variable to integer let's do this
we can typecast a variable like this
now let's print
this as you can see we can print it now
let's get back to our slides
next while pointer
when we create a pointer but don't
initialize it by assigning any memory to
it then this kind of pointer is called
while pointer
these pointers can be very tricky they
can even cause a program failure or a
segmentation fault
let's get back to the correlator and try
it with a simple code
first let's declare a pointer ptr
but they will not assign it with any
address
let's write a print statement to print
it this time we will directly print it
let's execute this
as you can see we are not getting any
results because there is no value
assigned to it sometimes it may even
show segmentation error
let's get back to our slides
next dangling pointer
let's suppose there is a pointer p which
is pointing at a variable
now if we dialocate this memory using a
free function
then this pointer will point at a free
space or a non-existing memory
then this pointer will become a dangling
pointer to get a better understanding of
this pointer let's try it with a simple
code
let's declare a pointer ptr
here we will dynamically allocate memory
using a mail of function
to do this we will put int star
in a bracket
then
bylock function
and in another bracket we will put
memory size to be allocated
now let's declare a variable a
and assign its address to the pointer
now to make it a dangling pointer we
have to diallocate the memory of this
pointer
we will use free function for that
now let's write a print statement to
print this pointer
let's execute it
as you can see since we have diallocated
its memory that's why it is pointing to
nothing hence it doesn't print anything
let's get back to our slides
till now we have discussed pointers ways
to access variables and types of
pointers
now let's talk about use cases of
we will talk about point to arithmetics
pointer to pointer array of pointers
call by value and call by reference
now let's dive right into it let's talk
about point arithmetics we can use four
arithmetic operations on pointers
increment decrement
addition or subtraction of an integer
from a pointer
since pointer operates on addresses it
only makes sense if we apply pointer
arithmetics on sequential data
structures like arrays or strings
let's discuss them in detail
first up increment
if we apply this operator
on a pointer then it will shift this
pointer's address to its sequential
successor
as you can see in the figure as we
increment the pointer's value we shift
to the next index of the array
let's get back to the code editor and
try it with a simple program
let's declare an array of size 3.
let's give them some value
we will then declare a pointer
and assign it to the arrays first
element
now let's write a for loop to traverse
this array
in this for loop we will increment a
pointer's value
and
print this pointer's value to traverse
this array
let's try and execute this program
as you can see we have traversed this
complete error
let's get back to our slides
next decrement
if this operator is applied on a pointer
it will shift this pointer's address to
its sequential predecessor
as you can see in the figure as we
decrement this pointer we also shift to
array's previous index
let's get back to the code editor and
try to implement it let's declare an
array of size 3
and assign it some values
now let's declare a pointer
and assign array's last elements address
to it
now let's write a for loop
to traverse this array
in this for loop we will decrement the
pointer's value
also we will keep printing this pointers
value to travel this array
let's try and execute this program
as you can see we have traversed this
complete array from the back
let's get back to our slides
next the addition of an integer to a
pointer
if this operator is applied on a pointer
it will leak forward accordingly
if the integer is 2 and our pointer
points at the first element then the
pointer will sequentially skip one
element and shift to the next element
let's implement it in the code editor
let's declare an array of size 7
and assign them some value
then declare a pointer
and assign it to the array's first
element
now let's take an integer n to add in
the pointer
now let's write a for loop to traverse
this array
in this for loop we will increment the
pointer's value with integer n
and we will keep printing the pointer
ptr value
let's execute this code
as you can see we have traversed this
complete array skipping one element at a
time
since we have skipped three elements
that's why we are getting last three
values as garbage values
let's get back to our slides
next
subtraction of an integer from a pointer
if this operator is applied on a pointer
then accordingly it will leap backward
if the integer is 2 and our pointer
points at the last element
then the pointer will skip one element
and shift to the previous element
let's try and implement it in the code
editor
first let's declare an array of size 7
and assign it some values
and declare a pointer ptr
and assign it to the array's last
element
now let's take an integer n to subtract
from the pointer
now let's write a for loop to traverse
this array
[Music]
in this for loop we will decrement the
pointer's value with integer n
also we will write an print statement to
print this pdr's value
now let's try and execute this program
as you can see we have traversed this
complete array from back skipping one
element at a time
since we have skipped three elements
that's why we are getting last three
values as garbage values
let's get back to our slides
let's talk about precedence of these
operators
operator asterisk and ampersand have the
same priority as the unary operator
increment and decrement
these operators are evaluated from right
to left
let's understand this concept with an
example
suppose if a pointer p points to a
variable x
then we can swap x with pointer p in
that expression
in the first row we have y is equals to
x plus one which means we are storing an
incremented value of x in y similarly if
we replace x with a pointer p we can
store incremented value of pointer in y
in row 2 and row 3 we are incrementing x
and storing incremented value in x
itself
we can do this with pointers as well
in row 4 we are attempting to execute
pre-increment with a pointer p
in row 5 we are attempting to execute
post increment with pointer p
here we have to put star p in braces
because these operators are evaluated
from right to left so to give more
priority to pointer p we have to use
braces as they have highest priority
let's talk about another use case
pointer to pointer
basically in this situation a pointer
will point at a variable via another
pointer
we declare it with two statistics symbol
let's discuss it with an example
suppose a pointer 1 points to a variable
and another pointer 2 points to that
pointer 1.
this way pointer 2 will indirectly be
pointing to the variable
let's go to the code editor and try
implementing it
first we will declare a variable where
a pointer ptr1
and a pointer to this pointer ptr2
then we will assign this variable wires
address to ptr1
and
ptr1s address to ptr2
now we will write a print statement to
print variable var
ptr1 and ptr2
now let's try and execute this program
as you can see
ptr1 and ptr2 shows variable vars value
as ptr2 is pointing to ptr1 and ptr1 is
pointing to that variable
so indirectly ptr2 points to the
variable var
thus it prints the variable's value
let's get back to our slides
let's discuss the area of pointers
as the name suggests it is an array that
has all its elements as pointers
these pointers can be pointing at
another array it is declared as an array
with asterisk symbol
let's discuss it with the program
first we will declare an array a of size
3.
then we will declare
a pointer array ptr of size 3.
now we will write a for loop to assign
a's elements address to ptr's element
then we will write another for loop to
traverse ptr and print its element
let's try and execute this program
as you can see it prints the value of
array a's elements because array ptr's
elements are pointing to array age
elements
let's get back to our slides
next
call by value
we don't use pointers in this concept
but it is very important to understand
this concept to get better understanding
of the next topic call by reference
in call by value we call a function and
directly pass the variables value as
parameters
in this situation a copy of those
variable is created and get passed into
a function as parameters
if we modify these parameters it will
not affect actual variables rather these
copies will get deleted as soon as the
function body ends
let's try implementing it in the code
editor
let's write a code
first we will declare a variable x
equals to 100
then we will write a function called to
function func
with argument x
next we will write a print statement to
check if any changes happen due to the
function
now let's write definition for this
we will take a void function
with argument
as x
in this first we will set x equals to
200.
and then we will write a print statement
to print this value
let's try and execute this program
as you can see here when we get back to
the main block from function its value
again reverted back to 10
because in call by value program we only
pass variables copy into the function
not the actual variables
let's get back to our slides
next
call by reference
in this if we call a function but this
time we pass the variables address as
parameters
then in this situation actual variables
will get passed into the function as
parameters
if we modify these parameters it will
modify the actual variables even outside
the function scope
let's try implementing it in the code
editor
first we will declare a variable int x
equals to hundred
next we will write a function call for
function func
with argument as address of x
then we will write a print statement to
check if any changes happen due to the
function
now let's write definition for this
it will be a void function
with argument as pointer x
in this we will first set x equals to
then we will write a print statement to
print this value of x
now let's try and execute this program
as you can see this time variable access
value didn't revert to hundred that's
because in call by reference we pass
actual variables address to functions so
it will modify them as well
let's get back to our slides
during the course of this video we have
learnt a lot about pointers let's
discuss some advantages of the pointers
first up pointers are useful to access a
memory location pointers are also an
effective way to access the array
elements
pointers are used for the dynamic memory
allocation and its distribution pointers
are also used to build complex data
structures like linked list graph tree
stack queue etc
now let's talk about some disadvantages
as well first up pointers are difficult
to understand so a programmer needs to
be careful while handling them
they might raise some errors like
segmentation error or access some
unrequired memory and cause program
failure
if a pointer is pointing to an incorrect
value then it might corrupt memory
pointers may also cause memory leakage
also pointers are slower than variables
at last let's sum up what we have
learned in this session with key
takeaways
first up a pointer is simply a storage
location for a data in a memory
we can use pointers to traverse array
more efficiently
we can also use function pointers to
call a function dynamically
we can perform arithmetic operations on
pointers as well
when we define an array of pointers its
elements can also points to function
making it easier to call different
function at once hope you guys found it
informative and helpful
hey everyone welcome to simply learn's
youtube channel in this session we will
learn about erase in data structure but
before we begin make sure that you have
subscribed to our youtube channel and
don't forget to hit that bell icon to
never miss an update from simply learn
now let's get started with the agenda
for today's discussion
so at first we will learn why exactly we
need arrays followed by that we will
understand what is an array then the
types of arrays next we have the
declaration of arrays followed by that
we will learn how to initialize an array
then access the elements in an array
after that we will understand the basic
operations that can be performed on
arrays and to wind up the session we
have the advantages and disadvantages of
aries at the end we'll have some key
takeaways i hope i made myself clear
with the agenda now let's begin with the
first topic that is why did we actually
need an array
so to understand this let's go through a
simple concept
let us imagine that we have some data
and the data is related to students
right so if we wanted to store the marks
of individual students then we had to
declare a variable for each of the
student
so you can see we have student 1 student
2 student 3 4 and 5 and their individual
scores so the score 1 is assigned to
student 1 and so on with student 5 being
assigned to score 5.
so in the real time this might be a
little clumsy we have here just 5
students so that is ok but what if we
had 500 students or 5 000 students right
that might be an issue there we have to
create some 500 or 5 000 variables and
it would be a little tough to handle
that right even if we wanted to apply
some operations collectively on all the
variables that might be a little tedious
so what if we had one variable which
could store all the five students or 500
students or 5 000 students all together
and make it really easy for us to apply
some operations collectively on all the
students right this sounds a little bit
logical
so similarly we do have a data structure
which can do that which can collectively
store all the data elements in it as a
single variable and it will also help us
to apply the operations which are
logical or mathematical on all the
variables and their values together as a
whole so that is the purpose why we had
created arrays that is the purpose why
we needed arrays
so far we have understood what was the
necessity for arrays now we will
understand what exactly are aries
so basically an array is a linear data
structure that stores the elements in a
sequential manner one after the other
and when you declare an array the
variables will be stored one besides the
other that is adjacent to each other in
a sequential order now let us understand
how the array is represented by the
compiler
now the next part that is the memory
representation of aries
now let us imagine that we have declared
an array which stores character type
data and another important point to
remember about r is when you declare an
array it stores only a single data type
typed elements only for example here we
have declared a character type array
right so we cannot store integer type
data or flow type data in it we only
have to save character type array or
character type elements in this
particular array
so now let us imagine that we have
created an array which is of character
data type and these are the elements
which are a r r a y now how does the
compiler represent it in the form of
memory
so when you create an array these are
formed that is the index values and the
address so basically compiler will
select a block of memory and it has
addresses to that block and it can be
anything right here we have 11 12 13 14
and 15 and in real time it might be a
thousand one thousand two thousand three
thousand four thousand five the main
motto is assign a sequential block of
memory and this is the array and the
elements are a r r a y and this
particular one which is the last one is
the index of the array that is the
position of the array for user so using
this index you can access the elements
in the array more on that in the
accessing part
so let us imagine that we wanted to
access the element r so how to access it
we might not know the address right in
that instance we will use the index this
is for our reference so we will tell i
want the element from array index number
2 and then we'll have the arr
our element so in the practical form
this is how we use the index
now let's continue with the lower bound
and the upper bound so the first initial
location is called as the lower bound
and at the last or the max value of the
array is called as the upper bound now
let us jump into the next topic where we
will understand the different types of
arrays
so these are the different types of
one dimensional arrays and
multi-dimensional arrays
in multi-dimensional arrays we have two
more types that is two-dimensional
arrays and three-dimensional arrays so
how are arrays different from each other
right so the first one will deal with
the first one that is the
one-dimensional array now how is an
array declared as one-dimensional for
that we need subscript
so one dimensional array requires only
one subscript to specify the number of
elements in an array so how is it
actually represented so here you can see
an example right on my screen
so here is how a one dimensional array
looks like so here we have the data type
that is integer data type and marks is
the name of the array and this is the
size of the array and here the elements
will be stored
and here it is the index value of the
array and remember the index value of
array always starts from zero in the
previous example that was only for basic
understanding so i just started that
with one
in the practical way the array index
always starts from zero
so followed by the one dimensional array
we will deal with the multi-dimensional
arrays in that we have the following
the first one is the two-dimensional
array and the second one is the
three-dimensional array
in the multi-dimensional arrays we
require more than one subscript in the
previous example we had one dimensional
array so the subscript is just 1 that is
10 columns
right so we just had one single row and
10 different columns but in the
multi-dimensional arrays we need
multiple rows and multiple columns
right so we need two subscripts for two
dimensional array and more than two
subscripts for three dimensional arrays
so first we have the two dimensional
arrays
the 2d array is organized in the form of
a matrix which can be represented as a
collection of rows and columns so here
is the example
as you can see on my screen we have
three columns and three rows
and we have two subscripts that define
the number of rows and the number of
columns and the elements in each and
every row so the 1 2 3 confines the
first row 4 5 6 confines the second row
and 7 8 9 will be the third row
now similarly we have three dimensional
arrays a 3d array is a collection of 2d
arrays which consists of three
subscripts block size row size and
column size
so here we have an example for that
so we have three subscripts that is the
first one is block size the second one
is the row number and the third one is
column number
so this happens to be the first block
this happens to be the second block and
this is how a three-dimensional array
can be represented
now we have the next stage where we will
understand how to declare the arrays and
the syntax is right on my screen you
need to specify the data type of the
array which is integer float or
character any selection which you make
followed by that you need to select an
array name for your array and inside
that you need to declare the array size
and sometimes you can also eliminate the
array size if you wanted to you know
have a dynamic array
and here is an example for that
you have integer data type name of the
array is example and the array size is
6.
so the compiler will allocate continuous
memory block of six integer type blocks
so
these are the few more methods to
initialize the array
so here you can see integer data type
array name is a element size is 5 and we
have 5 elements
the method 2 is remember i have said you
can eliminate the size of the array
right so here you can use this way as
well integer data type array name a and
no size here and you can directly
declare the elements
and the method third so here you have
the name of the array size of the array
and you are allocating the elements to
the individual memory locations this is
also another method to initialize array
and method four is using a forum you can
just initialize a for loop and the i
value will be stored in the array
locations starting from zero
now let us understand how to access the
elements in an array
so to access the elements in an array
you need to specify the name of the
array and memory block where you have
that element that you want to access so
here we have an example
which is integer data type name of the
array is xyz and the element we wanted
to access is 5. so here we have an
example that is integer type array array
name is xyz and it has the size 5
and now we wanted to access the first
element in an array that can be done
using the first index that is xyz of 0
index that is the first element and
accessing the second element and so on
xyz of one will be the second element
xyz of two three four will be the third
and fourth and fifth elements
now let us understand some basic
operations that can be performed on the
array elements
so the following are the operations that
can be performed on the array elements
that is the traversal insertion deletion
searching and sorting
now let us get into practical mode and
try to execute some examples based on
traversal of the array insertion of an
element into the array deletion of an
element from an array searching for an
element in an array and sorting the
complete array so at first we'll carry
out the traversal operation so here we
have an array that is a of 5 and the
elements are 1 2 3 4 and 5. now we're
going to use a for loop to traverse
through this array and print all the
elements sequentially now let us execute
this code and see the output
so as you can see the code got
successfully executed and the elements
that is 1 2 3 4 and 5 from the array a
are printed sequentially
now moving ahead we'll try to execute
some examples based on insertion of
element into the array so on my screen
you can see an example for inserting an
element into the array at the starting
position of the array now let us try to
execute this code and see the output
don't worry about the codes these code
documents will be attached in the
description box below and you will be
able to have an access to it and run
these codes in your personal laptop and
get a better learning experience
now you can see the code got
successfully executed and now it is
asking for the size of the array let's
declare it as 5
and now let's enter the elements into
the array
now it is asking for the element to be
added at the beginning of the array now
we have 2 3 4 5 and 6 existing in the
array let's add the first element 1
and there you go the resultant array is
1 2 3 4 5 and 6. the element which we
added at the ending which is 1 is
supposed to be in the first or the
beginning part of the array which is
here at at the first index location as
planned
now let's get started with another
example on the insertion
now let's try to insert an element at
any given location as per the user's
choice so as you can see we have a
program on my screen and running this
program must help us to insert an
element into any given location of the
array
now let's try to quickly run this
program and see the
so there you go enter the elements into
the array
let's enter 1 3
let's try to run this program and see
the output
so there you go the program got
successfully executed and now the output
is asking for us to tell it the number
of elements in an array now let's say
four elements
so now let's enter the four elements
one
three
four five and six
okay
so the four elements which is one three
four five are been inserted now it is
asking for the location where you want
to insert the element now let us insert
it in the second location
now let us set the value as 2 and there
you go the resultant array is 1 2 3 4
and 5 and the element which is 2 was
supposed to be added in the second
location and it has been successfully
added now let's try to execute another
example based on insertion where you
will try to insert the element in the
last position
now this program on my screen will help
us to add an element at the end of the
array let's quickly run this program
now it is asking for us to enter the
five elements of the array let's enter
that
now it is asking to enter the element to
be inserted now let us enter the element
and this element should be added at the
end location as discussed the resultant
array is one three 5 7 9 and 11.
now let's continue with the deletion
operation
now the program on my screen is an
example for deleting an element from the
beginning position of an array now the
program got successfully executed and
it's asking for us to enter the size of
the array let's enter the size as 5
and now let's enter the elements of the
array that is 1
2 3
and 5.
now the element from the first location
that is 1 has been deleted and the
resultant array is 2 3 4 and 5. now the
code on my screen will help you to
eliminate the element from the ending
location of an array now let's try to
quickly run this program and say the
so you can see that the program is
successfully run and it is asking for us
to enter the size of the array let's
enter four
now let's enter the elements of the
array that is one two three and four
now after eliminating the last element
from the array that is 4 we have the
resultant array that is 1 2 and 3.
now a little over for you guys let's try
to execute an example for deleting an
element from any location of an array
this will be a homework now don't worry
try on your own and if you don't get
that you can refer to the comment
sections below where you have the code
document attached in the description box
and you can refer to it
now let's continue with the next
operation where we will search for a
given element in the array
so you can see that on my screen we have
an example which will help us to sort
the elements in an array let's quickly
run this
so there you go the program got
successfully executed and now it's
asking for the array size let's enter 5
and now let's enter the elements in a
random order
[Music]
now the resultant array should be sorted
so there you go the array after being
sort is it's 2 3 5 14 and 21 so there
you go the array got sorted so now we
have finished our practical session
let's have a quick overview again
so traversal in an area is a process of
visiting each element once traversal can
be done by various means that is by
counting the array elements printing the
values sorted in the arrays
and sum of all elements present in the
array and many more
so this is how we traverse our array
from the first location to the last
location again the insertion operation
insertion in an array is the process of
including one or more elements in an
array and it can be done at the
beginning at the end and at any given
index of an array which we executed for
all the three types of examples
now next we have the deletion operation
so deletion operation or deletion of an
element is a process of removing a
desired element and reorganizing the
array and it can be done at the
beginning at the end and at any given
index so we have executed the example
for at the beginning and at the end and
the homework was at the given index
don't worry if you don't figure it out
you can always refer to the example
document which is mentioned in the
description box below
now the search operation searching is a
process of finding a given value in the
list of values and it decides whether
the search key is present in the array
or not and we have executed an example
on that
and again the sort operation where we
will sort the given array
if the given array is not in the default
order or in a given order that is
ascending or descending then we can sort
the order of the array by the user's
choice given it is ascending order or
descending order
now in the next section of the tutorial
we will discuss the advantages of using
arrays
so the first one is array stores
multiple elements of same data type with
same name
next one elements in an array can be
accessed randomly using just the index
number
array memory is predefined so there is
no extra memory loss
array avoids memory overflow and finally
2d arrays can represent the tabular form
of data in a very efficient way
now let us also have a look on some of
the disadvantages of using arrays
the first one the number of elements in
an array should be always predefined so
there is no chance that you can add some
extra element in the last moment
array is static in nature so its size
cannot be varied after declaration
what if consider that you wanted to
store 10 student data in one array and
you end up having just seven students so
the remaining three is a waste right so
you are wasting memory there that's the
problem and insertion and deletion
operations in an array is quite
difficult as the array stores elements
in a continuous form
and finally allocating excess memory
then required mainly to memory wastage
now we have the final key takeaways of
the arrays
so we discussed why do we need arrays
then we discussed what are all is
followed by that we discussed types of
arrays next we had a declaration of
arrays accessing elements from an array
initializing the arrays and basic
operations on array that is the
practical demo part and finally we have
discussed the advantages and
disadvantages of using an array now with
that we have come to an end of this
tutorial hello everyone welcome to
simply learn's youtube channel today in
this session we will learn about two
dimensional arrays but before we begin
make sure that you have subscribed to
our youtube channel and don't forget to
hit that bell icon to never miss an
update from simply learn
so without further ado let's get started
with the agenda for today's session
we will begin with learning what are two
dimensional arrays we will then
understand the need for two dimensional
arrays followed by that we will learn
the syntax of two dimensional arrays
advancing ahead we will visualize two
dimensional arrays and finally we will
enter into our hands-on part where we
will practically see how to initialize a
two-dimensional array and also learn how
to access elements in it and next we
will try to print the elements in a
two-dimensional area i hope i made
myself clear with the agenda so let's
get started with our first topic that is
what are arrays
so we will see a brief definition of
arrays
the array is a data structure that
stores elements of the same data type in
a sequential order
two dimensional arrays are considered as
an array of arrays
two-dimensional arrays represent the
information in the form of rows and
columns which is completely similar to a
tabular form of data following by the
definition and briefing of the
two-dimensional arrays
we will understand the need for two
dimensional arrays
so the main advantage of using a two
dimensional array is the elements can be
represented in the form of a matrix that
is rows and columns
using two dimensional arrays we can
initialize access and print multiple
elements in the matrix form by just
running one single code segment
you can see an example right on my
screen here this is an example of marks
list suppose a class has three subjects
namely english science and maths
we have four students and we wanted to
represent the data in the form of a
database so here the marks of the four
students can be represented using two
dimensional arrays
now we will see the syntax of a two
dimensional array so here the syntax
at first we need the data type the data
type can be integer character float
string etc then we have the name for the
two-dimensional array and later we can
have two subscripts which represent two
dimensions that is the rows and columns
the first subscript defines the number
of rows and the second subscript defines
the number of columns and note that the
column number can never be null
at the end we have a semicolon to
terminate the syntax
and here we have some examples of two
dimensional arrays so in the first
example we have the name of the two
dimensional array and we have
three rows and four columns
and followed by that we have another
example which is of character data type
and the name of the array is names and
we have 7 rows and 15 columns
next we will see how to visualize two
dimensional arrays
we read earlier that two dimensional
arrays are a collection of rows and
columns let's see an example of two
dimensional array
we will consider an array with 6 rows
and 4 columns
as you can see on my screen we have
integer type array and the name of the
array is array and we have 6 rows and 4
columns
the product of rows and columns will
give us the total number of elements
present in a two dimensional array
in the current example we have six rows
and four columns and the product is 24
so we must have 24 elements in this
array
next we will see how to initialize two
dimensional arrays
so there are two ways to initialize a
two-dimensional array so in the first
method we declare the elements in the
set of curly brackets
this array consists of three rows and
three columns
note that the index always starts from
zero here we have three rows it means
the row starts with 0 and ends with 2
the same goes for the column but
sometimes this method might be a little
confusing so we have a better method the
advantage of this method is clarity
we can visualize all the elements with
better clarity compared to the previous
method so the first three elements are
and 1.
they are present in the first row
and in the second row we have 144 70 and
50. they comprise the second row and
finally the third row in which the
elements are 10 12 and 78
so far we have learnt how to visualize
and initialize a two dimensional array
so we have done it by using the index
values that is the row index and the
column index so the row index value was
three and the column index value was
three for accessing an element in the
two-dimensional array we need to pass
the name of the two-dimensional array
followed by the row index value and the
column index value for example let us
assume that we wanted to access the
element 9 for doing so we will pass the
name of the array followed by the row
index value and the column index value
as shown below that is end first zero
comma zero
and an important point here is indexing
always starts with zero
we will now start printing the two
dimensional arrays
so to print a two-dimensional array we
will be using two nested for loops
so to understand the process of printing
the two-dimensional array let's get back
to the practical mode and we will work
on a code
so on my screen you can see an example
for two dimensional array so here we
have declared an array with the name
first and we have three rows and three
columns and inside that the first row of
elements is 961 and the second row of
elements is 144 70 and 50 and the third
row of elements is 10 12 and 78
followed by that we have two counter
variables which are i and j
so we are using the first counter
variable i in the order for loop and the
second counter variable j in the second
in the form
and inside the inner follow we have a
print statement which is used to print
the elements in the array
now
let us try to execute this code and see
the output
so you can see the code got successfully
compiled and we have our elements here
which is 961 144 70 50 10 12 and 78 now
let us understand the logic
so here we have declared the counter
variable as 0 and the condition is i
should be less than 3 which is true so
the control will enter into the second
inner for loop here we have j is equals
to 0 and j should be less than 3 which
is true so here the condition or the
statement
is valid and it will print the first
element 9. followed by that j will be
incremented again j is now equals to 1
and j is less than 3 so again we'll
print the second element 6.
again j value will be incremented to 2
so 2 is less than 3 then we will print
the third element that is
1.
now when you increment the value of j
from 2 to 3 the condition will fail
because 3 cannot be less than 3. so the
control will enter into the outer for
loop here we have i value is equals to 0
which will be incremented to 1.
so 1 is less than 3 again the control
will enter the inner for loop here again
we will check for j is equals to 0 which
is true so we will print the second row
of elements that is 144 70 50 in the
same way how we printed the first row
right so j will be equals to 0 so then
we'll print the first element so j will
be incremented to
1 and 1 is less than 3 then we will
print the second element that is 70 and
again j will be incremented to 2.
and 2 is less than 3 so we will print
the third element that is 50 in the
second row
and again j will be incremented to 3 now
the compilation of the condition will
result in false so it will exit the
second follow-up and but it will come
back to the first outer for loop now the
value of i will be incremented to 2 so 2
is less than 3 the control will enter
into the inner for loop again then we
will print the third row of elements
that is 10 12 and 78 in the same way how
we printed the first row and the second
row
after printing the third row the
condition will fail when j value is
incremented to 3 and it will enter the
order for loop here the i value will be
incremented again from 2 to 3 and the
condition fails now the overall control
will come out of both the for loops and
it will terminate here
so that's how we got 9 6 1 44 70 50 10
12 and 78 so with that we have come to
the conclusion and so far we have
learned the following things
what are two dimensional arrays why we
need two dimensional arrays syntax of 2d
arrays visualizing 2d arrays
initializing 2d arrays accessing 2d
elements and finally print the elements
of two dimensional arrays so with that
we have come to an end of this tutorial
hey everyone i am rabbi khandewal and i
welcome you all to simply learns youtube
channel in this session we will learn
everything about linked list we shall
begin our session by learning what the
linked list is and why do we need them
then we will try to implement it in the
code editor
then we will discuss different types of
linked list
then
we will learn various operation that we
can perform on linked list
post that we will discuss some
advantages and disadvantages of the
linked list finally we will take a
glance at what are the final key
takeaways from this session
but before we begin make sure you have
subscribed to our youtube channel and
clicked on the bell icon so you never
miss an update from simply learn's
youtube channel so without any further
ado let's get started with what is
linked list
a linked list is a linear data structure
made up of nodes these nodes consist of
two parts
data and reference to another pointer
typically a linked list starts with a
head node which goes all the way up to
the last node which is called tail
next let's discuss why do we need linked
list
a linked list is a linear data structure
like arrays but an array can only offer
a fixed size whereas a linked list can
dynamically increase its size
also operations like insertion and
deletion are much easier in a linked
list than in an array
now let's try to implement the linked
list in the code editor
let's start by creating
a node to create a node we need a class
let's declare a class node
we will declare its member as public
the first member is end data
and the second member is node
pointer
next
now we will go into the main block and
initialize our first node
to initialize a node we need to use node
star
the node name had
equals to
run
similarly we will
create more nodes
and our last node
tail
now we will allocate these four nodes in
the heap
to do that we will use
a node name
equals to
new node
star
braces
now we will allocate all the nodes in
the same manner
now we will assign data to our first
node
to access the member of the node class
we will use error formation
then we will use data
equals to
let's give it a value as 2.
now we will link this first node with
that second node
to do that we will use
head
same error formation
and next
which will be equals to
our
n1 node
and now we have
created our first complete node
now let's create other nodes as well
and one arrow
data
is equals to
let's give it three
and one arrow
next is equals to and two
and two arrow
data
is equals to
five
and two arrow
next
to arrow
next is equals to
tail
now
tail is equal still arrow data
equals to 7
and
tail
arrow
next
is given
null
now let's call up function to print this
list we will give head as the argument
as
we can only traverse a linked list from
its head
let's write a definition for this print
list function
this function will be a void function
argument is
not star
ah
we will use while loop to traverse this
linked list
we will give it
it condition
if a is not equals to
null
then
see out
is
a data
and l
now we will change
our cursor
from the current node to the next node
to do that we will use
a is equals to a arrow next
now let's try to execute this code
as you can see we have traversed our
complete linked list
now let's get back to our slides
now let's discuss different types of
linked list
the first of single link list
next is the doubly linked list
the circular linked list and finally we
have the circular doubly linked list
let's discuss each one of these in
details
first up single linked list it is a
unidirectional linked list
while using the sinclair link list we
can only traverse it in one direction
that is from head node to the tail node
next up doubly link list
it is a bi-directional linked list we
can traverse it in both the directions
in this linked list the node has an
additional pointer that points to the
previous node
next up circular linked list
it is a regular linked list except for
its last node points to the head node
programmer needs to be careful while
traversing it or they might get stuck in
an infinite loop
next up the circular doubly linked list
it is a combination of doubly linked
list and a circular linked list
its last node points at the head node
and the previous pointer of the head
node points to the last node
it is also bi-directional linked list so
that we can traverse it in both
directions
we have now discussed the linked list
why do we need linked lists
and types of linked list now let's learn
about some operation we can apply on
linked list we can use majorly two
operations on linked list
first up insertion and deletion
we can perform these operations in three
different situations
first at the beginning at the last or at
a specific position after a node
next we will discuss these operations in
detail
first of insertion we will discuss first
insertion at the beginning
we have to give the first node's address
to the new nodes next pointer to execute
this
next up insertion at the end
we have to give the new nodes address
your last node's reference pointer
next up in session at a specific
position
to do this we will have to change the
reference address of the previous node
to the new node's address
and the new nodes reference pointer to
the next node's address
now let's discuss deletion
first up deletion at the beginning
we have to change the first node's
address to the null to execute this
next up deletion at the end
we have to change the second last node's
address to the null
next up deletion at a specific position
we will change the reference address of
the previous node to the next node's
address
we have learned a lot about linked list
during this session
now let's discuss some benefits of
linked list
first up a linked list is a dynamic data
structure
that is we can dynamically increase its
size
next it offers easy insertion and
deletion than other linear data
structures like arrays and string
since it can dynamically increase its
size resulting in no memory base stage
next
it is pretty handy in implementing
complex data structures like stacks and
queues etc
now let's talk about some disadvantages
as well
first up since the linked list is made
up of nodes it takes extra storage for
storing data and reference pointer
next the traversal in the linked list is
a bit harder than other data structure
reverse traversing is easy in doubly and
circular doubly linked list but since it
uses one extra pointer it takes extra
storage making it another limitation
at last let's sum up what we have
learned in this session with key
takeaways
first up we have recognized linked list
as a dynamic data structure
next a linked list offers faster
insertion and deletion operation
next
linked list traversal is hard because we
have to start from the head node every
time
finally a linked list is an asset in
implementing other data structures like
stacks and queues
and this was all for today's session hey
everyone i am weber khandeval and i
welcome you all to simply learn's
youtube channel
in this session we will talk about
single linked list
we shall begin our session by
introducing a single linked list
then we will try to implement it in the
code editor
after that
we will try various operations on them
like insertion and deletion
finally we will sum up what we have
learned from this session
but before we begin make sure you have
subscribed to our youtube channel and
clicked on the bell icon below so you
never miss an update from simply learn
so without any further ado let's get
started with introduction to single link
list
a single linked list is a linear data
structure made up of nodes
these nodes consist of two parts
data
and reference to the another pointer
these nodes can be traversed using
pointers
it starts from the head node all the way
up to
tail node
now let's try to implement the singly
linked list in the code editor start by
creating a node to create a node we need
a class
let's declare a class node
we will declare its member as public
the first member is end data
and the second member is node
pointer
next
now we will go into the main block and
initialize our first node
to initialize a node we need to use node
star
the node name had
equals to
similarly we will
create more nodes
and at last repeat and our last node
tail
now we will allocate these four nodes in
the heap
to do that we will use
a node name
equals to
new node
star
braces
now we will allocate all the nodes in
the same manner
now we will assign data to our first
node
to access the member of the node class
we will use error formation
then we will use data
equals to
let's give it a value as 2.
now we will link this first node with
our second node
to do that we will use
head
same error formation
and next
which will be equals to
are
n1 node
and now we have
created our first complete node
now let's create other nodes as well
and one arrow
data
is equals to
let's give it three
and one arrow
next
is equals to
and two
and two arrow
data
is equals to
five
and two arrow
next
to arrow
is equals to
tail
now
tail is equal still arrow data
equals to 7
and
tail
arrow
next
is given
null
now let's call up function to print this
list
we will give head as the argument
as
we can only traverse a linked list from
its head
let's write a definition for this print
list function
this function will be a void function
argument is
note star
a
we will use while loop to traverse this
linked list
we will give it
it condition
if a is not equals to
null
then
see
out is
a data
and l
now
we will change
now we will change
our cursor
from the current node to the next node
to do that we will use a is equals to a
arrow next
now let's try to execute this code
as you can see we have traversed our
complete linked list
now let's get back to our slides
we have now introduced the single link
list
now let's discuss some of the operations
we can apply on a linked list
first up insertion
we can perform insertion at three
different situations
like at the beginning at the last or at
a specific position after a node
next up deletion
similar to the insertion we can perform
it in three different situation as well
at the beginning at the last or at a
specific position after a
node
let's talk about them in detail first up
insertion at the beginning
to execute this we have to give first
node's address to the new node's next
pointer
next up insertion at the end
to execute this we have to give new
nodes address to the last node's next
address
next up insertion at a specific position
to execute this we will change the
previous node's reference address to the
new node's address
and the new node's reference pointer to
the next node address now let's try
these operations in a code editor as you
know a linked list is made up of node so
we should start by creating a node to
create a node we need a class
node
and we will define its members as public
print data
and
node pointer
next
now we will create a function to insert
a new node in front of the list
for this function as an argument we will
give the reference to the head of the
list
and integer dot new data
now in the definition we will allocate a
node
new node equals to
now we will put in the data in the new
node
we will use arrows to put to access the
data
to
new
now we will make the next of this new
node as head
now we will move the head to point to
the new node
now we will create another function to
insert a node after a specific position
as arguments we will give it
the address to the previous node
and
and the integer new data
we will first check
if the given previous node is null
it is we will print
given node
and not
and then we will return the function
otherwise
otherwise we will allocate a new node
and then we will enter the new data in
that
now we will make the next of the new
node as a next of the previous node
and then we will move the next of the
previous nodes
as new node
now we will write a function to insert a
node at the end of the list
as an argument we will give it
a node pointer to pointer
add
and integer new data
we will first allocate a new node
we will also create a last node
and give it
now we will put in the data in the new
node
since this new node is going to be the
last node so we will make its next as
null
now if the linked list is empty then
we'll make the new node as head
to check that we will use
if
star head
is equal to equals to null
if it is then we will do
star head
equals to new
node else
we will traverse it to the last node
while
last
next
null
last
is equals to
fast next
now we will change the next of the last
node as a new node
now we will write a function to print
this list
while
node is not null
yo
load
arrow
data
and then
and node
equals to
node
now we will write the code for the main
block
first we will define a head node
and mark it as null
now we will start using those functions
to make a linked list
first we will use append function
to add
six in it
next let's let's use another function
push
and add seven in it
now we will try to insert one at the
beginning
so we will use push again
comma 1
now let's try to insert 4 at the end
so far the list looks like 1 seven six
four null
now let's tr let's try to insert eight
after seven
to do that we will use insert
after
as argument we will use head next as 7
is present next to the head
comma
8.
now let's try to print this linked list
see out
created
yes
list
add
return
let's execute this
as you can see we have created the
linked list in the correct order
let's get back to our slides now let's
talk about deletion first up deletion at
the beginning
to execute this we have to change first
node's next address to null
next up deletion at the end
to execute this we have to change the
second last node's address to the null
next up deletion at the specific
position
we will change the previous node's
reference address to the next node's
address
now let's try these operations in a code
editor
we will start by creating a class
node
in this class we will declare the
members as public
print
data
and
the node pointer next
now to insert the data in the node
we will use
a function
push
as argument we will give pointer to
pointer node
header
and
integer new data
we will allocate a new node
we will give this new node the data as
new data
and
and new nodes next as head
now we will write a function to delete
the node
as argument we will give a node pointer
to pointer
head
and end key
now we will store head in a temp node
and we will create a node prev
as null
if head node itself holds the key to be
deleted we will use if
amp is not equals to
null
and
temp
data
is equals to equals to key
then head
equals to
and
next
now we will free the old node
else we will search for the key to be
deleted
while
amp
is not equals to
and
temp data
is not key
brev
equals to temp
and temp
will be hydrated to its next
if
the key is not present in the linked
list
then we will just return the function
else we will unlink the node from the
linked list
and
delete
now we will write a print list function
to print the list
its argument will be a node pointer node
while
a node is not null
layout
less than
node
data
and we will iterate this node
using node equals to
node
next
now we will move on to the main block
we will start with the empty list
node
star
head
equals to null
now we will add the element to this list
so push
ampersand
head
comma seven
next push
head comma
push
ampersand
comma
5.
next push
ampersand
head
comma
now see out
created
test
and listed
now we will use delete node function
delete
two
we will use argument as
ampersand head
comma
two
now
we will check
the linked list
so
of
two
print test
let's try and execute this
as you can see we have deleted the two
from the linked list
let's get back to our slides
at last let's sum up what we have
learned in this session first up we have
recognized singly linked list as dynamic
data structure
next up the single linked list offer
faster insertion and deletion operation
next
single linked lists are unidirectional
linked list that is you can only
traverse it in one direction
finally a single linked list is an asset
in implementing other data structures
like stacks and queues
and this was all for today's session hey
everyone i'm weber khandelwal and i
welcome you all to simply learns youtube
channel in this session we will talk
about wlinklist we shall begin our
session by introducing doubly linked
list
then we will try to implement it in the
code editor after that we will try
various operations on them like
insertion and deletion
finally we will sum up what we have
learned from this session
but before we begin make sure you have
subscribed to our youtube channel and
clicked on the bell icon so you never
miss an update from simply learn
so without any further ado let's get
started with an introduction to double a
a-link list
a w link list is a linear data structure
made up of nodes
this linked list is a bi-directional
linked list that is we can traverse it
in both direction
these nodes consist of three parts first
up data
reference to the next node
and reference to the previous node
now let's try to implement the wa link
list in the code editor
as you know a linked list is made up of
nodes so we will start by creating a
node to create a node we need a class
node
its members should be defined as public
in data
note pointer
next
and note pointer
rev
now we will write a function to insert a
node at the beginning of the doubly
linked list
void push
argument will be a node pointer to
pointer
add
and
end new data
now let's allocate a node
node star
new node
pulse
new
node
now let's put in the data into the new
since we are adding at the beginning its
previous is always null
now we will link the old list of the
nuno
now we will change the previous of the
head node to the new node
we will check if head is not null
then heads previous
is equals to
new node
now let's move the head to the point to
the new node
now let's write a function to print the
given double linked list
its argument will be a node
we will iterate it until the node is not
null
layout
node data
and and
node
equals to
node next
now let's write a code for the main
block
we will start with the empty list
now we will use a push function to push
values in the function
another push function
add
comma 3
push
function
ampersand
had
comma
push function
add
comma 7
now
p
interest
then we will call the print list
function
in the double linked list
let's execute this program
as you can see we have successfully
created our first doubly linked list
let's get back to our slides
we have now introduced doubly linked
list
now let's discuss some of the operations
we can perform on a doubly linked list
we can perform three operations on a
doubly linked list
first traversal
insertion
and deletion
we can perform a traversal in two ways a
normal traversal and reverse traversal
and we can perform insertion and
deletion in three different situations
at the beginning at the last and at a
specific position after a node
let's discuss these in detail
first up normal traversal
we can traverse the doubly linked list
using a next pointer starting from head
to all the way up to tail node
reverse traversal similar to the normal
traversal we will use previous pointer
we will start from the tail node to go
all the way up to head node
now let's try to traverse the doubly
linked list in the code editor
let's start by creating a class node
we will define its members as public
print data
node pointer
next
and node pointer
trip
now we will write a function to insert a
node at the beginning of the doubly
linked list
by push
its argument will be a node pointer to
pointer head
and integer new data
now we will allocate a node
new node
new
node parenthesis
now we will put in the data
since we are adding at the beginning so
its pref is always null
now we will link the old node to the new
node
now we will change the previous of the
head node to the new node
now we will move the head to the point
to the new node
now we will write a function to traverse
the linked list normally
voip
traverse
node pointer
loop
node
is not null
therefore
keyout
node
data
equals to node next
now we will write a function to reverse
traverse it
its argument will be a note pointer to
pointer
head
we will create a note tail
equals to head
while
else next
is not null
this loop is enabling us to reach to the
tail node so that we can traverse it
from back side
now
while loop
until tail
is not equals to
head
layout
data
then
prep
data
handle
this last c out statement is only
because we are not traversing till the
head pointer
now let's go to the main block
let's start with an empty list
node star
add
equals to null
now let us create a linked list to test
the function
so we will use push function
another push function
ampersand head
comma three
since we are inserting at the beginning
so the actual linked linked list looks
like
seven
five
three
now
we will print the original linked list
first see how
original
traverse
and
see
reverse traversal
first traversed
linked list
and then
now let's try and execute this program
as you can see we have traversed it in
the
normal way as well as the reversed way
let's get back to our slides
next up insertion at the beginning
we will create a node with the previous
pointer pointing to a null and the next
pointer pointing to the head node
then we will change the head node's
previous pointer to the new node and we
will change the new node to the head
node
next up insertion at the end
we have to give the new node's address
to the last node's next pointer and
change the new node's previous pointer
to the last node
next up insertion at a specific position
we will change the previous node's next
pointer to the new node and the new
node's previous pointer to the previous
node and the next pointer to the next
node and vice versa
now let's try these operations in a code
editor
we will start by creating a class
node
public
pointer
now we will write a function push
insert a note at the beginning of the
list
its argument is node pointer to pointer
head
into new data
we will first allocate a new node
node star
new node
equals new
node paranthesis
now we will put in the data
node
arrow
data
is equals to new data
now we will make the next of the new
node as head
and previous as null
and new node
previous
is equals to null
now we will change the previous of the
head node to the new node
first we will check if the head node is
null
and
star head
previous
is equals to
new node
now i will move the head to the point to
the new node
now let's write another function to
insert a node after a specific position
void
insert after
argument will be
node pointer
rev
node
and
data
if we first check if the given previous
node is null
yes then we will give it c out
a given node
be
done
we will return to the function
or else we will allocate a new node
let's do new
now we will put in the data
now we will make the next of the new
node as the next of the previous node
equals
to ref
node
now i will make the next of the prep
node as new node
and make the prep node as the previous
of the new node
now i will change the previous of the
new node's next node
if
new node
next
is not null
and
new node
next
is equals to new node
now let's write another function
insert a node at the end of the list
void
append
its argument will be
a node pointer to pointer
and
new data
first we will allocate a new node
equals to
new
parenthesis
now we will create another nodes last
equals to head
now
we will put in the data
node
data
equals to new data
now since this new node will be the last
node so its next will be null
is
equation
and
star head
equals to new node
return
or else we will traverse till the last
node
i'll
last
next is not null
equals to
last next
now we will make the last node as the
previous of the new node
return
now we will write a print list function
to print this list
the argument is
a node pointer node
while
load
is not null
out
load data
or is equals to node
next
now
let's write the main block
we will start with an empty list
we will start by inserting 6 so the
linked list becomes 6 null
and
ampersand
header
almost 6
now we will insert 7 at the beginning
push
10 percent
now we will insert one at the beginning
also
now we will insert four at the end
till now the linked list looks like
one
seven
six
four
null
now we will insert eight after seven
so insert
after
head
next
comma
now
let's print
this linked list
let's try and execute this
as you can see we have created our
linked list in the correct order
let's get back to our slide
next up deletion
first up deletion at the beginning
we have to change the first nodes next
to null and second nodes previous to
null
next up deletion at the end
we have to change the second last node
next pointer to null and delete the
previous node to free up the space
next up deletion at a specific position
we will change the previous node's next
pointer to the next node and next node's
previous pointer to the previous node
now let's try these operations in a code
editor
we will start by creating a class node
public
and data
node pointer
next
load pointer
now we will write a function to delete a
node in a doubly linked list
void
delete
node
its argument as pointer to the head
repeat its argument as pointer to the
head node pointer
and pointer the node to be deleted
now we will check the base case
condition
that is f
add
is
or
note to be deleted is null
and return
now
if
the node to be deleted is a head node
then
is equals to
now
if next node of the dell
or null
that is
if
the node to be deleted is not the last
node
then
else next
previous
equals to
that's
previous
now we will change prev only if not to
be related is not the first node
so if
not equals to
null
then
del
rev
next
equals to
del's next
finally
we will free the memory occupied by the
dell
free
now let's write a function to insert a
node at the beginning of the way link
list
void
enter to the head node pointer
and enter new data
we will allocate the node
now we will put in the data
since we are adding at the beginning so
prev is always null
now we will link the old list of the new
node
now we will change the prev of the head
node to the new node
now we will move the head to the point
to the new node
now let's write print list function
note pointer node
while
node
is not equals to null
data
node
goes to node
next
now let's get started with the main
block
we will start with the empty list
now we will create new nodes
push
percent head
comma 2
push
ampersand
add
comma 4.
push
ampersand
head
comma 6
push
now let's print this list
see out
original list
in a list
now we will call the print list function
add
now we will delete the node from the
doubly linked list
here we are deleting the first node
next let's delete the last node
now the modified list
should look like
let's try and print this
see out
modified
list
add
let's try and execute this
as you can see we have deleted all the
nodes except for 6 and 4.
let's get back to our slides
at last let's sum up what we have learnt
in this session
first up we have recognized doubly
linked list as dynamic data structures
next the doubly linked list offers
faster insertion and deletion operation
next up doubly linked lists are
bi-directional link list
that is we can traverse it in both
direction
finally a doubly linked list is faster
at reverse traversal
and this was all for today's session hey
everyone i am rapper khandelwal and i
welcome you all to simply learns youtube
channel
in this session we will talk about
circular linked list we shall begin our
session by introducing a circular linked
list
then we will try to implement it in the
code editor after that we will try
various operations on them like
insertion and deletion
finally we will sum up what we have
learned in this session
but before we begin make sure you have
subscribed to our youtube channel and
clicked on the bell icon so you never
miss an update from simply learn
so without any further ado let's get
started with introduction to circular
linked list
a circular linked list is a linear data
structure made up of nodes
it is like a singly linked list except
its last node points at the head node
these nodes consist of two parts data
and reference to next pointer these
nodes can be traversed using the next
pointer
now let's try to implement it in the
code editor we will start by creating
nodes
to create a node we need a class
node
we will define its members as
public link to data
and node pointer
next
now let's write a function to insert a
node at the beginning
void push
we will use arguments as a pointer to
node pointer head
and ent data
we will define a node
new node
equals to new
note parentheses
star head
now we will put in the data into a new
node
since we are inserting at the beginning
of the linked list that's why this new
nodes next should be the head pointer
if linked list is not null then set the
next of the last node as head
while
next
is not equals to
head
the temp
is equals to
temp
arrow next
now
them
next
equals to new node
else
new node
next
is equals to
new node
star head
equals to new node
now let's write a function to print this
linked list
void
print list
node
star head
star temp
is equals to head
if
add
is not equals to
null
then
do
see out
temp
data
now while
amp
is not equals to
head
this condition is important to stop this
loop so that it doesn't go infinitely
now let's go to the main block
let's initialize this list as empty
node
star head
equals to null
now let's insert some nodes in this
linked list
so
ampersand
push
ampersand head
comma 11
head
comma
now this linked list looks like
11.
then it will again go back to 5.
now let's try to print this
c out
circular
listed
now let's try and execute this
as you can see we have successfully
created our first circular linked list
let's get back to our slide we have now
introduced the circular linked list now
let's discuss some of the operations we
can apply on a circular linked list
we can perform two operations on a
circular linked list
first up insertion we can perform
insertion at three different situation
at the beginning at the last and at a
specific position after a node
next up deletion we can perform deletion
at the three different situations first
up at the beginning
at the last and at a specific position
after a node
let's discuss these in detail first up
insertion at the beginning
we have to give the first node's address
to the new node's next pointer to
execute this
next up insertion at the end
we have to give new nodes address to the
last node's reference pointer
next up insertion at a specific position
we will change the previous node's
reference address to the new node's
address and the new nodes reference
pointer to the next node's address
now let's try these operations in a code
editor
so far we have implemented a linked list
using classes
now let's try to implement it using
structures
we will start by creating a struct
node
with its element as int data
and struct
node
next
now we will write a function which can
only insert a node to empty list
struct
node
star
add
empty
new data
now since this function is only for the
empty list so we will have to check if
the link list is empty or not
if
last
is not equals to
null
then we will return
last
now let's create a node dynamically
struct
node
start temp
equals to
struct
node
star
malloc
size off
we will copy this statement because we
will need it in the future functions
we will assign the data to this new node
temp
data
is equals to
neutral
data
last
is equals to temp
now we will create the
link to that we will use last
next
is equals to last
since we are in an empty list so the
first node will always point to itself
return
start
node
we are creating a function to insert at
the beginning of the linked list
struct
node
add
again
as argument we will use struct
node
and
data
if
last
is equals to null
then we will return
add empty
last
map data
now we will create a node
dynamically
i have already copied this statement for
the ease
now we will put in the data
data
is equal to data
and
next
is equals to
last
next
is equals to
return
last
now we will write a function to insert a
node at the end
struct
node
star
add
hint
data
if
last
equals to equals to null
and
return
add empty
last comma
data
now we will dynamically create a node
and put in the data
temp
data
equals to data
next
is equals to
last
next
now last next
equals to
temp
and last equals to
return
now we will write a function to insert a
node after a specific node
so struct
node
star
add
after
start
node
star
this item is a node after which we have
to insert the node
if
last
equals to equational
then
return
structure
p
e
is equals to
last
next
now do
if
goes to
item
equals to
we will dynamically create a node here
temp
is equals to
structure
node
star
malloc
size of
now we will put in the data so temp
data
is equals to data
temp
next
is equals to
a p next
temp
if
e is equals to last
last
is equals to temp
return
equals to
next
while
is not equals to
last
text
see out
item
not
present
in the list
return
last
now we will write a function to print
this list
void
print
list
struct
node
star lost
structure
now if
last is equals to null
then
see out
list
is empty
and return
else
we will point to the first node of the
list
so p is equals to
last
next
to traverse the list we will use do
while loop
so do
see out
data
is equals to
p next
while
e is not equals to
last
text
now
let's write a code for the main block
we will start with an empty list struct
node
star
last
supposed to
none
now last
is equals to
add
empty
last
comma
six
last equals to
add begin
last comma
last
equals to
add
begin
last
comma two
last equals to
add
and
last comma
last
equals to
add
after
last
comma
4.
list
let's execute this
as you can see we have created the
linked list in the correct order
let's get back to our slides now let's
talk about deletion
first up deletion at the beginning
we have to change the first node's
address to the null to execute this
next up deletion at the end we have to
change the second last node's address to
null to execute this
next up
deletion at a specific position
we will change the previous node's
reference address to the next node's
address
now let's try these operations in the
code editor
let's get started with creating a node
to create a node we need a class
node
we will declare its members as public
and data
node pointer
next
now we will write a function to insert a
node at the beginning of the list
void
push
a pointer to the node pointer header
and new data
now let's create a node and make head as
next of it
load
star
node
equals to
new
node parenthesis
let's put in the data
new
node
data
is equals to new data
and
new node
next
is equals to
head
if linked list is not null then set the
next of the last node
as the first node
if
star head
is not null
then they will find the node before head
and update next to it
so node star
temp
is equals to star head
while
next
is not
equals to head
stamp is equals to
tamp
next
now temp
equals to
new node
else
next
is equals to
new node
and
star head
is equals to
new node
now let's write a function to delete a
given node from the list
so
void
delete
node
its argument is a pointer to the node
pointer
add
and
end key
now if linked list is empty then we will
simply return it
if
star head
is equal to
null
then return
otherwise
if
add
data
and
add
next is equals to head
then
free
add
is equals to none
return
now
node
last
is equals to
star head
comma star d
now if head is to be deleted
then
star head
data
is
equals to
key
then
while
last
next
not equals to
star head
then last
is equals to last next
now we will point the last node to the
second node of the list
now we will free this head
our head
equals to
last
next
now if either the node to be deleted is
not found or the end of the list is not
reached then
while
last
next
is not equals to
head
and
last
next
data
is
then
last equals to
last
if note to be deleted was found
then
if
last
next
data
is equal to key
then
d is equals to
last
next
and
last
next
is equals to
these next
now we will free
d
or else
see
out
no such
key
formed
you
now let's write a function to print this
list
void
print list
node star
head
node
star
temp
is equal to
head
if
is not null
do
c out
temp
data
amp
is equals to
temp
next
while
temp
is not equals to head
see out
now let's write a code for the main
block
we will start by empty list
so note star
head
equals to
null
now we will push
ampersand head
push
comma
ampersand head
seven
push
ampersand head
comma
and push
ampersand head
comma 10
now we will print the list before any
deletion operation
c out
list
before
deletion
list
head
now
let's delete
let's delete seven
c out
list
after deletion
print list
add
let's execute this
as you can see our deletion function is
working perfectly
let's get back to our slides
at last let's sum up what we have learnt
in this session
first up we have recognized circular
linked list as dynamic data structures
next the circular linked list offer
faster insertion and deletion operation
next a circular linked list are
unidirectional in nature
that is we can only traverse it in one
direction
finally a circular linked list traversal
is quite tricky as we have to stop the
loop as soon as we revisit the first
node
otherwise it will traverse it
indefinitely
and this was all for today's session
hello everyone welcome to simply learn's
youtube channel today we will be
discussing about stack data structure
but before we begin let me tell you guys
that we have daily updates on multiple
technologies if you are a tech gig in a
continuous hunt for latest technological
trends then consider getting subscribed
to our youtube channel and don't forget
to hit that bell icon to never miss an
update from simply learn now without
further ado let's get started with the
agenda for today's discussion
so at first we will discuss what exactly
are stacks
followed by that we will understand the
representation of stack data structure
using arrays and linked lists
advancing ahead we will understand the
basic operations on stacks
and finally we will understand the
applications of the stack data structure
i hope i made myself clear with the
agenda now let's get started with our
first topic
what is a stack
so basically stack is a linear data
structure just like arrays and linked
lists the only difference is that it
follows a specific order when an
operation is implemented on it so what
is the specific order that it follows
that is lifo last in first out or failo
first in last out in the next part we
will understand this order in a much
better way
all operations can be done only at the
one end of the stack that is on the top
now we will discuss much about that in
the operations part of the stack now let
us understand the first fundamental that
is the representation of stack that is
how do you represent a stack normally
so a stack can be represented using two
different methods that is using an array
or using a linked list so in an array we
will be using the continuous memory
and in stack we will be using a
non-continuous memory and the stack will
behave like a dynamic stack or a dynamic
data
structure now the first method that is
the array method
so in this method an array is used to
represent the stack as you can see in
the image below we have a stack
so the name of the stack is stack itself
and you can see two more things here
that is top is equals to 2 and max is 4.
so the max is the value of the array or
the length of the array the maximum
length of the array and top is the
position where the last element of the
stack is present here in this case 56 is
the last element in the stack and top is
inclined or it is addressing to that
particular address that is two
and now let us discuss about the linked
list representation of stack
so in this method a dynamic data
structure that is a linked list is used
to represent the stack
this representation leads to a dynamic
stack it does not need to define the
maximum number of elements present in
the stack remember in arrays we had to
define the max value in the previous
example we had the max value as 5 but in
here you need not to assign the max
value as the stack itself as dynamic
the pointers links are used to store the
address of the upcoming nodes and the
variable used in this method is top so
the top is holding the address of the
topmost element in the linked list
representing the stack
now moving ahead we shall understand the
basic operations on stack now here we
will understand the previously discussed
definition that is push pull etc in a
much better way so the basic operations
on a stack are push pop or pull and peak
now let us discuss each one of them in a
detailed way the first one is push
operation
so the push operation is the mechanism
of inserting a new element into the
stack
as you can see we are trying to insert
the elements from the top so the push
operation basically involves the
following steps check if the stack is
either full or not so basically whenever
you are trying to insert an element into
the stack you need to make sure that the
stack is empty or it has some space if
it is full you cannot insert an element
into the stack step two if the stack is
full produce an error and exit that's
what i was talking about now the step
three
if the stack is not full increment the
top by one that is when you're inserting
an element then you need to update the
top value for example in the previous
slide when we had the array
representation of a stack we had the top
value as 2. so if you try to include an
element into the stack then you need to
update the top value from 2 to 3 that is
incremented by 1.
now the fourth step add data elements to
the stack where the top is pointing
and finally success the push operation
has been successful so this is how you
insert or push an element into the stack
now followed by push operation we have
pop or pull
so the pop operation is a mechanism of
eliminating or deleting or removing one
data element from the existing stack
so we shall understand the
pop operation in a much more detailed
way the operation involves checking the
stack is empty or not if in case the
stack is not empty then you can carry
forward the pop operation but in case if
the stack is empty then you have to
provide an exit status and exit the
control and leave the stack
so if the stack is not empty approach
the data element at the top that is at
the top position for example in the
previous array example remember right we
had the top position pointing towards
two so you need to take the control to
the top position and pick out the
element and pop it
and finally decrease the top by one so
when you eliminate the top element then
the top value from two will be
decremented to one
so this is how the pop operation is
carried over on a stack
next one
is the peak operation
the peak operation involves returning
the topmost data element from the stack
without moving it
so here you can see the top is pointing
to the element number four
and you're picking the
element number four and you're not
removing it from the stack you're just
returning the topmost data element
you're passing the value of the top
element
so to understand the push pop and peak
operations on stack in a much more
better way let's carry out a practical
example
now we are on the practical mode and
here you can see on my screen we have
the code example for this stack
now first we'll be checking if the stack
is empty as per the steps mentioned in
the previous discussion we will check if
the stack is empty or not if it is empty
then we will return else we will
continue and again another step we also
check if the stack is full if the stack
is full we will exit else we will
continue with the operation whatever it
is peak pop or push and here we have an
example for the peak operation that we
discussed previously and followed by
that we have a pop operation we are
trying to exclude an element from the
stack
and another one we have the push
operation where we'll be trying to push
the elements into the stack so these are
the three functions for push pop and
peak now we'll try to push in the
elements and also pop and
try to involve some functions on it or
run some operations on the stack now
let's run this code and see the output
so you can see that the code has
successfully executed and we have the
statements here the first one says the
stack is not full that is false and
stack is empty that is true
right and after that you can see that
the elements which we try to push into
the stack that is 11 76 71 15 and 66 are
been pushed into the stack and if you
clearly observe it we have the element
11 in the bottom 76 upon that 71 upon
that and 15 and last 66 so the order is
first in
last out that is the first element was
pushed first and when you are trying to
eliminate the elements from the stack
then you will first pick out 66 followed
by that you will pick out 15 followed by
that you will pick out 71 and so on so
this is the rule what stack follows
now i hope i made myself clear with the
example now we shall continue with the
applications of stack
so these are the few applications of
stack the first one is expression
conversion
so you can see we have the infix
notation prefix notation and post fixed
notation so the infix notation is no
rocket science there is only one thing
here to learn that is we have two
operands a and b and we have one
operator that is the addition operator
in between those two operands
and when you use the prefix notation you
will have the operator located at the
first place then you will have the
operands followed by it
and in the postfix one you will have the
operands first and followed by the
operands you will have the operator
so basically all the infects prefix and
postfix notations give out the same
results but the only difference is the
representation of those operands and
operators
now let us understand this in a much
more detailed way
so conversion of expression from one
form to another form is
the main application of stack so we have
the first one that is in fix to prefix
and infix to postfix now let us see an
example here you have 1 plus 2 star 3
plus 4 so this is the normal in fixed
notation and when you
try to present the same expression in
the form of prefix notation so this will
be the result and this is the result for
postfix
the next one prefix to postfix and
prefix to inflix
and this is the way you write the prefix
notation and if you want to convert that
to infix this is how you can write it
and this happens to be the result of
postfix notation
and finally postfix to prefix postfix to
infix and these are the results
now followed by expression evaluation
the next important
application of
stack is checking parenthesis
and you can see if the parenthesis is
set properly the expression gets
evaluated if not it will not be
evaluated
now the last one memory management and
function call the very useful thing of
using a stack is
the memory will not be allocated to your
stack elements unless the function is
called here you can see it is the main
function and these are the elements that
you wanted to declare into your stack
and unless you make a function call the
elements will not be declared their
memory or the elements will not get the
memory allocated for them
now another good application of stack is
the backtracking problem or the end
queen problem
the end queen problem is an example of
backtracking problem the end queen
solution to this problem is to position
the queen in such a way that the
opponent queen cannot attack your queen
now another example is string reversal
you can see on my screen we have a
string that is a b c d and e now using
stacks you can reverse this
right so you're basically eliminating an
element and relocating it to the first
place
and finally after reversing your string
this will be your result a b c d
and e
followed by that we have conversion
evaluation
so stack is used to evaluating the
expression as shown in the example
since parenthesis has the highest
precedence 5 plus 4 gets evaluated first
and it will result in 9.
then multiplication and division have
the same precedence
now the associativity comes into picture
so the associativity is always from left
to right so first
4 into 9 will be executed which will
result in 36 and then 32 divided by 4
which will give us 8.
now we have 36 minus 8 which will give
us an answer that is 26.
now the last application is the tower of
hanoi so the tower of hanoi is a
mathematical puzzle consisting of three
rods and n discs
this puzzle consists of some rules
the first rule states that
one disk can move only at a time the
second rule is that the disk can only be
moved when it is at the uppermost
position on the stack
the third one no dusk is allowed to
place on the top of the smaller disk
so this is how the tower of hanoi works
hello and welcome everyone today we are
going to discuss cues in data structures
but before we begin make sure to
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell icon so you never miss an
update from simply learn primarily let's
have a look at our plan for this session
today we will start this session with an
introduction to the queue
later we will discuss the structure of
the queue in detail
after that we will deal with different
operations that can be performed on
queues advancing further we will
understand various types of queues and
their structures
and finally we will discuss different
applications of queues to understand how
queues are used to manipulate data on
that note without further delay let's
get started with introduction to queue
you know that all of us depend on
messaging applications like whatsapp
facebook messenger instagram chats to
communicate with our friends and family
members and while using them you must
have observed that the person you are
trying to communicate with receives
messages in the same order as you have
sent them now the question that arises
here is how is this happening how are
these applications maintaining the order
of these text messages
and the solution to these questions
bring us to queue
basically in these applications a queue
is maintained for each user containing
the messages to be delivered to the user
when the user connects to the network
all the text messages in the queue gets
delivered and once the messages are
delivered empty queues get deleted
this example clearly illustrates the
importance of data structures so let's
dive further and understand the
structure of the queue in depth
but before doing that let's look at a
real-life example of cues to understand
it more clearly
the most common and relevant example of
a queue is a movie ticket counter
in the movie ticket counter you must
have observed that both of its ends
remain open also these ends are fixed
with the help of barricades and that is
why no one can enter in between these
ticket lines
additionally the person who enters first
receives a ticket first and the person
who enters last will obviously get
served at last
cues and data structure resembles all
these properties of a movie ticket
counter which makes them better at
creating virtual first-come first-served
systems
basically they are defined as a linear
collection of different data types that
allow insertion at one end and deletion
at another
unlike any other data structure the
queue ends remain open allowing it to
have different functionalities at both
ends the end at which insertion takes
place is called rare
and the end at which deletion takes
place is known as front
furthermore there are two approaches to
consider the structure of the queue and
both of them depend on the approach of
the programmer
that means being a programmer if you
consider the left hand as front then
your rear node will be at right end
otherwise if you consider the left hand
as rare then the right end will be your
q's front node
unlike arrays and linked lists elements
in the queue cannot be operated from
their respective locations here they can
only be operated from the front or rare
position
moving on let's discuss the operations
in queue data structures one by one
the first operation is nq it is used to
store the elements in the queue
next up is dq this operation is used for
removing them
further we have isful and is null
operations is full function scrutinizes
if the queue is full or not and the is
null operation evaluates if the queue is
empty
we also have a peak operation that helps
you get the element from the front of
the queue without removing it
let's now understand how these
operations work with the help of the
following examples
here we will look at nq5 and q1 and q
minus 2 then is full
then dq
peak
and is null
but before explaining these operations
it's essential that we initialize the
queue data structure by assigning some
random size to it
for example int q of 3 by this
declaration we are assigning only 3
spaces for insertion and q
at this phase there is no element in the
queue as it's empty so both the front
node and rear node will point to the
same location with null memory space in
the storage system let's consider that
null index to be -1 for ease of our
convention
now the first operation on our list is
nq of 5.
as we discussed previously enqueue
operation is nothing but the insertion
of data into a queue data structure
it begins with checking if the queue is
full or not
if the queue is full then the previously
assigned memory is completely filled
with data elements
so insertion would not be possible this
is also known as overflow error in terms
of programming
but as our queue is empty so the
insertion can be performed here for that
we have to increment the rare pointer to
index 0 from index -1
and once we do that the data element 5
will be added to the queue also for
front insertion both front and rear will
point to the same location as there is
only one element present in this queue
let's insert two more elements into this
queue with the operations enqueue 1 and
then q minus 2.
for that we have to increment the rare
pointer to the next index which will be
1.
now as the point is incremented so the
data will be entered into this position
next up is nq minus 2. again we have to
follow the same process of incrementing
the rare pointer we will increment the
rare pointer to point towards the next
index that is index 2 and hence the data
element with value -2 will be entered
here
the next operation on our list is is
full
in this operation if the rear pointer
points to the max size then the queue is
considered to be full as there is no
space left for insertion in our case the
max size of rq is 12 bytes
additionally we are considering to enter
only three integer elements
and one integer data element takes four
bytes of the memory space that means
three integer elements will take 12
bytes hence this function will prompt q
is full on the screen
now we will discuss the dq operation if
we want to access data from a queue we
have to perform two sub tasks the first
one is access the data where the front
is pointing and another is to remove the
data after access and this complete
process is called as dq operation
the first step of this operation is to
check if the queue is empty
if the queue is empty then there is no
element available for deletion this is a
case of underflow error
but as our queue is not empty we can
proceed with the next steps we will be
accessing data from the front node and
later we will be incrementing the front
pointer in order to remove the link to
the previous node so that the data gets
removed now front will point to the
index 1.
thus the data value 5 will be removed
from the queue and will also be prompted
on the screen
therefore this function comes with an
integer return type
next up is peak operation
in this operation element at the front
node will be accessed without deleting
it
the algorithm for this operation begins
with checking if the queue is empty or
not
if the queue is not empty then data at
the front node will be accessed with
temporary variable and printed on the
screen
advancing further let's perform two more
dequeue operations here first is dq of 1
and another one is dq of -2
the data at a front node will be
accessed primarily and the front pointer
will be incremented to point to the next
data element
when we do the point incrementation the
link to the previous node gets remote
which results in data deletion
similarly we will perform a dq of -2
operation here now the front will be
pointed to null memory space as there is
no element left in rq and the data -2
will be removed
the last operation on our list is is
empty
this function checks if the queue is
empty or not in the previous procedure
we mentioned that if the front points to
the null memory space then the queue is
empty and in our case the front is
already pointing to -1
so the output of this function will be q
is empty
this is all about operations in the
queue i hope that you all are clear with
these operations
next we will discuss different types of
queues and their structures at a glance
basically there are four types of queues
linear queue
circular queue priority queue and double
ended queue
the structure which we have discussed
till this time is that of a linear queue
so now we will move on to circular queue
the circular queue is almost similar to
the linear queue except that the last
node of this queue is connected to the
first
it is also known as ring buffer as all
the ends are connected to another end
additionally this circular queue is a
better version of the linear queue as it
removes the drawback of insertion in the
linear queue
the empty space available in a circular
queue can be filled with the new element
by simply incrementing the value of the
rare position
we will learn about this in detail in
our further sessions
a priority queue is another special type
of queue data structure in which each
element has some priority assigned with
it
based on the priority of each element
the elements are arranged in a priority
queue if the elements occur with the
same priority then they are served
according to the first in first out
principle
in the priority queue the insertion
occurs based on the arrival while the
deletion occurs based on the priority
the above figure shows that the highest
priority element comes first and the
elements of the same priority are
arranged based on the first in first out
structure
the last type of queue is dq
dq is a linear data structure in which
the insertion and deletion operations
are performed from both the ends we can
say that dq is a generalized version of
the queue
dq can be used as stack as well as q as
it allows the insertion and deletion
operations on both the ends
if the insertion takes place at one end
and deletion at another then that eq is
known as a linear queue
and if both addition and deletion are
performed at a single end then that dq
is called stack
advancing further let's discuss some
applications of queues to gauge an
insight into the importance of queues
the queue data structure is used in
computers printers and applications to
utilize the benefits of the first come
first serve technique
in computers whenever you work on
documents or ppt you must have observed
that whichever key you press on the
keyboard appears in the exact same order
on the screen
but when your processor is too busy with
other tasks you might notice that the
keys you press appear on the screen with
some delay after you press them
basically those keys are stored in queue
and when the processor becomes free it
processes in the order the keys are
pressed
that means the key pressed first will be
written in a word document first
so this is how computers use a queue to
eliminate deadlocks when multiple
processes are in a ready state
next up is printers
a queue data structure is used in
printers to maintain the order of pages
while printing that means the pages are
stored in a queue in the order that you
want to print them and once the page is
removed from an ordered queue it gets
printed
another most common application of queue
data structure is their usage in web or
mobile apps
applications like domino swiggy uses a
queue for maintaining food order status
if you place an order from an online
portal your order id enters the queue
and once the previous orders before your
order id gets scattered then your order
will be catered as well
from these examples we can clearly say
that queues are used whenever there is a
need for an fcfs strategy in software
development so whenever you work on
projects that need a first come first
serve approach then remember that you
have to implement a queue data structure
to complete it successfully
finally let's have a look at some key
takeaways that we discussed in this
session
we started this session by examining the
structure of the queue
we learned that the queue is a linear
data structure
after that we talked about different
operations of queues in which we learnt
nq and dq are responsible for data
manipulation in a queue
later we discussed different types of
queues as well
finally we discovered some applications
of queues and how they fulfill the need
of fcfs systems
we have also made it clear that queues
can handle multiple data types as well
so with this we come to the end of this
video hello everyone welcome to simply
learns youtube channel today we will be
discussing about dq in data structure in
today's video we have an interesting
quiz for you guys so stay tuned and do
leave your answers for the quiz that's
going to pop up on your screens in next
few minutes but before we begin let me
tell you guys that we have daily updates
on multiple technologies so if you are a
tech geek in a continuous hunt for
latest technological advancements then
consider getting subscribed to our
youtube channel and don't forget to hit
that bell icon to never miss an update
from simply learn
now without any further ado let's get
started with the plan for today's
discussion
we'll start this discussion by
understanding what is double ended queue
in data structure followed by that we'll
understand the properties of dq in
detail advancing ahead will deal with
the different types of dq after that
we'll understand the representation of
dq using circular queue and further
we'll discuss different operations that
can be performed on dq
once finished with that we'll implement
a dq using circular queue and finally
we'll cover applications of dq to
understand its importance
i hope i made myself clear with the
agenda now let's get started with our
first topic what is dq
dq is an abbreviation for double ended
queue and as the term double ended queue
suggests it is a type of queue with some
advanced features at both of its ends
but previously we have learned that the
basic queue data structure must perform
insertion from one of its end and
deletion from another or opposite end so
what new limitation or feature does this
particular type of queue brings
well the dq extends the concept of a
linear queue by implementing insertion
and deletion at both of its nodes by
that what i mean is the dq data
structure is acquainted with the
possibility to insert and delete new
elements at any node that is why dq is
concerned as more generalized version of
queue data structure
now moving ahead we shall understand the
key properties of dq
the first property of dq states that the
dq can use the lipo principle for
inserting or removing elements the last
in first out principle is used while
implementing stacked data structure and
according to this principle the queue
elements must be inserted from one end
and should also be removed from the same
end for instance we are storing some
elements inside the skew structure which
is performing both insertion and
deletion from one end
however when deletion begins the element
inserted at last will be removed first
whereas the element stored at first will
get removed at the end this property
clears that the dq can inherit all the
properties of stack data structure
the next property of dq states that the
dq can use the fifo principle for
performing both insertion and deletion
operations
that means the element which enters
inside the queue at beginning will also
leave the queue at first
further the element which entered at
last can leave the queue at last
both of these properties displays the
uniqueness of this particular type of
queue data structure
now in upcoming slides we will
understand different types of the dq
the first type of dq we have is termed
as input restricted queue
this terminology itself suggests that
this particular type of dq will have
some restrictions while performing
enqueue or insertion operation
in this type of dq the insertion can
only be performed from one end where
deletion can be performed at both of its
ends the representation of dq shown
below explains how the operations in
this type of dq will get accomplished
the next type of dq is output restricted
dq
this term makes clear that this type of
queue will have some restrictions while
performing deletion operations
in this specific type of queue the
removal of elements can only be
performed from one end where the
insertion can be performed at both of
its eights this particular structure of
a queue explains how the different
operations will take place in this type
of dq
now here is the interesting question
that we want you all to answer based on
the properties of dq that we have
discussed till now which of the
following data structure will be more
ideal for implementing dq in data
structure
what i mean by idl is the time and space
complexity for implementation strategy
that you decide should be minimum
the options that we have are
circular array
singly linked list and doubly linked
list
it will be interesting to see how many
of you guys will get this right
so guys do leave your answers to this
question in comment section below in a
week's time we'll be announcing the
right answer and you all can check it
out
on that note let's dive further and
understand the representation of dq
using circular queue and yes
circular queue is one of the answers for
previous questions we'll understand why
it is best in upcoming slides but please
check the complexity analysis of other
two strategies to decide your answer for
the previous question as multiple
answers can be accurate for that
question
now let's understand what a circular
queue is
well a circular queue is nothing but the
extended notion of linear q as it
follows the first in first out principle
with the exception that the last
position of this particular queue is
connected to its first position making a
circular link
the circular link is responsible for
naming of this queue as circular queue
or ring buffer let's understand how a
circular queue operates with the help of
simulation
this is the illustration of a circular
queue having size 5. as the position of
rear pointer keeps increasing a new
element will be inserted in this queue
until the rear pointer reaches the end
of q
but what if we perform dq operation now
if we perform the deletion then the
empty space will get created at front of
queue however this space can further be
utilized in this particular type of
queue by making circular incrementation
of rear pointer or circular link
so if we increment the rear pointer from
its index 5 to index 0 we can utilize
empty space by making new insertions
using this feature of circular queue we
can implement both insertion and
deletion at both the ends of queue
let's understand how we can do that in
upcoming slides
the first type of insertion is a pretty
ordinary one and this insertion will
increment the position of rear pointer
to insert a new element the arrow shown
in blue is rear pointer and the arrow
shown in orange is the front pointer so
as you can see once we increment the
rear pointer new elements get inserted
this is how the insertion using rear
node happens
now what if we want to perform insertion
using front end in order to perform the
insertion using front node we'll have to
make front pointer reach to the end of q
the only possible way to achieve that is
to set front pointer equal to max size
-1 manually
this command will allow a front pointer
to reach the end of q for performing
insertion and for further insertions
we'll just have to decrement the front
pointer location for inserting new
elements this is all about insertion
now that we have implemented insertion
from both ends let's move on to the
deletion operation
primarily we'll look into the deletion
using front node in order to delete
elements using front node we'll have to
increment the front pointer until it
reaches the end of q and once it reaches
the max size we'll use circular
incrementation to bring the front
pointer to the beginning of queue while
performing these incrementation
meanwhile the elements will be removed
from the queue
next up is deletion using rear end for
performing deletion using a rear pointer
we'll have to decrement its location
once we decrement the rear pointer
location the element will get removed
from the queue
now moving ahead we'll look into the
different operations that can be
performed on a double ended queue
basically there are four primary
operations in the dq which we have
already understood in the representation
of dq using circular queue
these operations are insertion and
deletion at the front and insertion and
deletion at the rear
additionally the circular queue
implementation of dq cost us big of 1
which is the most optimal complexity
that we can hope for
having said that let's dive into the
implementation of these operations using
a circular queue
we'll implement a double ended queue
using circular queue in order to do that
we'll use c programming language and
one-dimensional arrays so without
wasting any time further let's move to
the code editor
now in order to get started with
implementation of dq will have to create
array and pointer variables so let's do
that
and
we'll name this array as dq
and we'll provide 100 as initial size
next we'll create pointers
and
rear
is equal to minus -1
now we'll also define the maximum size
for our queue using define call
size
as 5
after done with this initialization
process we'll start working on insertion
from front node we'll declare a function
named as void front insert so let's do
that void
front
underscore
insert
and insert this function will pass an
argument into z to insert an element
now while performing insertion we should
always check if the queue is full or not
because if it is full then the insertion
won't be possible so for that we'll
write condition
if
front
is equal to equal to zero
and and
rear
it's equal to equal to size
minus one
inside
and braces
or
front
is equal to equal to rear
plus one
printf
tq
is full
insertion it's not possible
okay
otherwise if both the front and rear
node are pointing to null memory index
or minus 1 will manually set our front
pointer to index 0 to make the first
insertion into the queue
and we will insert the element at new
location or index 0 where the front
pointer is pointing so for that
what we'll do is we'll write another
condition with lc block
else if
front
is equal to equal to
-1
and and
zero
is equal to equal to minus one
then
make front
is equal to rhea is equal to
zero
and
dq
front
is equal to
z
now if we want to insert the element at
the last node of q then we need to set
front pointer to the max size minus 1
location to do that we'll write this
condition
else
if
front
is equal to equal to 0.
then
front
is equal to
size minus 1
and dq
front
is equal to z
if all these above mentioned conditions
fail then the front pointer is already
at the last part of q
and it just need to decrement its
location for inserting element in empty
spaces as discussed previously so to do
that we'll write one more condition
using else block so let's do that
else
front
is equal to front
minus 1
and dq
front
is equal to z
now we have successfully implemented a
front insert function so let's move
forward and work on another function
that is called as void
rear
underscore insert
and will pass
g as an argument to insert an element
now as done previously we will first
check if our queue is full or not so
let's do that using if condition
if
front
is equal to equal to zero
and and
ria
is equal to equal to size minus one
inside braces
or
front
is equal to equal
equal to equal to
rear
plus 1
then
printf
dq
is
full
next if there is no element in an array
we'll manually set the rear pointer to
index 0 for new insertion so for that
we'll write condition else if
front
is equal to equal to minus 1
and and
rear
it's equal to equal to minus 1
then
set rear
is equal to 0
and
insert
dq
rear
is equal to z
otherwise if rear pointer is already at
the end of q then we will bring it to
the beginning of q so for that we'll
write condition else f
rear
is equal to equal to size
minus 1
then
bring
rear
to index 0
and
dequeue area
is
equal to z
if all these mentioned conditions fail
then what we'll do is we'll write else
condition and we'll simply increment our
rear pointer to make an insertion so for
that what we'll do is we'll create else
block and we're inside it
we will
do rear plus plus
and we will set dq
rear
is equal to
z
with this we have successfully
implemented void rear insert function so
now let's move into deletion functions
first we'll create void front dq
function void
front
underscore dq
and there is no need for any argument
for this function
to begin with this function first we'll
have to check if dq is empty because we
cannot delete elements if there is no
element to delete so for that we'll
write f condition f
front
it's equal to equal to minus 1
and and
rear
it's equal to equal to minus 1
then
printf
there is no element
to
delete
inside
this
dq
in the next condition we'll check if
there is only one element inside the dq
if there is only one element then we
will set both front and rear to minus 1
manually for that what we'll do is we'll
create else if condition
else if
front
is equal to equal to zero
then
printf
let slash into take this to the next
line
the
deleted
element
from
the front is
modulus d
comma
dq
front
and we will set front
is equal to minus 1
similarly
rear
is equal to -1
now if both these above mentioned
conditions fail then we will delete the
element from our front node
the first removal will be in a case when
the front pointer is at the end of queue
so for that we'll write condition else f
front it's at end of queue that is size
-1
and what we'll do is
we will printf
slash and
the deleted
element
from
the front
edge
modulus
d
comma
dq
front
comma
and another condition will be when the
front pointer is at the beginning
section of a cube for that
we'll write else condition
printf
slash n
the
deleted element
from
the front is
modulus d
comma dq
front
with this we have successfully
implemented our front dq function now
let's move towards next function that is
deletion from the rear end for that
we'll create new function name
void
dq
underscore rear
and this function also does not need any
argument
so next
what we'll do is we'll create
condition to check if the queue is empty
or not
so
if front
it's equal to equal to minus 1
and and
rear
is equal to equal to minus 1
then printf
printf
slash n
there is no element
to
delete
inside the queue
now let's move to the next condition
in next condition we'll write else if
front
is equal to equal to rhea
then printf
some statement
and
set run
is equal to minus 1
along with rear is equal to -1
and that statement will be
the
deleted
element
from
the dq
using
rear
node
as
modulus d
comma
dq
rhea
now
if both these above mentioned conditions
fail
then we'll have to delete the element
from our rear node the first removal
will be in a case when rear is at the
beginning portion of a queue for that
let's write a condition
else if
rear
is equal to equal to 0 that is at the
beginning part of q
then
printf
some statement
and
rear
is equal to size minus 1 that is setting
it to the max size of cube
and the statement that we will return is
backslash n
the deleted
element
from
the rear
node
as
modulus d
comma
dq
rear
in other cases we'll just have to
decrement the size of rear pointer and
delete the element so for that we'll
write else condition
printf
some statement
and
set rear
is equal to
rhea minus 1 that is decrementing the
size of rear pointer and the statement
that we'll write as backslash n
the
deleted
element
from
the rear
node
as modulus d
and comma
dq
rhea
well here is one spelling mistake so
let's remove it
okay
so with this we have successfully
implemented our void dequeria function
now we will implement one more function
to display the state of our
dq the name of that function will be
void
display
and this function also does not need any
argument
so we'll begin with implementation of
this function for this we'll create an
iterator element and we'll set it to the
front pointer
and we will printf
backslash n
elements
inside
the
dub
double
ended
queue
are
next line
will enter into while loop to print
those element
i
not equal to
rear
printf
modulus
d
comma
dq
i
and
will increase the value of i
by
i
plus
modulus
sides
and
outside this while loop we will print f
modulus d
dq
rhea
okay
with this we have implemented all the
required functionalities for our dq so
let's work on driver method that is main
function
in order to check the output of our
program so let's work on this main
function
first we will insert
a few elements into our queue so i will
insert first element using front insert
next
let's insert one more element from front
node
using function front insert and this
element will be 23.
next we will insert elements using rear
node
underscore insert
and we'll pass 17 now
next we'll insert
and
we'll insert one more element using this
rear node only
insert
47.
now we will display
the state of our queue after performing
all these operations
and next we will
dq
few elements
so for that we'll use front dq function
and next
we will dequeue
from
rear node
so
dq here
and after performing deletion operations
will also display the state of our queue
so let's call display once again
and let's add one more command
return
zero
okay
so with this we have successfully
implemented our program for dq
implementation so let's run it and check
if it is working fine or not
okay so we are getting output here
but uh
display function is printing output in
weird manner so let's
work it out
so
all we have to do is we'll have to add
space before modulus t here and here as
well
so
once done with this let's
recompile our code
okay
so now our output is clear so let's
check if it is
perfect or not
so
the first insertion that we made was -5
second was 23 from the front end so
5 should be getting inserted before 23
so minus 5 is getting inserted before 23
but as we are inserting it using front
pointer so 23 is remaining at the front
now
after these two insertions we are
performing insertions using rear pointer
the first rear insertion was 17 then 12
then 47 and these elements are getting
inserted
so let me show you how they are getting
inserted in exact same order
so
look here so elements inside the double
ended q qr 23 minus 5 17 12 and 47 that
means the insertion is in right order
after that we deleted the element from
front node so the front node is at 23 so
23 is getting deleted after that we
deleted the element using rear node so
47 is getting deleted from the
rear node
we are still getting 23 here that means
the dq function is incomplete so we'll
have to change it so let's go to the dq
function
and i guess it was from
front end so we'll need to change code
for our front dq
so
okay
so in this case we haven't brought our
trend pointer to index 0 so let's do
that here and once we do this let's
recompile our code again
okay
so now you can see that the 23 is
getting deleted
with this we have successfully
implemented our dq function
now let's move back to the powerpoint
and understand few applications of dq
the first application that we are going
to discuss in detail is palindrome
checker you all must have heard about
the term palindrome
the palindrome is a specific word or
number which reads the same backward as
forward for example the word radar it
reads the same from both ends so using
the dq we can implement the palindrome
checker program with complexity big of
1.
the string which you need to check will
be inserted into a dq and after that it
will read from both sides if the reading
is the same then that string will be
considered as palindrome
the next application of dq is its use in
multiprocessor scheduling
but what precisely is multi-processor
scheduling and why do we need it
well the system implemented in the old
days use single processor scheduling to
manage the computing processes
when multiple processes need to be
executed by a single core or cpu then
the process take more time to implement
and thus the system lacks computing
power
but the multiprocessor scheduling
implemented in modern computers resolves
that problem using a double ended queue
suppose we have three processors in our
system and each processor has some
processors to execute each processor
maintains a dq that contains threads
that are ready to execute the processor
executes a process and if a process
creates a child process then that
process will be inserted at the front of
the dq or parent process suppose the
processor p2 has completed the execution
of all its threads then it steals the
thread from the rear end of processor p1
and adds it to the front end of the
processor p2 the processor p2 will take
the thread from front end therefore the
deletion takes from both the ends
this is also known as a still algorithm
in process scheduling so with this we
came to the end of this video
hey everyone welcome to simply learns
youtube channel in this session we will
learn about linear social algorithm its
complete logic and how to program and
implement it in real time let us take a
quick look on the agenda for today's
session
so we will begin with understanding what
exactly is searching then we will learn
what is a linear search algorithm
followed by that we will get into
learning how does a linear search
algorithm works in real time then we
will look into the pseudo code for
linear search algorithm followed by that
we will understand the complexity of
linear search algorithm and finally we
will wind up the session by
understanding few important applications
of linear search algorithm i hope i made
myself clear with the agenda before
getting started let me tell you guys
that we have daily updates on multiple
technologies if you are a tech geek in a
continuous hunt for latest technological
trends then consider getting subscribed
to our youtube channel and don't forget
to hit that bell icon to never miss an
update from simply learn
now let's get started with our first
topic now let us try to understand what
exactly is searching
searching in data structure refers to
the process of finding the desired
element in the set of items the selected
item is called the target element any
data structure such as an array linked
list tree or graph can be used for
searching a set of elements
in data structures searching can be
categorized into two types first type is
the sequential search in which we check
the elements in a data list or an array
one by one
in data structures searching can be
categorized into two ways the first type
is a sequential search in which we check
the elements in a data list or an array
one by one
an example for sequential search is
linear search
now let us learn about the next type of
searching approach the next type of
searching approach is the interval
search approach
interval search divides the search in
half by repeatedly targeting the center
of the data set the binary search
algorithm can be an example for interval
search we will go over the binary search
algorithm in detail in our upcoming
video
after understanding the logic of search
and the types of search we will get into
understanding what is linear search
algorithm
the linear search method is a simple
search technique in this type of
searching approach we perform a
sequential search across all objects one
after the other every element is
examined and if there is a match found
then the specific element is returned
otherwise the search will continue until
the data gathering is complete
let us go through an example for better
learning experience on my screen we have
the following elements 50 10 20 30 70 40
90 60 as randomly distributed elements
let us imagine that our target element
is 70.
we found that our target element was 70
using linear search strategy so how does
it work in the next segment we will look
into the working terms of linear search
algorithm the simplest method of
searching the data collection is the
linear search starting from the
beginning of the data set each element
is examined until no match is found the
linear search is completed after the
item has located
in the first stage we compare the first
element that is 50 to the search element
that is 70. we will go on to the next
element because 50 and 70 are not
matched
we will compare the second element which
is 10 to the search element that is 70
in the next step and once more there is
no match found then we have the element
30 as the next comparison and 70 and 30
are not matched
we have the next element that is 20 in
the fourth phase and there is no match
when we compare 20 with 70.
moving on to the following stage we have
the data element 70 and after comparing
70 with the search element there is a
match
we will now have the searching and
display index as 4 and this index
contains the searched element
we now comprehend the pseudo code of the
linear search algorithm after learning
the working terminology of linear search
algorithm
first we have a function called linear
search which has two variables in its
parameters the arrays name which is an
array and the search variable which is
the value then using a follow we must
search for our target variable by
analyzing all the data elements in the
data set with the condition that is the
search item is identical to any sets
value we must return its index value
now we must stop searching once the
searched value has been discovered
then we will close our if and for loop
as well as the linear search function
we will now look into the complexity of
linear search algorithm after
comprehending the pseudo code
the complexity of linear search
algorithm is divided into three
categories the best case which is the
big o of one the average case which is
the big o of capital n and the worst
case scenario which is same as the
average case which is the big o of n
here n is the number of data items to be
sorted let us look into how all these
complexities of linear search algorithm
play out in detail
first we have the best case which is big
o of n as a result the best case
scenario happens when the searched
element is found in the data sets first
block
as a result the search takes a constant
amount of time here is an example of an
array with 50 10 40 20 30 as the
elements
now our search element is 50 which is
located in the first location of the
array then there's the typical case of
linear search algorithm which has big o
of n and occurs when the search element
is in the middle of the data set or any
point of the data set with the array
containing the same search element 50 we
can easily see that the element 50 is
present in the center of the array at
the location number 2. finally we have
the worst case which is big o of n which
is same as that of the average case of
the linear such algorithm and happens
when the search element is in the last
block of the data set
as a result of the number of searches
required is proportional to the number
of elements as demonstrated in this
example the search element 50 is found
in the last block of the array index
which is 4.
in the next segment we will look into
some real-world instances of linear
search algorithms according to the first
application of the linear search
algorithm linear search is particularly
efficient when it comes to discovering a
particular string next we will look into
the second application of linear search
algorithm
when a data set has only few elements
linear search is the simplest to
implement
the final real world application of the
linear search algorithm is with the help
of telephone directory you may find out
the name of a person
with the phone number 123
this can be implemented easily using
linear search algorithm now let us have
a look at the linear search algorithm
working in practical demonstration
so on my screen we have an example for
linear search algorithm we have included
three libraries standard input output
standard library and console input
output library
then we have entered the main function
where we have declared an array with
maximum size of 50 elements account
variable i a variable named target where
we would store our searched element and
finally num variable where the number of
elements in the array is recorded
then we have a printf function to ask
the user how many items are there in the
array and then we use a scanf function
to allow input from the keyboard so we
have added percentage d format specifier
to the scanf function which is used for
numeric values and num variable then
using a for loop we will try to print
all the items in the array starting with
0 and ending with num variable which is
the last element then we will enter our
search element which we want to find
among all the elements of the array and
as previously said we'll store the found
element in the target variable
following that we will use the for loop
to examine all the elements in the array
then we use the if statement to check
for the element is identical to our
searched element or not
if the element is found we exit the
follow and we will break the keyword
and if the target values location is
less than the number of elements in the
array then we will return the location
otherwise if the value location is
greater than the number of elements in
the array then the search will be
unsuccessful and we won't be able to
find the searched element
now we will compile this code and see
the output
so there you go the code got
successfully compiled now it is asking
for the number of elements in the array
let me give us five elements now let us
enter the elements into the array let us
enter some random elements
now we have entered the 5 elements let
me provide the searched element as 2
now we have found the target element to
be found in the location 2
that is 0 1 and 2. yeah 2 is located in
the second index location so with that
we have come to an end of this tutorial
on linear search algorithm hello
everyone welcome to simply learn's
youtube channel and in this session we
will be discussing the tree data
structure before we begin let me tell
you guys that we have daily updates on
multiple technologies if you are a tech
geek in a continuous hunt for latest
technological trends then consider
getting subscribed to our youtube
channel and don't forget to hit that
bell icon to never miss an update from
simply learn now without further ado
let's get started with the agenda for
today's discussion
so we will be discussing what exactly is
a tree data structure
followed by that we will understand why
we need a tree data structure
then we will learn the tree
terminologies followed by that we will
understand tree node then we will see
the types of trees and followed by that
we will understand the tree traversal
and finally we will see some
applications of trees in real time i
hope i made myself clear with the agenda
now let's get started with the first
topic that is what is a tree data
structure
so what exactly is a tree data structure
the tree is a non-linear data structure
that consists of nodes and is connected
by edges i know it's a little difficult
to understand just by the definition so
let me show you the pictorial
representation
as you can see we have the elements that
is 10 20 30 40 50 60 and 70 and all
these are stored in the tree data
structure they are stored in a
non-linear structure if we had used
arrays it would have been in a linear
consecutive way where 10 starts first
and 70 ends at the last position
now in the next section we will discuss
why we had made to a switch to the tree
data structure when we already had a
linear data structure that is array
now the next topic that is why we need
tree data structure
so there are many reasons why we have
switched into tree data structure and
one of the reason is a linear data
structure always stores the elements in
a sequential form that is one after the
other and in operations to be performed
in linear data structure
the time complexity increases as the
data size increases you can see here
that as discussed before the elements
are stored in a linear form that is 10
at the first place and 70 at the last
place imagine you wanted to access the
element 70 then using the traversal you
had to start from the first position
that is 10 20 30 40 and slowly at the
end is 70. so accessing that particular
element is really time consuming we are
facing this just for 70 elements imagine
if we had 700 elements
right so that is exactly why we had made
a switch to tree data structure and
using trade data structure we have many
advantages as the tree data structure is
completely non-linear and it allows
easier access and quicker access of the
data elements how is that possible
we will look into it into the next
segment where we will discuss about the
traversal of trees
now before we understand the traversal
of trees we should understand another
important topic that has the
terminologies of tree
so the first one is the node node is the
entity that contains the keys and
pointer to its child nodes
so here you can see that the elements a
b c d e f and g are the elements so each
and every element or the blue dot is
called as unknown and the blue dots here
are
1 2 3 4 5 6 and seven so we have seven
blue dots so we have seven elements here
so you can see the line between each
elements right so this particular line
is called edge now we'll discuss about
the edge in the next part
so the connecting links between any two
nodes are called as edges so we
discussed about the nodes right where
the element is stored the blue dots are
the nodes and the lines connecting
between the elements or nodes is called
as the edge
so out of all the nodes
this first node that is the element a is
called as the root node in a tree data
structure
so indirectly root node is also called
as the parent node of all the nodes now
we will understand what are parent nodes
and children nodes
so in a tree data structure the node
that is the node's predecessor is called
as parent node so here we have discussed
that a or the root node is the parent of
all nodes
so for a b and c nodes are children
nodes and for b and c nodes a happens to
be the parent node similarly d and e are
the children nodes of b and f and j are
children nodes of c
and
the
nodes d and e have b as the parent node
and the nodes f and g have c as the
parent node now followed by that
we will understand the descendant node
so as discussed before the descendant
node is the node that comes after the
parent node here the b and c are the
descendants of a and d and e are
descendants of b and similarly f and g
are the descendants or children of the
node c
so in a tree data structure the node
which does not have any child is called
as the leaf node now at the end we have
d e f and g so these particular nodes do
not have any children nodes like b and c
so these particular four nodes which do
not have any children are called as the
leaf nodes
in a tree data structure the node with
at least one child node is called as the
internal node
so here the internal nodes are b and c
which have at least one child
in a tree the total number of children
of a node are called as the degree of
that node so in this particular diagram
the degree of root node is 2 because it
has two child nodes and the degree of b
is 2 as it has two child nodes similarly
the degree of c is 2 because it has two
child nodes but when it comes to d e f
and g
the
degree is 0 because they do not have any
child nodes
in a tree data structure the root node
is said to be at level 0 and the
children of the root node are said to be
at level 1 and the children nodes of the
level 1 are at level 2. so to understand
this let's go through the diagram as you
can see this particular root node is
called as level 0
and followed by that we have the
children nodes of a that is b and c and
that level is called as level 1 and
followed by that we have level 2 and if
this tree goes forward the levels also
increase accordingly
now in a tree data structure the total
number of edges from a leaf node to the
particular node is the longest path and
this particular path is called as the
height of that node now here we have our
general tree data structure and here you
can see the height of node a s2
and the height of node b and c together
is at one and the height of the last
leaf nodes happens to be zero
next in the tree data structure the
total number of edges from the root node
to a particular node is called as the
depth of that node
now in this particular tree data
structure
the depth of the root node is zero and
the depth of b
and c together is one because the number
of edges connecting to the
node a from b is just one and similarly
the number of edges connecting the node
c from a is just one so the depth of
both b and c is one
now if we consider the last leaf nodes
then the depth is two because if you see
g is connected to a using two different
edges similarly f is connected to a
using two different edges and e and d
also have two nodes to connect to a so
the depth is 2d
now in the next segment we will
understand the tree node
so the tree data structure has data part
and references to its left and right
child node in the tree data structure so
here you can see this is the node and
the node has three segments that is data
element and the references to its left
child and the references to its right
child
now there are four different types of
trees the first one is the binary tree
followed by that we have the binary
search tree then we have avl tree and
finally we have the b3 let us discuss
each one of them the first one is the
binary tree a binary tree is a tree data
structure in which each parent node at
most has two children
so in this particular tree we'll have at
most two children that means it might
have one or more than one but not more
than two children per node
moving ahead we have the binary search
tree
so a binary search tree or a bst is a
tree data structure in which each node
has a maximum of two children all nodes
of the left sub tree are less than the
right node all nodes on the right sub
tree are more than the root node so here
you can see the image or the gif which
represents the image of a binary search
tree so here all the nodes of the left
sub tree are less than the root node and
all the nodes of the right sub tree are
more than the root node
the next type of the tree is the avl
tree the avl tree got its name after
inventory georgie adelson welsky and
landis
avl tree is the self-balancing tree in
which each node maintains a balanced
factor most value is either one
zero or minus -1
violence factor is equals to height of
the left subtree minus height of the
right subtree or height of the right
subtree minus height of the left subtree
so in this particular image you can
identify it is an abl tree
and now the last type of tree that is
the b tree
b3 is a special kind of self-balancing
search tree in which each node can
contain more than one key and can have
more than two children b3 is also known
as the height balanced m v tree now in
this particular gif we can see how a b
tree looks like
now followed by this we will discuss the
tree traversal
so traversing a tree helps to visit
required node in the tree to perform
specific operations tree traversal can
be performed in three different ways
the first one is the pre-order traversal
where we visit the node
and visit all the node from the left
side then visit all the nodes from the
right side so this particular gif is an
example for pre-order traversal where we
visit all the left side nodes first then
we visit the right side nodes
now we will move ahead into the next
type of traversal
that is the in order traversal
first we visit all the nodes from the
left side then we visit the root node
and then represent all the nodes from
the right side so this particular gif
will be an example for the in order
traversal where we visit all the left
side nodes and then we visit the root
node and followed by that we will visit
the right side nodes
and the last type of traversal is the
post order traversal where we visit all
the nodes from the left side first then
revisit all the nodes from the right
side and finally visit the root node
so this particular image on the right
side is an example for post order
traversal now before we get into
learning the applications of trees we
will try to execute one example based on
the post order pre-order and in-order
traversals and tree data structure
so you can see that we have an example
on my screen right now so here we have
the node structure
then we have the in order traversal
function followed by that we have the
pre-order traversal function and finally
we have the post order traversal
function now let's quickly run this
program and see the output and don't
worry about the code this particular
code document will be attached in the
description box below and you can have
access to it
now we have the run option over here and
the program got successfully executed
uh you can ignore this warning and here
we have the in order traversal of the
tree and the first output then we have
the pre-order traversal of the tree and
finally we have the post-order traversal
of the tree now let's discuss the last
part
where we will learn the application of
trees
so the application of trees are as
follows binary search trees are used to
quickly check whether an element is
present in the set or not then we have
the most popular database usage of b3
which is a variant of tree data
structure then we have the modified
version of trees called as tris which is
used in the router to store routing
information and finally the compiler
uses a syntax tree to validate the
syntax of every program you write
so with that we have come to an end of
this tutorial on tree data structure hey
everyone welcome to simply learn's
youtube channel in this session we will
be learning about tree traversal in data
structures
so let's take a look at the agenda for
today's session
first we will begin with understanding
what exactly is tree traversal in data
structures next we will understand the
data structure used for implementing
tree traversal after that we will learn
the types of tree traversals in data
structure
and lastly we will discuss the different
applications of tree traversal in data
structure
but before we begin let me tell you guys
that we have daily updates on multiple
technologies if you are a tech geek in a
continuous hunt for latest technological
trends then consider getting subscribed
to our youtube channel and don't forget
to hit that bell icon to never miss an
update from simplylearn now without
further ado let's get started with our
first topic that is what is tree
traversal in data structure
tree traversal is a process of visiting
each and every node in a tree data
structure
so right here on my screen we have a
tree with different nodes that is a
b
c
d
and e
so here we will be visiting all the
nodes one after the other using the tree
traversal methods
now that we have a brief understanding
of what exactly is a tree traversal
process let's get into the next topic of
our discussion for today that is the
data structure used for free traversal
in a tree data structure there are
primarily two data structures utilized
for tree traversal the first one is the
stack data structure and the second one
is the queue data structure a stack is a
linear data structure that operates on
the last in first out lifo principle
there is only one pointer in the stack
that is the top pointer which points to
the stack's topmost element only the top
of the stack is used for insertion and
deletion now the next one is the queue
a queue unlike stacks is open on both
the ends the one end is always open and
used only for input and the other is
only used for deletion or elimination
the principle followed in queue is
first in first out or fifo approach
followed by that we will look into the
different types of tree traversals in
data structure
tree traversal can be done in the
following ways the first one is breadth
first search and the second one is the
depth first search
first let us have a look at the breadth
first search algorithm or breadth first
search traversal
we follow level order traversal in
breadth first search
breadth first search traverses notes by
level instead of subtrees first we visit
the root node followed by the root node
we visit the left sub tree of the tree
then followed by the left sub tree we
finish the right subtree of the entire
tree
after that we go until the leaf nodes of
the entire tree is found the second one
is the depth first search in depth first
search we traverse three data structure
in three ways that is pre-order
traversal in-order traversal and post
order traversal
let us take a look at how these
traverses are carried out
first let us discuss the pre-order
traversal
we traverse the root node first in the
pre-order traversal then we traverse
through the left sub tree and finally we
traverse through the right subtree
then there is in order traversal in
order traversal involves traversing of
the left sub tree first followed by that
we enter the root node then we visit the
right subtree lastly we have the post
order traversal so post order traversal
involves traversing of left subtree
first then the right subtree and finally
we visit the root node
now next we will have a look at some of
the important applications of tree
traversal in data structure
so we use tree traversal in data
structures to build a prefix expression
or polish notation from expression trees
then utilize the pre-order traversal and
then traverse the expression tree in a
pre-orderly manner
a binary tree's postfix representation
or reverse polish notation can be
generated using post order traversal
because it returns values from the
underlying set in order according to the
comparator setting up the binary search
tree in order traversal is often
employed on binary search trees
a complete binary tree can be deleted or
released when deleting or freezing nodes
and values in the post order traversal
now next we will see an example based on
trade reversal in data structures
so on my screen we have an example for
tree traversal in data structure to
begin we have included the enum or user
specified data type traversal it mostly
used to give integral constant names
which make a programmer easier to
comprehend and maintain
we defined three variables in the enum
data type that is pre-order in order and
post-order traversal we can define the
type that can take one of the two values
by using the typedef and enum keywords
we have a traversal data type with trap
variable and a node data type with node
variable then we define the node using
the data structure type as struct node
we declare one variable x and two nodes
as a left and right nodes respectively
in this node section
we then attempted to create node using
the create node function passing the
root node as an argument in this code we
use a malloc function to create a node
assign data to x and null to both the
right and left nodes before returning to
the root node
if node t is not equal to null we simply
return it otherwise we will use the
released tree function to release the
left and right nodes and if neither is a
root node then we will use the free
function to release the node t which
will behave as the root node
then we define the display tree function
which takes the trap variable and the
root note as parameters
there is a condition in this function
that is if the root node is not null we
will return the root node then using the
switch case scenario we attempted to
traverse the tree using all three types
of traversals
we utilize a trav variable in the switch
function so if any of the in-order
pre-order or post-order variables match
the trap variable the traversal will be
executed then we created a tree using
the create tree function which takes a
data variable as input in the create
tree function we used a malloc function
to create the root node and we first
assigned a null to the left and right
nodes as well as the data to the
variable x before returning to the root
node
we first traverse the root node then the
left subtree and finally the right
subtree in the pre-order traversal case
in order traversal case we first
traverse the left subtree then the root
node and finally the right subtree and
in the post order traversal case v
traverse the left subtree then the right
subtree and finally traverse through the
root node
and finally we exit the display tree
function and move on to the main
function we assign the values 5 as the
root node then 10 20 and 30 as the left
notes and similarly 15 25 and 35 as the
right notes and then we call the three
tree traversals that is preorder in
order and post order to traverse the
tree and finally we release the root
mode
now let us try to execute this program
and see the output
so there you go the program got
successfully executed and you can see
that the output has been displayed on my
screen so the pre-order traversal is 5
10 20 25 15 30 and 35
followed by the pre-order traversal we
have the in order traversal that is 20
10 25 5 30 15 and 35 and finally we have
the post order traversal that is 20 25
10 30 35 15 and 5
and with that let me give you a simple
question
so what is the pre-order and post-order
traversal of this binary search tree so
the elements are one two three four five
six and seven you need to find out the
pre-order and post-order traversal of
this binary tree and you can let us know
the answer in the comment sections below
with that we have come to an end of this
tutorial on tree traversal in data
structure
hey everyone welcome to simply learn's
youtube channel in this session we will
learn about binary trees in data
structures but before we begin let me
tell you guys that we have daily updates
on multiple technologies if you are a
tech geek in a continuous hunt for
latest technological trends then
consider getting subscribed to our
youtube channel and don't forget to hit
that bell icon to never miss an update
from simply learn
now without further ado let's get
started with the agenda for today's
discussion
so we shall begin our session by
learning a binary tree and some basic
terms related to binary tree then we
will try to implement it in the code
editor after that we will discuss its
properties then we will discuss
different types of binary trees then we
will try various operations on them like
traversal insertion and deletion
and finally we will take a glance on
what are our final key takeaways from
this session but before we begin make
sure that you have subscribed to our
youtube channel and click on that bell
icon to never miss an update from simply
learn
so without further ado let's get started
with our first topic that is what
exactly is a binary tree
so it is a treated structure in which
each node can have at most two child
nodes these nodes are referred to as
left child in node and right child node
next let's discuss about some terms
related to binary tree
first up a node a node consists of data
and linked to its both child nodes
next the root node root node is the
first node of the tree next leaf nodes
these are the nodes which has no child
next parent node apart from the root
node any node which has at least one
child is called as parent to that child
node next up a child node any node with
a parent is called as a child node
next up is the internal node any node
with a child and a parent is called as
an internal node next up is the height
of the binary tree the longest path from
the root to any leaf node is called as
the height of the binary tree
next up is the depth of the binary tree
the depth of the node is the total
number of edges from the root node to
the target node or the
last child node
now let's try to implement the binary
tree in the code editor
as you can see now we are on the code
editor and the code on my screen is an
example for binary tree now here you can
see that we have created a structure for
node followed by that we have a function
where we will print the tree
and this is our main function
now don't worry about the code this
particular code segment will be
available in our description box below
and you can always have access to it and
try to edit and run this code on your
own local system to have a better
learning experience now without further
ado let's try to run this program
quickly and see the output
so there you go the code got
successfully executed and here you can
see the output of this particular binary
tree
now let's get back to the theory part
so as discussed before followed by the
implementation part we will learn about
the properties of a binary tree
now let's discuss the properties of the
binary trees
first up maximum number of nodes at a
level l is 2 to the power l next up
maximum number of nodes in a binary tree
of height h is equals to 2 to the power
of h minus 1.
next up minimum possible height in a
binary tree with two nodes is equals to
log of l plus one base two
next up the minimum possible level in a
binary tree with n nodes is equals to
log of l plus one base two
finally a binary tree with l leaves has
at least
log l base two plus one levels
now let's discuss about the different
types of binary trees
first up we have the full binary tree
followed by that we have the complete
binary tree then we have the perfect
binary tree
followed by that we have the balanced
binary tree and lastly the degenerate
binary tree let's discuss about these in
detail first up full binary tree a full
binary tree is a unique tree data
structure in which a node can have
either two children or no child
next a complete binary tree
so a complete binary tree is another
specific binary tree where each node on
all levels except the last level must
have two children and at the lowest
level all leaves should reside possibly
on the left side
the next one is the perfect binary tree
a binary tree is perfect if every node
must have two children and every leaf is
on the same level
the next one is called as the balanced
binary tree
a binary tree is balanced if for each
node the height of the left subtree and
the height of the right subtree varies
at most by just one
at last we have the degenerate binary
tree
a binary tree is said to be degenerate
if every internal node has only one
child
we have now discussed the binary tree
some terms and properties related to
binary trees and types of binary trees
now we will look into the operations
that needs to be performed on the binary
tree so there are basically three types
of operations that can be performed on
binary tree which are traversal
insertion and deletion
so first we'll look into the traversal
operations
there are three different types of
traversal operations possible on binary
tree which are pre-order traversal
in-order traversal and finally the post
order traversal
now let's get back into the text editor
mode and try to execute our example
so right now we are on the text editor
and this particular code is for the
traversal operations on our
binary tree and here you can see we have
the structure for node and we have also
the in order function
pre-order function and post order
function and don't worry about the code
this particular code will be available
in the description box below and after
you have written the code we have some
standard input over here you can see
that we are giving the number of edges
as four and the left subtree elements
are two and one and the right subtree
elements are two and three and another
left subtree elements are
three and five and lastly we have five
and six for another left subtree now
let's try to execute this code
now we have already executed the code
and we also have the output over here
and here you can see we have entered the
number of edges as for and the traversal
is in order traversal which is one two
six five and three and the pre-order
traversal output is two
one three five six and the post order
traversal is one six five three and two
now let's get back to the ppt now we
have the insertion operation
and now let's get back to our text
editor and try to see an example for
insertion operation as well
so on my screen you can see an example
for insertion operation
so here we have the insert function
as i said this particular code will be
available
in the description box below now let's
provide the standard input
so the standard input will be four edges
and we have two and one as the left
subtree and two and three as right
subtree three and five as left subtree
again and
five and six as the left subtree now
let's quickly run this code
and there you go the program got
successfully executed and here we have
the
output
the nodes got inserted and it has
provided an in order traversal that is
one two six five and three
now let's get back to the presentation
and the last type of operation is the
deletion operation let's quickly execute
an example based on deletion operation
as well
now as you can see we are on the text
editor again now here the example is for
deletion operation we have the delete
function over here
now for this particular program we don't
need any standard inputs so just let's
run the program
so there you go the program got
successfully executed and we have the
output over here and in order traversal
before deletion and in order traversal
after the deletion of an element
so the deleted element is element 11.
now with that let's get back to the
presentation mode again
so that's how the element got deleted
now we have reached to the last part of
this session that happens to be the
final key takeaways
so what are the final takeaways so
binary tree is faster at search
operations than other type of tree
and it is easier to find maximum and
minimum elements in the binary tree
binary tree does not allow duplicate
values and graph traversal is done using
binary tree it is used to convert the
post fixed expressions into the prefix
expressions so these were the final
takeaways
now with that we have come to an end of
this session on binary trees hey
everyone i am baba kundawa and i welcome
you all to simply learns youtube channel
in this session we will talk about
binary search trees
we shall begin our session by
introducing binary search trees
then we will discuss some of the
properties of binary search trees
after that we will try various
operations on them like insertion and
deletion
finally we will sum up what we have
learned from this session
but before we begin make sure you have
subscribed to our youtube channel and
clicked on the bell icon below so you
never miss an update from simply run
so without any further ado let's get
started with introduction to binary
search tree
binaries history is a set of nodes
organized in such a manner that they all
have the same binary search tree
characteristics
a key and a value is assigned to each
node
the requested key is compared to the
keys in binary search tree
so during search if the key is found
then the corresponding value
will be retrieved
next up
properties of binary search tree
first up
the left subtree of a node contains only
nodes with keys lesser than the
parent node
next up
the right subtree of a node contains
only nodes that are greater than the
parent node
the left and the right subtree each must
also be a binary search tree
next let's discuss what are the
operations we can perform on a
binary search tree
first up insertion
last deletion
let's discuss them in detail
first up insertion
we can insert a node
in a such a way so that we obey binary
search tree rules that is the
new node should be either less than the
parent node if it's a it's on the left
subtree or if it's on the right subtree
it should be greater than the parent
node let's execute this in the code
editor
we will start by creating a class for
the binary search tree
so
class pst
hint data
and bst pointers
left
comma
right
next we will define some functions
publicly
public
first default constructor
and a parameterized constructor
a function to insert the value
and a function to traverse the node
now let's write default constructors
definition
so bst
psd
foreign
now let's write the parameterized
constructors definition
bst
and
value
data
is equals to value
and left
is equals to null
and
right
equals to null
now let's write the definition for the
insert function
so bst
star root
comma
and
value
now we will check if the tree is empty
or not
so if
root
then we will insert the first node
we will return
new
estimate
otherwise we will insert the data so if
value
is greater than
root
tata
then
then we have to insert it
in the right subtree
so
root
right
is equals to
insert
root
right
comma
value
else
else the value should be inserted in the
left
side
so root
left
is equal to
insert
root
left
comma value
and then we will return
root
now let's write the traverse function
so void
est
root
if
and we will return
otherwise we will first traverse
left side
then we will print the root data
then we will traverse
the right side
root
right
now let's write the main block
so we will start with an empty tree so
bst
b
comma
star root
is equals to null
the root
is equals to
b dot insert
root
comma
d dot
insert
equals to
root comma 10
b dot insert
sorry we already use 50 so we will use
a dot insert
root comma
let's use 20
let's try to traverse this
so b dot
traverse
root
let's execute this
as you can see we have successfully
created and traversed our first binary
search tree
let's get back to slides
at last deletion
we will delete a node following the
binary search tree rules that is the
value of the left subtree should be less
than the parent node and the value of
the right subtree should be greater than
the parent node
let's try these in the code editor
let's start by creating a node
this time we will use structure
substruct
node
comma
right
now we will create a utility function to
create a new binary search tree node
so struct
node
star
new node
and
item
or
star
amp
equals to
product
size of
node
next
amp
will be assigned the key
is equals to item
amp
left
equals to null
and
damp
right
is equal to
now let's write
a function to traverse the tree
traverse
product
node
star
route
so if
root
is equal to null
traverse
route
left
see out
root
e
covers
right
now let's write a utility function to
insert the new node with the given key
in the binary search tree
substruct
node
comma
and
key
so if
node
is equals to null
then we will return
new node
key
otherwise
we will recur down the tree so if
e
is less than
the node key
then we will
insert in the left subtree so node
left
is equals to insert
code
comma
key
else
node right
would be inserting
e
now let's return the node
now we have given a non-empty binary
search tree
so we have to return the node with the
minimum key value found in that tray
so
we will start
struct
mode
star
men
star mode
node
star
current
is equal to node
so we will loop down to find the
leftmost leaf
so while
current
and
parents left
is not equals to null
so current
should be equals to
current
return
delete
node
product
note star
loop
comma
and
key
f
root
equals to null
return
root
now if the key to be related is smaller
than the roots key then it lies in the
left subtree so we will check
if
e
less than
root key
then root
left
it will be equals to
delete
node
root
left key
comma key
now if the key is deleted
is greater than the roots key then it
lies in the right subtree so else
if
e
is greater than root
root
right
is equals to
delete
node
root
right
comma key
else
if
roots
dot left
equals to null
and
root
dot right
is equals to null
and return
else
if
root
left equals to null
then struct
node
is equals to
root
right
and free
root
return
temp
else if
roots
right
is equals null
then struck
outstar
temp
is equal to root
three
route
return
amp
now note with the two children get the
in order successor
smallest in the right subtree
so struct
node
star
temp
is equals to
min value
node
root
right
now we will copy the inorder successors
content to this node so root
is equals to temp
now we will delete the in order
successor so root
right
equals to
delete
node
root
right
comma
temp
now we will return
root
now let's write the main block
we will start with an empty tree
product
node star
route
is equal to
null
now root is equals to
insert
root comma
two
root
is equals to insert
comma 5
root
is equals to insert
comma
root
is equals to insert
root comma 4
root
is equals to
insert
root comma
and root
equals to insert
root comma
six
let's try to traverse this so see out
traversal
of the given
i was
root
now first we will delete a value c out
delete
two
our root is equals to
delete
node
root comma
true
see out
traversal
after
deleting
traverse
root
let's execute this
as you can see we have successfully
deleted
to and traverse the tree again
let's get back to our slides
at last let's sum up what we have
learned from this session
first of left side nodes are always
lesser than the parents node and the
right side node are always more than the
parent node
next it is easier to search and sort
elements in a binary search tree
finally a binary search tree offers
faster insertion and deletion operations
and this was all for today's session
hello everyone welcome to simply learns
youtube channel
today we will be discussing about
recursion in programming in today's
video we have an interesting quiz for
you guys so stay tuned and do leave your
answers for the quiz that's going to pop
up on your screens in next few minutes
but before we begin let me tell you guys
that we have daily updates on multiple
technologies so if you are a tech geek
in a continuous hunt for latest
technological advancements then consider
getting subscribed to our youtube
channel and don't forget to hit that
bell icon to never miss an update from
simply learn
now without any further ado let's get
started with the agenda for today's
session
we'll start this session by
understanding what is recursion
followed by that we'll find out how
recursion gets executed in memory area
once done with that we'll look into
different types of recursion and finally
we will implement a program that
demonstrate the concept of recursion i
hope i made myself clear with the agenda
now let's get started with our first
topic what is recursion
well recursion is a process in which a
function repeatedly calls itself either
directly or indirectly those calls are
majorly done by explicitly calling
function by its name however it can also
be accomplished by implicit calling as
well the fundamental idea behind calling
the function over and over again is to
break a larger problem into smaller sub
problems
we do this for reducing the
computational complexity of a larger
problem by breaking it into several
pieces this tactic is also called as
divide and conquer approach in
programming so now you must be thinking
about how we can break the larger
problem into smaller sub problems
well to do that we break the given
problem statement into two parts the
first one is base case and the second
one is recursive step
the base case is nothing but the
simplest instance of a problem that
consists of condition which holds the
recursive function
given the function calls argument this
base case computes the output of our
program right away
whereas in the recursive step we compute
the result using one or more recursive
calls to the same function but with the
inputs decrease in size or complexity
to understand this breakdown
let's have a look at mathematical aspect
of recursion
suppose you have to formulate a
mathematical function for computing the
sum of n natural numbers that means the
function that you are going to create
must calculate the summation of all
natural numbers in the range 0 to n
mathematically it can be represented as
summation of all numbers from k is equal
to 0 to k is equal to n
now the critical question here is how
can we actually represent this in form
of recursive function
the answer is quite simple all we need
to do is break this larger problem into
small fragments we can represent this
problem as n plus sum of all natural
numbers till n minus 1.
this process of traversing in function f
n minus 1 times is called the recursive
step of our problem statement
whereas the base case is a condition
which is stopping the recursion when k
is reaching value 0. in terms of
programming it can be represented using
a vlog now i hope you guys have
understood how we can break a larger
problem into smaller sub problems moving
further we are going to understand how
recursion gets executed in memory area
in order to do that we'll take this c
program as an example in this program we
have two methods the main method
contains one variable and the statement
that invokes a function named fun this
function fun is making a recursive call
in its function body we have both base
case and recursive step inside this
function's body
now whenever a function is called its
activation record will be maintained
inside the stack
so for this program we are going to look
into its control flow
as we know the main function gets
invoked primarily by an operating system
thus will include the main function at
first in our memory stack this
activation record will consist of local
variables of function parameters and the
record of return address to the caller
but here for the sake of simplicity we
are just maintaining the local variables
inside the activation record after this
step as you can see the main function is
activating method 1 with argument 3.
once activated it will prompt 3 on
screen and will invoke fun 3-1 that is
fun2 now again as 2 is greater than 0
the control will invoke fund 2 minus 1
that is fun1 after this the control will
activate fund 0.
this time once the control enters an if
lock it will execute a return statement
and activation record 0 will get popped
out of the memory stack
further every function inside the memory
stack will get popped out from it which
will result in generation of output the
output that will get printed on the
console for this particular program is 3
2 1.
now here is the interesting question
that we want you all to answer
based on the properties of recursion
that we have discussed till now which of
the following statements seems right to
you the options that we have are
recursion is always better than
iteration option b
recursion uses more memory compared to
the iteration
option c recursion uses less memory
compared to the iteration
it will be interesting to see how many
of you guys will get this right so guys
do leave your answers to this question
in comment section below in a week's
time we'll be announcing the right
answer and you all can check it out now
moving ahead we'll discuss different
types of recursion in programming
there are basically four types of
recursion the first one is direct
recursion the second one is indirect
recursion the third one is tail
recursion and the fourth one is non-tail
recursion so let's discuss direct
recursion
a function is called direct recursive if
it calls itself in its function body
over and over again
to better understand this definition
let's look at the structure of a program
that is direct recursive in nature
in this program we have a method named
fun which is calling itself again and
again in its function body thus we can
say that it is direct recursive in
nature
next up is indirect recursion
the recursion in which the function
calls itself via another function is
called as indirect recursion for example
in this program you can clearly see that
the function fun one is explicitly
calling fund2 which is invoking fun 1
again explicitly hence we can say that
this is an example of indirect recursion
further
we have tail recursion
a recursive function is said to be tail
recursive if the recursive call is the
last execution done by the function
let's try to understand this definition
with the help of an example
if you observe this program you can see
that the last line adi will execute for
method fun is recursive call and because
of that there is no need to remember any
previous state of our program
finally we have a non-tail recursive
function on our list
a recursive function is said to be
non-tell recursive if the recursion call
is not the last thing done by the
function
after returning back there is something
left to evaluate let's consider one
example
in this function you can clearly observe
that there is another operation after
the recursive call hence our adi will
have to memorize the previous state
inside this memory block that is why
this program can be considered as
non-tail recursive
now finally let's implement a program to
demonstrate the recursion
the program that we are going to
implement is solution to the problem
statement that we discussed earlier
according to that problem statement we
have to calculate the sum of n natural
numbers given the number n
now in order to address this problem we
are going to use c programming language
so without any further ado let's head
over to the code editor
now in order to get started with coding
implementation first we'll create an
utility function to calculate sum of n
natural numbers so let's do that
and we'll pass an argument and
n
now we have arrived inside the body of
function sum what we'll first do is
we'll calculate sum of n minus 1 natural
numbers by making and recursive call to
function sum so let's do that
sum
n minus 1
and we'll store this value inside a
temporary variable
now we'll add this temporary variable's
value to n in order to return it as an
result
the statements that we just wrote are
called as recursive steps but if you
observe this statement
we are not putting any limitation to our
recursive call so that is why we'll have
to add base case to our function so
let's do that
f
n equal to equal to 0
then
return
0.
with this we have successfully
implemented a sum function
so let's work on our driver method to
generate the result
in this driver method
first we'll create a variable n
and after that we'll write printf
statement
enter
the natural
number
n
to calculate
the sum of
n numbers
semicolon
and in next line
we'll write scanf statement in order to
take input from our user so
inside this will write modulus d
comma
ambrose in n
and semicolon
and the next statement will make a call
to a sum function in order to calculate
sum of n natural numbers so how we can
do that well we can add modulus d here
comma
sum
and
semicolon
and i hope
our code works fine now so let's check
it
by compiling
here
the console is asking us to provide with
value of variable n and i am going to
provide value 5 here so let's provide
value 5
and enter
so
the output that we are getting is 15
here that means our code works fine
with this successful coding
implementation we came to the end of
this video hey everyone i am
vivekandalwal and i welcome you all to
simplylearn's youtube channel
in this session we will talk about avl
trees we shall begin our session by what
is an avl trees then we will discuss
various rotations we can perform to
balance avl trees then we will discuss
the complexity of avl trees
after that we will try various
operations on them like insertion
deletion
finally we will sum up what we have
learnt from this session
but before we begin make sure you have
subscribed to our youtube channel and
clicked on the bell icon below so you
never miss an update from simply learn's
youtube channel
so let's get started with introduction
to avl trees
an avl tree is a height balanced binary
search tree for each node we have to
make sure that the height of the left
subtree and the right substrate can
differ by at most one
we can calculate this balance factor by
subtracting the height of the left sub
tree from the height of the right
subtree
now let's discuss various rotations we
can perform on avl trees
first up ll rotation next rr rotations
next lr rotation
at last rl rotation
let's discuss them in detail
first up ll rotation it is a clockwise
rotation when a node is inserted on the
left subtree of the left subtree of a
node then we apply this rotation to
balance the tree
it is applied on the node below the
balance factor 2 node that is we will
apply right rotation on the green node
next rr rotation
when a node is inserted into a right
subtree of the right subtree of a node
then we perform rr rotation
it is an anti-clockwise rotation which
is applied on the node below a node
having balance factor minus 2 that is we
will apply it on the green node
next up lr rotation
when a node is inserted into right
subtree of the left sub tree of a node
then we perform lr's rotation
it is a combination of rr and ll
rotation
first we will apply error rotation on
green and yellow node
after this red node is still unbalanced
so we will perform ll rotation on the
yellow node
finally
rl rotation
when a node is inserted into the left
subtree of right subtree of a node then
we perform rl rotation
it is a combination of ll and rr
rotation
first we will apply ll rotation on green
and yellow nodes
after this the red node is still
unbalanced so we will perform rr
rotation on the yellow node
now let's discuss complexity of avl
trees
first up
space complexity is a bigger of n
next up avl tree offers a complexity of
bigger of log n for searching
next up
avl trees offer a complexity of bigger
of log n for insertion
finally avl tree offers a complexity of
bigger of log n of for deletion
we have now introduced an avl tree and
rotations on it
now let's discuss some of the operations
we can perform on avl trees
first up insertion
and deletion
let's discuss them in detail
first up insertion
we will insert a node following binary
search tree rules
then we will check if the nodes are
balanced or not if they are not then we
will balance it by using suitable
rotations
now let's try these operations in a code
editor
let's start by creating a node to create
a node we need a class node
we will create its member as public
and key
node star left
star
right
and
height
now let's write a function to get
maximum of two integers
so
max
a
comma
and b
now let's declare of utility function to
get maximum of two integers
so int
max
a
comma
end
v
now let's write a function to get the
height of the tree
and
height
node
star
n
now if
n is null
then we will return zero
else
we will return
and calls
now let's write that function to get
maximum of two integers
hint
max
and a
comma
and b
we will return
if
a is greater than b
then we will return a
else we will return b
now let's write a helper function that
allocates a new node with a given key
and null left and right pointers
so node
star
new node
and
key
star
node
goes to new
so node
key
will be equals to key
node
left
will be equals to
f
node
left
will be equals to null
and
node
write
will be equals to null
and node
height
will be equals to
1.
and
return
node
here we have kept height as 1 because at
the new node is initially added at leaf
so by default it will always be at 1.
now let's write a utility function to
write rotate subtree rooted with y
node
star
right
would start why
now node
star x
is equals to
y is left
and
node
star
e2
is equals to
x
right
now we will perform rotation so
x right
will become y
and
y is left
become t2
now we will update the heights so y
height
is equals to max
of
height
of y left
plus one
now
x
height
equals to
maximum off
height
x
left
comma
height
of
x
right
plus one
now return
x
now let's write a utility function to
left rotate subtree rooted with x
node
left rotate
star x
node
star y
will be equals to
access right
and
node star t2
will be equals to xs
sorry
why is
now we will perform rotation so y
left
will be equals to x
and
x
right
will be equals to t2
now let's update height so x
height
is equals to
maximum of
height
of
excess left
comma height
of
access right
and
wise height
equals to maximum of
height
of
y's left
comma
height
wise write
return
y
now let's write a function to get
balance vector of node n
so end
that
balance
argument as node pointer
and
if
n is n is equals to null
then we will return
otherwise
we will return
height
of
ends
left
minus
height of
hence write
now let's write a recursive function to
insert the key in the subtree rooted
with node and returns the new root of
the subtree
so
node
star
insert
notes
star
node
comma hint
key
now we'll perform the normal bst
insertion so if
node is equals to
null
then we will return
new
node
key
now if
this key
is
less
than nodes key
then
node
left
will equals to
insert
node
left
comma key
or else
we will insert that in the right node
right
is equals to
insert
node
type
comma
key
now we will return node
this if else will make sure that we will
reach to the leaf node and then we will
insert the key
now we will update the height of the
sensor node
so node
height
is equals to 1 plus
max
height
of
mode
comma
height
of
node
right
now we will get the balance factor for
this ancestor node to check whether this
node became unbalanced so int
balance
is equals to get
now if this node becomes unbalanced then
there are four cases
so if
balance
is greater than one
and
e
is less than
node
left
key
then we will return
write
rotate
note
this if statement for the left left case
so or ll case
now let's write it for the right right
case or rr case
so if
balance
is less than -1
and
e
is greater than
node
right
key
then
we will return
left
rotate
node
now write for the left right case or lr
case so
if balance
is greater than one
and
e
is greater than node
left
key
the node
left
is equals to
rotate
node
left
i'll return
right
rotate
now let's write the right left case or
rl case
so if
balance
is less than -1
and
key
is less than
node
to the right
key
node
right
will be equals to
light
rotate
node
to the right
and we will return
left
shortly
now we will return this node
now let's write a function to print
pre-order traversal of this tree
so void
pre-order
code
star route
so now if
root
is not
null then
c out
root
key
and now pre
order
root
and pre-order
now let's write the code for the main
block
we will start with an empty tree
node
star route
is equal to null
now we will try to construct tree
the root
is equals to
insert
root
comma 10
a root is equals to
insert
root comma
root
is equals to insert
comma
to
root
is equals to insert
comma
root
is equals to insert
root comma
and root is equals to insert
um
now let's try to print this
so c out
behavior
is equals to
in
order
spray order
root
let's execute this
as you can see we have successfully
created our first av tree
let's get back to slides
at last deletion
we will delete a node following a binary
search tree rules
then we will check if all the nodes are
balanced or not if they are not then we
will balance it by using suitable
rotations
now let's try these operations in a code
later
let's start by creating a node to create
a node we need a class
node
we will define its members as public
and key
note star
left
node star
right
end
height
now
let's write a utility function to get
height of the tree so end
height
node
star
n
f
n is equals to null
then in that case we will return
otherwise we will return
hence height
now let's write a utility function to
get maximum of two integer
and
max
so we will return
if
a is greater than b
then a
else
b
now let's write a helper function that
allocates a new node with a given key
and null left and right pointers
so node
star
new
node
end
key
so node
star
new node
is equals to new
node
parenthesis
now newnode
will get key
as
key
new node
left
is equals to null
and new node
right
is equals to null
and new nodes
height
is equals to 1
because new node is initially added as
leaf
that's why it is always be given as 1.
now we will return this node return
node
now let's write a utility function to
right rotate a sub tree rooted with y
so node
are
right
rotate
node
star
y
star x
is equals to
y left
node
star t2
is equals to
x
right
now we will perform rotation so x
is equals to
y y
left
is equals to t2
now we will update heights
so why
high
equals to maximum of
height
of
y's left
comma
height
of
vice
right
plus one
and
x height
is equals to
maximum of
height
of
axis left
comma
access right
plus one
now we will return this new route so
return
x
now we will write
node
star
left rotate
node star
x
node star y
will be equals to access right
and
our star t2
will be equals to y's left
now we will perform rotation so y
left
equals to x
and x
right
is equals to t2
now we will update these heights so x
height
is equals to maximum of
of x
left
comma
height
of
x
right
plus 1
and
y's height
is equals to
max
of height
of
y's left
comma height
of
y's
right
plus one
now we will return this y
now we will write a function to get
balance factor of node n
so int
cat
get balance
node star n
so if
n is equals to null
then we will return
zero
otherwise we will return
height
of
ends left
minus
height
of
ends right
now let's write a function to insert a
node
so node
star insert
star
node
comma
end
key
now we will perform normal bst rotation
so if
node
is equals to null
and we will return
new node
key
so now
if
key
is less than node key
then
node
left
will be equals to insert
node
left
comma key
now if
e
is greater than node key
then
node
right
is equals to
insert
node
write
comma key
else
we will return node
because equal keys are not allowed
now we will update the height of the
ancestral node
so node
height
is equals to
1 plus
max
height
of node
left
comma height
of
node
right
now we will get the balance factor of
this ancestor node to check whether this
node becomes unbalanced
so if
end
balance
equals to
that
balance
of this node
now if this node becomes unbalanced then
there are four cases that could be
possible
first up llks
so if
balance
is greater than
one
and
key
is less than
node
left
return
right
rotate
mode
now let's write right right case
so if
balance
is less than -1
and
key is
greater than node
write
key
then we will return
left
rotate
node
now
let's write left right case
so if
balance
is greater than one
and
e
is greater than node
left
key
and
node
left
will be equals to
left rotate
and we will return
write
rotate
now let's write the case for right left
case
if
balance
is less than minus one
and
e
is less than
node
right
so node
right is equals to
write rotate
node
right
now we will return
left
rotate
note
now let's return the unchanged node
pointer
so return
node
now let's write a function to find
minimum value node
so node star
min
value
node
node star node
so node
star
current
equals to node
so while
current
left
is not equals to null
is equals to
current
at left
now we will return current
now we will write a recursive function
to delete a node with the given key from
subtree with the given root
so node
star
delete node
its arguments are
not pointer root
comma
end key
starters we will perform standard bst
delete so if
root
is equals to null
then we will return
root
now if the key to be deleted is smaller
than the root key then it lies in the
left subtree so
if
e
is less than
root
e
then
root
left
will be equals to
delete
node
root
to the left
comma key
now if key to be deleted is greater than
the root key then it lies in the right
subtree
so else
if
e is greater than root
e
then
root
right
equals to
node
root
height
comma key
now if the key is same as the root key
then this is the node to be deleted so
else
f
root
to the right
is equals to null
then node
star
temp
is equals to root
left
now if
temp
is equals to null
then temp
will be equal to root
and root
will equals to null
else
root
will be equals to star temp
and free
damp
it's
node
star temp
is equals to
min value node
root
right
now we will copy the inorder successors
data to this node
so root
e
is equals to temp
key
now we will delete this in order
successor so root
write
is equals to
delete
node
key
now if
root
is equal to null
then we will return
root
now we will update the height of the
current node
so root
right
is equals to 1 plus
max
of height
of roots
left
comma
height
up
comma height
up root
height
now we will get the balance factor of
this node
so
end
balance
is equals to
get
balance
root
if this node becomes unbalanced then
there are four cases
first up ll case
so if
balance is greater than one
and
that balance
of
roots
left
is greater than equals to zero
then we will return
right rotate
now if
balance
is greater than one
and
get balance
of root
left
less than zero
then
root
left will equals to left rotate
left
now we will return
write
rotate
now let's write right right case so if
balance
less than minus 1
and
cat balance
is less than equals to zero
then we will return
left
rotate
now we will write right left case so if
balance
is less than minus 1
and
get balance
of root
right
is greater than zero
then
root
light
is equals to
write
rotate
right
now we will return
left
rotate
and we will return this route
now let's write a function to print
pre-order traversal of this tree
so void
free
order
style root
so if
root
not equals to
null
and c out
root
e
preorder
root
duct
and pre-order
root
right
now let's write a code for the main
block
we will start with an empty tree so node
root
is equals to
null
now
root is equals to insert
root comma
two
root
is equals to insert
root comma
root is equals to insert
root
comma
is equals to insert
root
comma
root is equals to insert
root comma 5.
root
is equals to insert
root comma three
now let's try and print this of avl tray
so see out
created
avl
reorder
harder
now we will delete a node so root
is equals to delete
node
root
comma
done
now let's again try and print this
so see out
modified
behavior
tree
pre-order
after
deletion
of
10.
layout
handle
pre order
root
now let's execute this
as you can see our deletion function is
working perfectly
now let's get back to our slides
at last let's sum up what we have
learned from this session
first up avl trees is a self balancing
binary search tree
next every node must have a balance
factor of either -1 0 or 1. next after
every rotation we must verify if each
node is balanced or not
finally avl trees offers fast insertion
and deletion operations
and this was all for today's session hey
everyone welcome to simply learns
youtube channel in this session we will
learn about bubble sort its complete
logic and how to program and implement
it in real time let us take a look at
the agenda for today's discussion and
meanwhile be kind enough to get
subscribed to our youtube channel and
don't forget to hit that bell icon to
never miss an update from simply learn
first we will begin with understanding
what is bubble sort algorithm next we
will understand the working procedure of
bubble sort algorithm after that we will
understand the pseudo code of bubble
sort algorithm later we will learn the
optimized bubble sort algorithm and next
we will see some varieties of bubble
sort algorithms
after that we will understand the
complexities of the bubble sort
algorithm and finally we can wind up the
session with application of bubble sort
algorithm i hope the agenda was clear
hoping we are good to go let's get
started with our first topic
let's try to understand what is a bubble
sort algorithm
the bubble sort algorithm is one of the
fundamental and simplest forms of
algorithm used to sort a collection of
elements the collection of elements can
be either a set of numbers or characters
the control iterates through a sequence
of numeric or character type elements in
the bubble sort algorithm and rearranges
them into ascending or descending order
the bubble sort algorithm rearranges one
element at a time
the bubble sort algorithm is also known
as the sinking algorithm
here we have some random distributed
elements which are 30
50 and 40 and after performing the
bubbles out algorithm all the elements
are sorted as 10
40 and 50.
so how is it done
we will see in the next segment where we
will understand the working
terminologies of bubble sort algorithm
the bubble sort algorithm will not get
implemented on the entire array in one
go instead it compares two adjacent
pairs of elements in an array if the
elements are not in the correct order
then they are swapped so the largest of
the two moves towards the right and this
process continues until the most
significant element or bubble is moved
towards the highest position
after the first process is finished the
search for the next most significant
object starts
and the swapping continues until the
whole array is in correct order this
process is employed when you want to
arrange the elements in ascending order
to understand the logic in a better way
let's go through an example
the example on my screen consists of
five elements according to the bubble
sort algorithm logic we need four
iterations to sort all the elements in
the ascending order or in descending
order
the elements in the array are as follows
they are 3
8 4 2 and 12. so in this array the index
begins with 0 and ends with 4
and each time the bubble sort algorithm
goes through the data element list and
it is known as a pass
let us analyze the total number of
comparisons required to sort the array
in the correct order according to the
formula
if n is the total number of elements in
an array then the total number of
comparisons needed to sort the entire
array can be calculated by a simple
formula shown on my screen that is
n
is equals to n minus 1.
so in this scenario we need 5 minus 1
that is 4 comparisons or passes to sort
the entire array in the first pass there
are 4 steps
let us select the first two elements
that is three and eight according to the
requirement we need to sort this array
in the ascending order hence when we
compare three and eight clearly we get
three as the least number so we do not
need to swap them
next is the step 2 comparing the second
and third elements which are 8 and 4.
here we need to swap these two elements
because
8 is always greater than four and it
requires placing the elements in the
ascending order now moving ahead we have
step three moving on to the third and
fourth elements which are eight and two
and here again we need to swap eight
with two because 8 is greater than 2
and in the step 4 we have we have the
last elements which are 8 and 12. there
is no need to swap because 8 is already
less than 12 so you can see it clearly
so now we enter into pass two and in
pass two we need three steps
so the first step in the second pass let
us select the first two elements which
are three and four
no swapping is necessary as they're
already in order
next we have step 2
in step 2 we need to select the elements
2 and 4. as you can see 2 is always less
than 4 so there is no swapping required
next we have step 3 in step 3 we need to
compare the elements 4 and 8 and here we
may not need any switching because 4 is
already less than 8. now here you can
see that we are not comparing 8 and 12
because the last element is already
sorted now we have come to the last pass
and here there is only one step the step
is to compare the first two elements 2
and 3 and then swap them as 3 is greater
than 2. now the array is finally sorted
and we do not need to do any more
comparisons
after understanding the working process
of the bubble sort algorithm we will see
its pseudo code in this pseudo code
there is a function named as bubble sort
the bubble sort function includes an
array of collections of sortable
elements let us consider n as the length
of the array after that we have to
repeat comparisons for the first element
to the last element of the array
if the first element is greater than its
next consecutive element then we must
swap both the elements and place them
correctly we do not need to switch after
closing this repeated statement and
getting out of the loop this bubble sort
function will end after understanding
the pseudo code of the bubble sort
algorithm let's learn about the
optimized bubble sort algorithm so we
can optimize the algorithms in a loop by
programming it to avoid the comparison
at n minus 1 position after every
iteration since the nth element is
already sorted in the previous iteration
more generally
more than one element may be placed in
their final position on a single pass
all the elements after the last swap are
sorted in every pass and do not need to
be rechecked optimized bubble sort
algorithm allows skipping over many
elements this results in a worst case
that is 50 improvement in comparison
count and adds little complexity because
of the new code sub sums the swapped
variable
next we will learn variations of the
bubble sort algorithm so there are two
variations of the bubble sort algorithm
they are
odd even sort and cocktail shaker so odd
even sort is a parallel version of
bubble sort for the message passing
system
whereas cocktail shaker is a sort of
bi-directional bubble sort that first
goes from beginning to the end and ends
to the beginning after knowing the
variation of the bubble sort algorithm
now we will see the complexity of bubble
sort algorithm
so the best case of the bubble sort
algorithm is big o of n where n is the
number of elements being sorted and
worst and average cases of the bubble
set algorithm are big o of n into n and
lastly the space complexity of the
bubble sort algorithm is big of one here
n is the number of data elements being
sorted let us understand when this
complexity occurs the best case of
bubble sort algorithm is o of n which
occurs at all the data elements in an
array are already sorted here we have an
example with some data elements in an
array which are already sorted that is
10 20 30 40 and 50.
next talking about the average and worst
case the worst case and average case of
the bubble set algorithm is o of n to
the power 2 that is n squared or n into
n it occurs when all the data elements
in an array are reversely sorted again
we have an example that consists of data
elements that are reversely sorted that
are 50 40 30 20 and 10 in a narrate
lastly we have space complexity the
space complexity of bubble sort
algorithm is o of one because only one
additional variable is required to
implement bubbles or algorithm that is
temporary variable we came to the last
topic where we will understand four main
applications of bubble sort algorithm
first application of bubble sort
algorithm states that this sorting
technique is used to sort the elements
in a specific order the bubble sort
algorithm uses less storage and is the
second application of bubble sort
algorithm third the real life
application states that the bubble sort
algorithm is used to store the students
based on their height in the line
lastly bubble sort is used to create a
stack pile up the elements based on
their height after covering all the
bubble sort algorithm topics we will now
see a practical demonstration of bubble
sort algorithm
now on my screen we have an example for
bubble sort algorithm so let us get
started with the code in this code at
the first position we have some header
files that is standard input output
standard library etc
after that we will define the main
function in the main function we will
declare an array with maximum size of
50. so here you can see that we have the
first array variable that size is 50.
size will be defined by declaration only
because we cannot change the array size
in the run time after that we will
declare four variables that is a
b
num and temp
non variable will store the number of
elements of an array after that we will
ask the user how many elements are
required for the array using printf
function
so here is the printf function where we
will be asking the
user to enter the number of elements in
an array and the user will enter the
elements and this will be done using
scanf function then finally we will
print all the elements that the user
wants to store in an array using another
printf function
we will have three loops firstly there
will be a loop from the first element to
the last element of the array so this is
the first for loop we need then second
the for loop will use the variable a for
the rotation purpose as we know rotation
equal to number of elements minus 1 so
it will make a loop from index 0 to
number minus 1.
the last loop is used for how many
passes will be required for the
implementation and we already pass
equally to the number of elements minus
number of rotations minus 1. so there is
the loop from index 0 to number minus a
minus 1 then there will be
the if condition stating that if the
first element of an array at index b is
greater than the element at the index b
plus 1 then we will make swap then we
will come out of the loop and we will
print all the array elements after
performing the bubble sort algorithm now
let's quickly execute this program and
see the output
so you can see the program got
successfully executed now let us enter
the number of elements let me choose 5.
now let us enter the elements in a
random order
so this was the array input three two
four one and five and here after
executing the bubble sort algorithm we
have the sorted array that is one two
three four and five
and with that we have come to an end of
this tutorial hope the video was helpful
and informative
hey everyone i am vivokandalwal and i
welcome you all to simply learns youtube
channel in this session we will discuss
insertion sort algorithm we shall begin
our session by introducing insertion
sort
then we will discuss insertion sort
algorithm after that we will implement
the insertion sort algorithm in the code
editor
finally we will sum up what we have
learnt from this session
but before we begin make sure you have
subscribed to our youtube channel and
clicked on the bell icon below so you
never miss an update from simply learn's
youtube channel so without any further
ado let's get started with an
introduction to insertion sort
insertion sort is basically a sorting
algorithm in which each item in the
final sorted array is sorted one at a
time
and it is significantly less efficient
than more sophisticated algorithms like
quick sort heap sort or merge sort on
larger data sets
now let's discuss the algorithm of
insertion sort
let's say we have an array
we will start with traversing the array
from index 1 to n minus 1.
while traversing we will compare
elements at the current index to its
predecessor
if the data at the current index is
smaller than its predecessor then we
will compare it with the element before
that
after that we will shift bigger elements
to an index up to make space for swapped
elements
then we will shift the bigger elements
to an index up to make space for the
swapped element and then we will iterate
the same steps again to sort the
complete array
we have now introduced the insertion
sort and its algorithm
now let's implement this algorithm in
the code editor
we will start with creating a function
to sort an array using session sort so
void
insertion sort
we will give it argument as end
array arr
comma and
size
we will declare variables and i
comma key
comma j
now
we will create a loop for loop
from i is equals to
to i less than
size
i plus plus
here we are traversing this array from
index 1 to the size n minus 1.
so key
is equals to
ar
at i
and j is equals to
i minus 1
now we will move the elements of arr 0
to i minus 1 that are greater than the
key to one position ahead of the current
position
so while
j
is greater than equals to
zero
and
arr at j
is greater than key
and we will swap these
so a ir
at j plus 1
is equals to a r r
f j
and j will be equals to j minus 1
and then we will assign arr j plus 1
is equals to key
now we will write a function to print
this array
of size
void
print
array
we will give its argument as end
and
size size
we will declare end i is equals to zero
for loop
i is equal to zero
i
less than size
i plus plus
c out
arr
bracket eye
and say out
handle
now we will write the main block
so end
arr
is equals to
12 comma
11 comma 15 comma
9 comma 6 comma 7.
and
size is equals to we will find the size
using size of
so size is equals to
size of
arr
divided by size of
arr at index 0.
now we will print this array without
sorting
so see out
unsorted array
we will print
array
comma size
now we will call insertion sort
arr comma size
c out
we will print this
array
sorted
now we will again call print
array
argument as arr comma
size
now let's print this
as you can see our function is working
flawlessly it has sorted this array
let's get back to our slides
at last let's sum up what we have
learned from this session
first up insertion sort is efficient for
arrays with small data sets
next up insertion sort require a
constant amount of extra memory
next insertion sort can only sort a
single element at a time
and finally insertion sort has the worst
complexity of big o of n square
and this was all for today's session
hope you guys found it informative and
helpful hey everyone i am pepper
kandalwal and i welcome you all to
simply launch youtube channel in this
session we will discuss selection sort
algorithm
we shall begin our session by
introducing selection sort then we will
discuss selection sort algorithm
after that we will implement selection
sort algorithm in the code editor
finally we will sum up what we have
learned from this session
before we begin make sure you have
subscribed to our youtube channel and
clicked on the bell icon below so you
never miss an update from simply learn's
youtube channel
so without any further ado let's get
started with an introduction to
selection sort
the selection sort algorithm is an
in-place comparison based method that
divides the list into two halves with
the sorted portion on the left and the
unsorted half on the right
then the smallest element from the
unsorted array is chosen and swapped
with the leftmost element and that
element is added to the sorted error
now let's discuss the selection sort
algorithm
let's say we have an array
first we will divide this array in two
sub arrays unsorted array and sorted
array
then we will divide the minimum element
from the unsorted array and swap it with
the leftmost element of this unsorted
array after that we will add it to the
unsorted array
we will keep repeating this process
until there are no elements left on the
unsorted array
we have now introduced selection sort
and its algorithm
now let's implement this algorithm in
the code editor
we will start by creating a function
swap
argument will be integer pointer
x
comma
integer pointer
y
you will declare an element temp
to store the value of pointer x
then we will store pointer wise value in
x
and we will store temps value in wire
and that's how we can swap them
next we will write the definition of
selection sort function void
selection sort
argument will be end
array arr
comma
and
n
we will declare variables end i
j
and a min
underscore idx
variable to store the minimum index
now we will one by one move boundaries
of unsorted sub arrays
so for loop
i is equals to 0
where i is less than n minus 1
i plus plus
we will find the minimum element in this
unsorted array so
min
underscore
idx
is equals to i
now for
a is equals to
i plus 1
j less than n
j plus plus
if
array element at j location
is less
than array at the min index
then
min idx
will be updated with j
now we will swap the form minimum
element with the first element
so
we will call swap function
with argument as
ampersand
arr
at min idx
comma
ampersand
arr
at ith location
now we will write a function to print
this array
so void
array
argument as int arr
and its size
and n
uh
and i is equals to 0
i less than
n
i plus plus
layout
arr
at i
layout
and l
now we will write the code for the main
block
so end
arr
is equals to
4 comma 2 comma 1 comma 8 comma 3.
we will find the size of this array so
end n is equals to
size of
array arr
divided by
size of
this array is first element
now we will call selection sort function
argument as arr comma n
then we will try to print this so c out
sorted
array
and we will call the function print
array to print this array
arr comma n
now let's try and execute this program
as you can see we have successfully
sorted this array using selection sort
algorithm
let's get back to our slides
at last let's sum up what we have
learned in this session
first up the selection sort algorithm is
a comparison based in-place algorithm
next the selection sort algorithm is not
appropriate for use data sets
next up selection sort have the worst
complexity of big o of n square
finally it can be beneficial when memory
write is an expensive procedure
and this was all for today's session
hope you guys found it informative and
helpful hey everyone welcome to simply
learn's youtube channel in this session
we will learn about merge sort in data
structures
now let us quickly look into the agenda
for today's session
we will first begin with understanding
what exactly is divide and conquer
algorithm next we will try to define the
merge sort algorithm after that we will
understand the working of merge sort
algorithm later we will learn the pseudo
code of merge sort algorithm after that
we will understand the complexities of
merge sort algorithm
next we will see some of the real-time
applications of merge sort algorithm and
finally we will wind up the session by
understanding some of the important
drawbacks of merge sort algorithm but
before we begin let me tell you guys
that we have daily updates on multiple
technologies so if you are a tech geek
in a continuous hunt for latest
technological trends then consider
getting subscribed to our youtube
channel and don't forget to hit that
bell icon to never miss an update from
simply learn so without further ado
let's get started with our first topic
that is what exactly is divide and
conquer
algorithm a divide and conquer algorithm
iteratively divides a problem into two
or more sub problems of the same or
relative type until they are simple
enough to be solved directly the sub
problem solutions are then integrated to
solve the original problem
there are three steps involved in the
divide and conquer principle that is
divide
conquer and combine
the first step is to divide the
significant problem into smaller sub
problems
the second phase is to conquer the
solutions to all divided sub problems
then the final step is to combine and
merge all of the solutions to create a
definite solution
we will understand this by an example
right here on my screen
suppose we have a large problem we can
use divide and conquer technique to
divide it into n number of sub problems
such as problem 1 problem 2 problem 3
problem 4 and so on until we reach the
problem n
then we conquer all the solutions to the
specified sub problems as solution 1 2 3
4 and so on and finally we match all the
solutions to get one definitive solution
now that was divide and conquer
algorithm followed by that let us get
into merge sort algorithm
so merge sort is one of the most
efficient sorting algorithms it is based
on divide and conquer strategy merge
sort continuously divides a list into
numerous sub-list until each sub-list
contains only one entry then merges all
those sub list into a sorted list
there are four elements on my screen
we have 7 and 3 in the left half and 5
and 2 in the right half after dividing
the four elements in half we combined
all the items in ascending order that is
2 3 5 and 7.
in the next segment we are going to
understand how it happened and we are
going to learn the working procedure of
merge sort algorithm
there are two approaches to implement
the merge sort algorithm the first
method is top down approach and the
second method is bottoms up approach the
first method that is the top-down
approach implies that it begins with the
large picture from then it's broken into
smaller chunks
now the second method that is the
bottom-up technique which starts with a
specific number of jobs and works its
way up to the general
let's have a look at how to implement
the merchant algorithm using top down
approach the top down merge sort
approach is the methodology that uses a
recursion mechanism it starts at the top
and proceeds downwards splitting the
array into two halves making a recursive
call and merging the results until one
gets to the bottom of the array for a
better understanding of the top down
approach method
consider the following scenario right
here on my screen we have an example of
an array of size 6 consisting of
elements 7 3 9 5 6 and 4 starting with 0
and ending with 5
using the following formula we'll divide
the array by its middle that is middle
is equals to left plus right divided by
2.
we have 3 elements on the left and 3
elements on the right near the middle so
according to the drop down strategy we
divide the given array in half resulting
in three elements that is 7 3 and 9 on
the left and 5 6 and 4 on the right next
we sort all these elements in ascending
order by doing so the first half will be
three seven and nine and the right half
will be four five and six and after
merging all of them we will have the
sorted array that is three four five six
and nine
next we will understand the bottoms up
approach
an iterative process is used in bottoms
up merge sort approach it starts with a
single element array and then joins two
neighboring items while also sorting
them
the combined sorted arrays are combined
and sorted again only until one single
unit of the sorted array elements
remains
now let us look at an example right here
on my screen in the first iteration we
will merge pairs of array sizes by 1
sorting each of the 2 elements when you
iterate the array by size 1 the elements
7 and 3 become 3 and 7. similarly nine
and five become five and nine and
finally six and four become four and six
we will merge the pairs of array size by
two in the next iteration with the
bottoms up method as a result the
elements 3 7 and 5 will become 3 5 and 7
and the same way 9 4 and 6 will become 4
6 and 9.
in the last iteration merge pairs of
array size by 3 so that after sorting 3
5 7 4 6 and 9 becomes 3 4 5 6 and 7 as
sorted arrays
after understanding the working
procedure of merge cert algorithm we
will now see the pseudo code of merge
sort algorithm
we have a function called merge sort in
this pseudo code and parameter of the
function contains an array named as
array and two variables named as left
and right
if the number of elements in the left is
greater than the number of elements on
the right we will get a middle using
formula left plus right divided by 2.
the merge sort is called and this
function
now has an array a left variable and
right variable by calling merge sort we
have array left as middle plus one and
right variable and finally by calling
merge sort we have left middle and right
variables in our upcoming segment we
will implement the merge sort method in
a practical demonstration
in the next section we will discuss the
complexity of merge sort algorithm
first we will look into the time
complexity of merge sort algorithm as we
all know time complexity in data
structures is divided into best case
average case and worst case the best
case of merced algorithm is big o of n
into log n average case of merced
algorithm is big o of n into log n and
the worst case of merced algorithm is
big o of n into log n
the number of elements being sorted is
given by n merge sorts time complexity
is big o of n star log n in all three
situations that has first average and
best because it always divides the array
into two halves and merges the two
halves in linear time it takes up the
same amount of space as the unsorted
array as a result it is not a good idea
to use it to search big unsorted arrays
moving on to the space complexity of the
merced algorithm the space complexity of
the merge sort algorithm is large o of n
in the merced algorithm we store the
left and right parts of the merged array
in the temporary arrays and then utilize
the original array to keep the entire
merged array in the worst case scenario
the left and the right sub arrays will
each be n by 2 in size and then the
total auxiliary space will be big o of n
resulting in a space complexity of big o
of n
following that we will look into several
applications of the merge sort algorithm
so the first application is merge sort
is an efficient way to sort link list in
big o of n log n time
subsequent application of the merchant
algorithm is for linked list
merge sort implemented without taking up
more space followed by that the mod
start method is used to count the number
of inversions in a list
last application states that in internal
sorting the merge sort is employed
now let us look into some of the
drawbacks of merge sort algorithm
so some of the drawbacks of merchant
algorithm are for smaller assignments
merge sort algorithm is slower than the
other sorting algorithms for temporary
array the merge sort technique requires
an additional memory space that is space
of big o of n
now let us look into a practical
demonstration of merge sort algorithm on
my screen we have an example for merge
sort algorithm
to define constants or micro
substitution we use the hash defined as
preprocessor directive with a constant
variable max of 10. following that two
arrays array 1 and array 2 are declared
we declare array 1 and initialize it
with elements like 8
9 10
4 and 1
array 2 is used for temporary array then
to implement the merge sort concept we
declare a merge sort function we specify
three variables in this function
parameter that is left right and middle
the left variable is used to display the
left part of the array one the right
variable is used to display the right
part of the array one and middle
variable is used to indicate the middle
or center of the array in this function
we utilize the for loop in this function
setting the left 2 level 1 the middle
plus 1 to level 2 and the left to
variable i with the condition that level
2 is less than or equal to the middle
and level 2 should be less than or equal
to the right of the array we have a
condition in this for loop that if level
1 of array 1 is less than or equal to
level 2 of array 1 we will initialize
all the consecutive elements of level 1
of array 1 to array 2. else we will
initialize all the successive elements
of level 2 of array 1 to array 2.
out of for loop all subsequent elements
of level 1 of array 1 will be
initialized to array 2 until level 1 is
less than or equal to the middle all
successive elements of level 2 of array
1 will be initialized to array 2 until
level 2 is less than or equal to the
right of the array
using the loop which will run from i
equal to the left of i is less than or
equal to right we initialize all the
items of array 2 to array 1. we have
declared one more function in this code
namely sorting out of the merging sort
function in which only the left and
right variables are defined we specified
the middle function in the sorting
function with the condition that if the
left is less than the right the middle
will be calculated as left plus right
divided by 2. then we call the sorting
function passing left as middle as right
and then another sorting function
passing left as middle plus 1 and right
finally we use the merge sort function
passing left middle and right to the
sorting array 1 otherwise we would
return nothing
we entered the main function out of the
sorting function where we declared the
counter variable i and printed the array
before sorting using the printf function
in for loop where i will run from index
0 to the array's maximum size after that
we invoked sorting method
passing left as zero index number and
write as the arrays maximum value
finally after doing the merge sort
process we will print the array using
the printf function and for loop we will
run
from 0 to the array's maximum value then
we compile the program and run it
now let's try to quickly execute this
program and see the output
so there you go the program got
successfully executed and the list
before sorting is eight seven six two
three five nine ten four and one and the
list after sorting is one two three four
four five six seven eight nine and ten
and with that we have come to an end of
this session on merge sort algorithm hey
everyone i am weber khandelwal and i
welcome you all to simply launch youtube
channel
in this session we will discuss quick
sort we shall begin our session by
introducing quick sort
then we will discuss quick sort
algorithm
after that we will implement quicksort
in the coordinator
finally we will sum up what we have
learnt from this session but before we
begin make sure you have subscribed to
our youtube channel and clicked on the
bell icon below so you never miss an
update from simplylands youtube channel
so without any further ado let's get
started with an introduction to
quicksort a quick sort is highly
efficient sorting algorithm and it is
based on partitioning an array into
smaller sub arrays and then we will sort
these two resulting sub arrays in the
same manner
this algorithm is quite efficient for
large size data sets as its average and
worst case complexities are big o of n
square
now let's discuss algorithm of quick
sort
let's say we have an array first we have
to select a pivot
we can select either the first element
or the last or medium or any random
element as pivots
this pivot will dissect the array into
two sub-arrays
then we will shift all smaller elements
than the pivot element to the left
then we will again apply the same
operation for the left sub array
and take pivot like we did for the main
array
we will perform the same for the right
sub-array as well
we have now introduced the quick sort
and its algorithm now let's implement
this algorithm in the code editor
we will start by creating a function
swap
so void swap
int
star
x
comma
end
equals to star x
star x is equals to star y
ry is equals to temp
now we will write a function which will
partition this array this function will
take the last element as pivot
and the pivot element at its correct
position in sorted array and places all
smaller elements
to the left of the pivot and all greater
elements to the right of the pivot
so int
partition
and i
so end
pivot
equals to
ar high
now end
i
is equals to
low minus 1.
so for
end
j is equals to low
j less than equals to high minus 1
a plus plus
now if current element is smaller than
the pivot
so if
arr at j
is less than pivot
then we will increment the i
then we will swap
ampersand array
i
comma
ampersand array
at j
and we will swap
ampersand
array
at i plus 1
comma
ampersand
array
at high
and then we will return
i plus 1.
now we will write the main function that
implements quick sort
so void
quick sort
and
arr
bracket
comma and
low
comma and high
so if
o
is less than high
and
pi
is equals to partition
arr comma
low
comma
hi
now we will separately sort elements
before partition and after partition
so
quick sort
arr comma
low
comma
pi minus 1
and
quick sort
arr
comma
p i
plus 1
comma i
now we will write a function to print
this array
so
void
and
array
arr
comma
end
size
and
high
so for loop
i less than size
a plus
plus see out
array
at it
layout
handle
now we will write the main block so end
array
and comma 7
comma eight
i will find the size so int n
is equals to
size of
array
is divided by
size of
array
element at zero
now we will call quick sort
n minus one
now we will print this
so c out
sorted
array
print
eric
arr command
now let's execute this
as you can see we have successfully
sorted our array
let's get back to our slides
at last let's sum up what we have
learned in this session
first up quick sort follows the divide
and conquer principle
next up quick sort has an average space
and time complexity of big o of n log n
next all pivots should be selected in
the same manner as the first pivot
finally quick sort is an unstable
sorting algorithm so even a single
mistake can crash a program
hey everyone welcome to simply learn's
youtube channel in this session we will
be learning about graphs in data
structures but before we begin make sure
that you have subscribed to our youtube
channel and don't forget to hit that
bell icon to never miss an update from
simply learn now without further ado
let's get started with the agenda for
today's discussion
so we will be discussing a brief
introduction to graphs first
followed by that we will understand the
graph terminologies
up next we will see the types of graphs
available in data structures after that
we will understand the representation of
graphs then we will look into the graph
traversal and finally we will understand
the application of graphs i hope i made
myself clear with the agenda now let's
begin with the first topic that is a
brief introduction to graphs
so what exactly is a graph
so a graph is a data structure like any
other data structure example linked list
arrays etc so graph is a little
different from the other types of data
structures such as linked list and
arrays they are linear data structures
whereas graph is a non-linear data
structure that consists of finite sets
of vertices and a bunch of edges
connecting with them
so what are these vertices and edges so
let us understand that a graph is
usually represented by
a set of vertices and edges
so a vertice is the node present in a
graph imagine that you are a group of
five friends so each one of you is
considered as a vertex and the network
connecting you guys is known as an
edge so the overall graph of your people
can be considered as g and it is
represented by vertices and edges set
where vertices is u and the network
connecting you guys is called as an edge
so here you can see it clearly each one
of the friend is called as a vertex and
the network connecting them is called as
an edge and the entire graph is
represented using a set of vertices and
edges
now moving ahead we will understand the
graph terminologies
now at first we have the adjacency
vertices and adjacency edges so what are
adjacent vertices
if there is an edge between two vertices
that is
one vertex or one node is connected to
another node directly using just one
single edge then those vertices are
called as adjacent vertices
now what are adjacent edges
if there is one common vertex between
two edges then those two edges are
called as adjacent edges let's imagine
this way let us imagine that we have
three vertexes and
these three vertexes are connected using
two edges so here we have one vertex
which is common between these two edges
so such type of edges are called as
adjacent edges
next we have the degree in an undirected
graph number of vertices adjacent to the
vertex is called as a degree
next is the path
the path is considered as a sequence of
distinct vertices such that two
consecutive vertices are adjacent to
each other
up next we have the cycle a path that
has only one repeated vertices are
called as first and last vertices
followed by that we have the work
the term block is self-explanatory a
book is the sequence of vertices and
edges in the graph which is used to
traverse through one vertex to another
vertex
now we have entered the next segment of
this particular tutorial where we will
be discussing the different types of
graphs available
so at first we have the finite graph
so what exactly is a finite graph a
graph is said to be finite when the
number of vertices and the number of
edges are in a finite number or in a
countable number
now the next type of graph is the
infinite graph so what exactly is the
infinite graph so the infinite graph is
a typical opposite of the finite graph
so this particular graph will not have
countable number of edges and countable
number of vertices
the image here is an example for a
typical infinite graph
now followed by the infinite graph we
have the trivial graph so what is a
trivial graph
a graph is said to be trivial if there
is only one single vertex without any
edges
so this particular type of graph will
only have vertex that is only one single
vertex not more than one and there will
be no edge if you have just one vertex
then there is no possibility of having
an edge unless if you have one single
loop type of edge which is connecting to
itself
but in a trivial graph we don't even
have that we just have one single vertex
so followed by trivial graph we have a
simple graph
so what exactly is a simple graph
a graph is said to be simple if there is
only one and one edge between each
vertex
so this particular example can be
considered as a simple graph so here
each and every set of vertices have one
single edge between them
now followed by the simple graph we have
the multi graph
so if there are multiple edges between
the pair of vertices then this
particular type of
graph is known as a multi-graph so here
you can see that we have two vertices a
and b and we have two edges connecting
them not one but two but in a simple
graph we were supposed to have just one
edge connecting the vertices so this is
the difference between simple graph and
a multi graph
so followed by multi graph we have a
null graph
so what is a null graph a graph is said
to be null if there are only vertices
and no edges between them so remember
the trivial graph right we just had one
single vertex but no edges but here we
do have multiple vertices but no edges
connecting them so this type of a graph
is considered as null graph
so followed by null graph we have the
complete graph
so what is a complete graph
a graph is called as a complete graph
where each vertex must be connected with
the other vertices using the edges so
the meaning of this particular type of
graph is all the edges are connected to
all the other edges using at least one
single edge so here you can see a is
connected to b d and c all together with
at least one edge and similarly all
other vertices are connected to each
other with at least one single edge
now followed by the complete graph we
have the pseudograph
so what is a pseudograph a pseudograph
is a graph where at least one vertex
will have self looping type of edge so
remember the self loop or self edge we
have discussed in the trivial graph type
so this particular type of an edge where
it connects to itself is called as a
loop or kind of self-connecting edge so
any graph that has this kind of a edge
is called as a pseudograph
so followed by the pseudograph we have
the directed graph
so what is a directed graph
any graph is called as a directed graph
where each edge has a direction
associated with it
so so far we have just discussed the
edges which are connecting to one or the
other vertex but there was no direction
but here you can see that this
particular edge has a direction that is
from b
to a not from a to b it is from b to a
this type of edges which are directing
the traversal of the graph are known as
the directed graphs
now followed by the directed graphs we
have the regular graph
so a graph is a regular graph where each
vertex of the graph has the same degree
now here you can see all the vertices
have the same amount of degree that is
the connection between all the other
vertices so the degree of a is 3 so the
degree of b is also 3 and the degree of
d is c and similarly the degree of c is
also 3.
so what i mean to say is all of these
vertices have the same degree that is 3.
now we have the weighted graph so what
is a weighted graph a weighted graph is
where each edge holds some weight that
denotes the traversal cost through those
edges now here you can see that all the
edges have a different weight the edge
from a to b has the weight 5 and the
edge from a to c has the weight 9
and the h from c to b has 2 and the edge
a 2 d as 8 and finally c 2 d as 7 so all
these values are the weight or the cost
to traverse from a to another vertex
flow so from a to b we have the cost
five and a to c we have the cost nine
and similarly c to d we have seven and
so on
now followed by the weighted graph we
have the connected graph
so what exactly is a connected graph a
graph is said to be connected where each
pair in the graph is connected
followed by a connected graph we have
the disconnected graph so it is a
typical opposite of the connected graph
a graph is said to be disconnected where
each pair in the graph is not connected
to each other
now next we have the cyclic graph so a
graph is said to be cyclic if it
contains at least one cycle in a graph
that is one complete traversal
connection so a can be traversed again
from traveling a to c c to d d to b and
b to a again so this type of a graph is
called as a cyclic graph
now next we have the acyclic graph
so it is the typical opposite of the
cyclograph so here you cannot traverse
to a again by traversing from a to c c
to d and there is no connection between
d to b so the complete cycle is not
available here this type of graphs are
called as acyclic graphs
so moving ahead we have the graph
representation
so generally there are two different
ways to represent the graph data
structure
they are using adjacency matrix and
adjacency list
so what is adjacency matrix
so adjacency matrix is a sequential
representation adjacency matrix is used
to represent which nodes are connected
to
which node
if there is an edge between two vertices
then the value of the corresponding
element of the graph is one otherwise
zero if there is any weighted graph
besides then zeros and ones we can store
the weight of the h as that particular
number
suppose that there is a connection
between a and b and it is represented as
a weight of 5 then there is a connection
so we will use the connection as true
but we will not represent it as 1.
instead we will use the weight that is 5
to represent it as 5 not as one if there
is no weight then we will represent it
as one and if there is no connection
then we will represent it as zero
now undirected graph representation
so here you can see how we have
represented a graph so there is no
connection between a to a that is there
is no loop so the value will be zero if
there was a loop and if it was
represented with a width then we could
have written a weight here since we do
not have weight then the no connection
is represented as 0 and a connection is
represented as 1. we have a connection
from a to b so we have represented as 1
and similarly to a to c so and so on
now directed graph representation
so the simple difference between the
directed and undirected graph
representation is we did not have a
direction in the previous segment but
here we do have directions so
b is connected to a but a is not
connected to b so we will write it as 0
because the control is traversing from b
to a but not from a to b so we need to
take care of the traversal of control so
we are representing 0 and you can see
from d to b we have one connection and
the traversal is in the direction of d 2
b so we will have 1 there so here we
have d and b so we have one so in that
way we represent the directed graphs
next undirected weight graphs
so this was what we discussed before
instead of zeros and ones they will
represent the weight here so we do not
have a connection between a to a so that
is zero as usual but we do have a
connection from a to b so we have
represented it with a number that
happens to be the weight of the edge
and remember we do not have the
direction here this is undirected
weighted graph now if it were the
directed weighted graph then we could
have seen the direction and represented
the number with the weight
now after this let us look into the
adjacency list
so what is adjacency list
adjacency list is a linked
representation
in this representation we maintain the
list of its neighbors for each vertex in
the graph
every vertex of the graph contains the
list of adjacency vertices
area of vertices which have vertices
indexed by each vertex number for every
vertex the array element points to the
linked list of the neighbors of the
vertex so this might be a little
complicated to understand so let us
understand this using an example
so directed graph representation
implemented using linked list
so this is the directed graph we are
using
so you can see that a is not connected
to anything so we have ended the address
of next location as x but b is connected
to a and c is connected to a similarly d
is also connected to a
so that is how we represent the
directed graphs using linked lists
next we have directed graph
representation using array
so a is not connected to anything so we
have represented as 0 and b is connected
to b as well as a so we have 1 there and
c is connected to b
so c is also connected to a so we have 2
there d is connected to a c and b so we
have 3 there
now we have the graph traversal
so graph traversal refers to the process
of examining each edge and vertex in a
graph
graph traversing can be performed in two
ways
the first one is breadth first search or
bfs algorithm bfs starts traversing the
graph from root node and explores all
the neighboring nodes then it selects
the nearest node and explores all the
new nodes queue data structure can be
used in bfs algorithm
so the following image depicts the epfs
algorithm working it chooses the nearest
node first then it traverses to all the
other nodes
so followed by bfs algorithm we have the
dfs algorithm that is the depth first
search algorithm dfs starts traversing a
graph from the initial node of the graph
and then it goes deeper and deeper until
it finds the node has no child then
backtrack from the dead end towards the
recently explored nodes stack is used
for bfs algorithms so this particular
gif image can be considered as the graph
traversal which is performed using dfs
algorithms so if you don't know much
about dfs and bfs algorithms don't worry
about that those particular tutorial
videos are added in the description box
below you can go through it and
understand bfs and dfs algorithms in a
much better way
now we will go through some of the
applications of graphs
so some of the major applications of
graphs are used in the
websites google maps and social media
websites like facebook and some security
systems
and also software programming
so with hello everyone welcome to simply
learns youtube channel today we will be
discussing about kruskal's algorithm in
data structure in today's video we have
a challenging activity for you guys so
stay tuned and do participate in
formulating answer to the question that
is going to pop up on your screens in
next few minutes but before we begin let
me tell you guys that we have daily
updates on multiple technologies so if
you are a tech geek in a continuous hunt
for latest technological advancements
then consider getting subscribed to our
youtube channel and don't forget to hit
that bell icon to never miss an update
from simplylearn now without any further
audio let's get started with the agenda
for today's discussion
we will start this discussion with
introduction to kruskal's algorithm
followed by that we'll understand how we
can create a minimum spanning tree for a
given graph using kruskal's algorithm
and finally we will cover the coding
implementation of crystal's algorithm
using disjoint sets i hope i made myself
clear with the agenda now let's get
started with our first topic
introduction to kruskal's algorithm
the kryskal's algorithm is used to find
the minimum spanning tree for a given
graph but what exactly is a minimum
spanning tree or mst
well a minimum spanning tree is a subset
of graph g having the same number of
vertices as of graph g and edges
equivalent to number of vertices minus
1. along with these properties it also
has a minimum cost for the summation of
all age weights included in a minimum
spanning tree
if you want to learn more about spanning
trees then please consider watching our
video which you can find in the i button
section right away
now coming back to the kryskals
algorithm the kruskal's algorithm sorts
all ages in increasing order of their
age weights and keeps adding nodes to
the tree only if the given age does not
form a cycle also it picks the age with
minimum cost at first and the age with
maximum cost at last
hence we can say that the kruskal's
algorithm makes a locally optimal choice
intending to find global optimal
solution
that is why it is also considered as
greedy algorithm the data structure that
we are going to use for implementing
this kruskal's algorithm is union fine
but now you must be thinking what
exactly is this union find data
structure and how it works well union
find is a data structure that keeps
tracks of elements that are split into
one or more than one disjoint sets where
a disjoint set is collection of two
distinct groups or clusters that do not
have single common element the union
find features two important operations
named as find and union
the operation find returns the set or
group to which provided element belongs
basically it constructs a bijection
between the object provided and its set
whereas the union function joins two
distinct disjoint sets to create a
single subset let's understand how this
data structure works with the help of
real life example
let's say we have some singing magnets
placed on table with a higher magnetic
affinity towards each other all the
singing magnets present on the table are
color coded with sky blue color
now due to the high magnetic attraction
the magnets a to e will form a strong
magnetic field which will cause the
bonding or connection of all these
magnets as a result all these magnets
will be grouped together we will now
color code this set with red color along
with that we'll also call this set as
red
after that the magnet f2i are also
closer to each other thus they will also
form a connection we'll call this set as
green
finally this last set of magnets will
also formulate a connection with each
element inside a group
we will call this group as set purple
all these distinct magnets got
distributed into three different
disjoint sets
but as the magnetic attraction between
these groups increases significantly
hence all these clusters of magnets will
end up connecting with each other this
scenario can be related to the union
function union function merges different
sets into a single subset where the find
operation helps in extracting the group
of element to which the particular
element belongs similarly in this
scenario a particular magnet can be
traced back to its group with the help
of color code that we have maintained
alongside the magnets
the use of union find in kruskal's
algorithm can be related to this example
while implementing kruskal's algorithm
we are going to maintain three distinct
disjoint sets the first set will store
age weight values for all ages in a
graph whereas the second set will store
tree hierarchy for different nodes the
last set will store the ranks for all
nodes included in an msd
by using the union find structure and
its operation we can justify the entry
of each edge into the spanning tree
which we will explain in the
implementation of this algorithm
but let's understand the functioning of
this algorithm primarily
the crystals algorithm begins with
sorting all edges into increasing order
of their age weights this sorting is
done to include edges with the least age
weight primarily into the tree structure
after that we'll pick the first smallest
edge and we'll check if it generate any
cycle in the tree structure or not
if it does not form any cycle then we
will include that edge into our spanning
tree otherwise we will discard it
we will keep repeating this process
until mod of v minus 1 edges are
included into our mst where v is number
of vertices now moving ahead let's
discuss how we can create a minimum
spanning tree using kruskal's algorithm
this given graph gve contains 12 edges
and six vertices and we are supposed to
find out g dash such that the number of
vertices is equal to 6 and the number of
edges is equal to v minus 1 that is 6
minus 1 which is equal to 5.
the one more condition that the
formulated structure must abide by is
that the summation of all included edge
weights must be the minimum possibility
for this spanning tree going forward
we'll discuss how we are going to create
mst for this graph using kruskal's
algorithm
the first step that we need to perform
is removing all the loops or parallel
edges from our graph hence primarily
we'll remove these two present loops
the next step that we are going to
perform is arranging all the edges in
increasing order of their weights
the reason behind maintaining the sorted
list is to make sure that the first edge
for insertion is of a minimum cost here
i have maintained the sorted list for
all the edges that are part of our graph
so according to this sorted list the
first age that we are going to insert in
our mst is hef as it has minimum weight
cost that is 2.
the next stage that we have in our
sorted list is hfd it also has an edge
weight equal to 2 hence we'll include it
in our spanning tree
the third edge in our sorted list is hbc
with weight 3. the inclusion of this
edge does not formulate any circle in
our tree structure hence we'll add it to
our mst the next age is hcf having the
age weight 3 so we'll include it in our
msd structure
the fifth edge that we are going to pick
is hcd having weight 4 but the inclusion
of this edge inside a spanning tree will
create a loop and the structure that
contains a loop can never be considered
as tree hence we have to exclude this
edge
the next age is hbf and the inclusion of
this age will also generate a cycle in
our spanning tree structure
so we will exclude this age as well
the next age
is hbd
this edge has weight value 6. the
inclusion of this age can also create a
loop in our structure so we'll have to
discard this edge as well
the next stop is h a b with a weight
value 7
even though this age has higher weight
value than previous ages but it does not
formulate any cycle in our msd so we'll
include it in our tree structure
by doing that we have generated v minus
1 edges for our spanning tree thus we
won't iterate further in our sorted list
this generated mst has minimum possible
cost for our graph gve which is 17 i
hope that you guys have understood the
mst implementation process using
kruskal's algorithm cause in the next
slide i have a problem for all of you
guys to assess your understanding of
kruskal's algorithm the graph shown on
your screen contains 10 vertices and 18
edges
and for this graph you are supposed to
generate a minimum spanning tree such
that it contains 10 vertices 9 edges and
minimum construction cost
in order to do that you can take out
your pen and paper to draw the spanning
tree structures based on the state that
we have discussed till the time i am
aware that this graph is quite strangely
structured however if you can solve this
problem you will undoubtedly be able to
solve other difficult problems out there
and of course if you are confused about
any step then you can reiterate through
the session but here i am going to give
you guys a little moment to figure out
your answers
well now that you guys must be ready
with your solution so let's check if it
is true
the highlighted part of this graph is
possible structure for a spanning tree
with minimal cost
by removing all the edges the msd will
look something like this i hope you guys
have got the right answer on that note
let's dive further and discuss the
implementation strategy for kruskal's
algorithm
while implementing the kruskal's
algorithm primarily we'll generate a c
structure for keeping track of the
source and destination node along with
its weight
after that we'll sort all that edges of
a graph in increasing order of the age
weights
moving ahead we'll create three distinct
sets to maintain nodes of a graph their
hierarchy in tree and corresponding
ranks for every node for each insertion
of an age in mst we'll update the rank
and parent of each node
if the two nodes have the same parent
node then we will not insert the 8
joining them as it will generate the
cycle in tree structure
let's understand all these steps with
the help of an example
this is the graph structure for which
we'll try to generate a minimum spanning
tree using c programming language
as discussed earlier primarily we'll
create a sorted list of all ages in
increasing order of their age weights
the list will contain the source node
destination node and corresponding edge
weight for that particular edge along
with that we are going to maintain
disjoint sets to carry out union
operation those disjoint sets apparent
and rank and they will include rank
value and parent value for every node in
our graph initially all the nodes are in
their own different sets
hence we'll set their parent values to
-1 also the ranks for these nodes will
be initialized to 0 at the beginning
because we haven't included them in our
minimum spanning tree having said that
let's include the nodes of our graph in
our msd
in upcoming slides we'll traverse
through our list of edges to include
them in our minimum spanning tree
now the first edge that we are going to
check is hdc which have minimum age cost
that is 1.
in order to insert this edge in rmst
will need to find the absolute parent of
node d and c as well so let's check out
the parent set to determine the absolute
parent value of node d and c
the parent value of node d is -1 and
parent value of node c is also -1
both of them are having same ranks which
means either we can make node d point to
c or node c point to d
here i'll assume that node d points to
node c
so if node d is pointing to node c then
the parent of node d will become node c
and as
c becomes the parent of node d the rank
of node c will change
remember whenever two disjoint tree
structures are joined together then the
rank of one being pointed to will
increase by one
hence the rank of node c will become 1
now
once the disjoint sets are updated the
union operation will generate the link
between node d and c
now we'll process the second edge in our
list that is
age cb having weight 2 primarily we will
check the parent values of both these
nodes node b and node c have parent
values minus 1 and minus 1
which indicates that these nodes are
absolute parent of their own sets
since they have different absolute
parents we can join both of them
however the rank of node c is higher
than node b thus the connection should
point from node b to node c
as node b
if pointing towards node c thus node c
will become the parent of node b as well
hence will update the corresponding
absolute parent values for them
next up is hba with the weight value 2.
now the parent value for node a is -1
and the parent value for node b is c so
both of them have distinct parent value
which implies that we can establish a
connection between them
for that purpose we'll have to update
the rank field
and as the parent of node b is node c
the rank of c will definitely increase
by 1.
once the fields are updated the edge
will get included in our msd
on that note we have generated our
minimum spanning tree but you must be
thinking about how our algorithm will
discard the other edges
so to understand that we'll traverse
further in our list of edges
the next age is h ac and the parent of
node a is node c itself hence we'll
discard this node as well
now the final edge in our list is h80
and again both these nodes have the same
parent node thus we'll discard this node
as well
now you must be thinking about how we
can limit iteration of the whole list if
we formulate mst using the few topmost
edges only well the answer to that is
pretty straightforward we can avoid the
complete traversal of the list by using
looping condition from e is equal to
zero to e is equal to mod of v minus one
when we use this condition the looping
will stop when v minus edges get
included in our msd
now the next uh is the time complexity
analysis of kruskal's algorithm the time
complexity of kruskal's algorithm will
be big o of e log e plus e log v the e
log e for sorting all edges and e log v
for finding the age from maintain three
sets
the average time complexity graph for
this implementation will be something
like this it will be a parabolic nature
i hope that you all have understood the
strategy for implementing kruskal's
algorithm
so without wasting any time further
let's visit the code editor to develop a
program in c programming language for
crystal's algorithm
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit skillup by simplylearn click
on the link in the description to know
more
to begin with coding implementation the
first thing that we'll do is we'll
create a storing system to represent a
weighted age for that purpose we'll use
structure in the c programming language
so
let's get started with that
struct
edge
and inside this structure
will create end
source
destination
and
weight
now what we'll do is we'll utilize this
structure to store the edges of the
graph moving ahead we'll also initialize
the structure for storing the complete
graph
so let's create one more structure
and we'll name the structure as graph
and insert this graph structure we'll
create
node
we'll also create variable e
to represent number of
edges in our
graph
we'll also call the reference of
structure h to this graph by doing this
we'll be able to include all the edges
into our graph structure as well so
let's create that reference
struct
h
star
now we have successfully created the
structure for graph
now moving forward what we'll do is
we'll assign dynamic memory to the
reference of graph structure
for that what we'll do is we'll write
code struct
graph
star
generate
graph
and inside this function will pass
and
node
the number of
edges
that is e variable
now we'll write body
for this function
and inside body first thing what we'll
do is we'll create
the space
that is dynamic memory space for this
graph structure
equal to struct
graph star
malloc
size of
start
graph
dot
node
will be equal to node
and graph
dot number of
edges
will be equal to
e itself
next
what we'll do is
will allocate a memory
to each edge
okay
underscore here
for that what we'll do is we'll use
struct
h star
malloc
size of
struct
h
and finally
will return
the
graph
now we have successfully allocated
memory space to our graph and individual
edges as well so moving forward what
we'll do is we'll initialize one more
structure to store the parent array and
rank array basically these are the
disjoint sets whose usage will allow us
to generate a spanning tree using union
find algorithm
so let's get started with that we'll
create another structure
and will name the structure as
tree underscore
maintainance
underscore set
and
inside this structure
will create
parent array
and
rank array
now we have created the tree maintenance
set structure so let's generate an union
find algorithm for maintaining msd
structure
in order to do that let's create a
function named find disjoint set first
so
this find disjoint set function
will be of end data type
find
underscore
disjoint
set
and inside this will pass
struck
tree
underscore
indigenous underscore set
and it's object
subsets
and
a variable and i
inside this function we'll use if case
to find root and make it as a parent of
argument i
also if it is minus 1 then we'll need to
update it for that we'll keep recurring
through this a block by calling the
function find disjoint set inside f
block so
let's do that if
subsets
i
dot parent
is not equal to
i
then what we'll do is
we'll
get inside this f block and will execute
subsets
i
dot parent
is equal to
find
underscore
disjoint set
and will again pass same argument
subsets
comma
i
dot
parent
and finally
we'll get out of this f block
and
will return
subsets
i
dot parent
now we'll create a function for union
operation
let's name this function as
void
union
underscore
disjoint
set
and insert this will pass
struct
tree
underscore
maintenance
underscore set
and its object
subsets
and will pass
argument x
and argument
y
now inside this function will create two
variables named x root and y root
and the x root variable will store the
return data from find disjoint set when
the x has been passed to the function
and similarly the y root will store the
return value for find disjoint set given
y as an argument so
let's write command for that
and
x root
will be equal to
find
disjoint set
and objects will be subsets
comma
x
similarly
and
y root
will be equal to
find
this joint set
and object subsets
and variable y
now in order to build connection between
these nodes
as discussed previously the node with
lowest rank value should always be
pointing to the node with highest rank
value and vice versa so we'll have to
use this a block in order to put this
condition in the connection building
block of our program so we'll write
condition for that here now
f
subsets
x root
dot rank
it's greater
less than
subsets
y
root dot rank
then what we'll do is
we'll set
subsets
x
root dot parent
to y root
that means
oh okay
so what we are doing here is we are
checking the rank value of x root
if the rank value of x root is smaller
than y root then what we'll do is we'll
simply set the y root as parent of x
root
i hope you guys are clear with this now
moving forward we'll write lc part of
this condition
else f
subset
x root
dot rank
sorry
i'll have to add s here
and
f subsets x root dot rank is greater
than
subsets
y root
dot
rank
then what we'll do is
we will
set subsets
y root
dot parent
is equal to x root
otherwise
if both above mentioned condition fail
then what we'll do is we'll add one more
condition
we'll set subset
y root
dot parent
to
x root
and then
we
set subset
x root
dot
rank
to incrementation
there is one mistake over here
subsets okay
so now we have implemented the union
find algorithm
for this crystal's implementation
next we'll create a function to sort the
list of edges in our graph according to
increasing order of their 8 weights
so let's create new function for that
we'll name this function ads
and
my
comparator
and inside it will pass
const
void
star
a
and
const
void star
p
and
we'll create function body
but before we get started with coding
implementation of this my comparator
function
i want to talk about arguments of this
so basically a and b are constant
quantifiers
the significance of this quantifier is
to tell the user that you cannot modify
this pointer and the location it is
pointing to throughout the program
so
let's
get started with
the coding part of this my comparator
function
what we'll do is
we'll create
struct
h
star
a one
is equal to
struct
h
star
a
semicolon and similarly
struct
h
star
b1
will be equal to
struct
h star
b
next we'll return the output
a
one
dot weight
it's greater than
b1
dot
weight
so basically what this statement will do
is if the weight value of a1 is greater
than b1 then it will return a1 as output
and if the weight value of b1 is greater
than a1 then it will return b1
i hope you guys are clear with this my
comparator function
so moving forward will finally create a
crystal msd function
the return type of this function will be
void
and will name this as kruskal mst
and inside it will pass argument
struct
graph
star
and will create function body
now the first thing that we'll do here
is we'll assess the value of number of
nodes in a graph and after that we'll
generate a new reference of structure
age for storing our msd so
the first thing we'll
get
the node
to
graph
dot
node
and
struct
h
result
node
along with it will also initialize
variable e
and variable i equal to zero so and
e
is equal to zero
and end
i
is equal to
zero
we need to break the indentation here
and here as well
and semicolon so basically these
variables will store index values for
result and index variable for the sorted
list simultaneously
now moving forward
we'll sort all the edges of a graph
if we are not allowed to change the
given graph then we can create a copy of
the given graph the function name q sort
allows us to do that so let's create
that q sort function here
q sort
graph
edge
comma
graph
a
comma size of
graph
h
zero
so this q sort is nothing but c standard
library function that implements a
polymorphic sorting algorithm for arrays
of arbitrary objects according to a user
provided comparison function and that
comparison function is nothing but this
my comparison function
and
i guess
you guys must be
with this q sort term
so let's add
comma here
and will give call
to a
my comparator function
now moving forward we'll break the
indentation
and
we'll call
the object of tree maintenance set
underscore
maintenance
[Music]
set
star
subsets
equal to
start
tree underscore
maintenance
underscore
set
star
malloc
node
star
sides of
struct
tree underscore
maintenance underscore
set
and will add
semicolon here
so next we'll create subsets equal to
number of nodes and after that we'll
make sure that all the elements have the
rank value equal to zero
and to do that we'll initialize new for
loop
so
let's
create for loop here
we'll begin it from v is equal to zero
to
v
it's less than
node
and
we will set this way
to incrementation
after that
make body for this for loop and inside
it
will set
subsets
v
dot parent
is equal to
v
and
subsets
v
dot rank
is equal to
zero
now moving further
will traverse through all the edges in
the graph
but we want to limit our traversal to
the number of vertices minus one and to
achieve that we'll create while loop
here
while
e
is less than node
capital node
then
node minus 1
and and
i
it's
smaller than
graph
a
then
create
struct
h
next underscore h
equal to
graph
dot
h
i plus plus
and here
we'll create
x and y nodes
so
let's do that and x
will be equal to
find
underscore
disjoint set
and will pass subsets
comma
next h
dot source
and
for y
will pass
find underscore distance sets
subsets
comma
next
underscore h
dot
destination
now if including the h between x and y
does not create the cycle in our graph
only then we can include that edge in
our msd for that what we can do is we'll
set if x
it's not
equal to
y
then
we'll set
result
e
plus plus
equal to
next
underscore h
and
we'll find unions
disjoint set
for
subset
and
will pass x and y as well
with this we have successfully created
our crucial semester function
now what we'll do is we'll also print
the structure of our minimum spanning
tree for that we'll need to create
pattern using printf function so let's
do that
the first statement that will print on
screen is edges
created
in
mst
are
adds below
and we'll add backslash n so that our
output gets to the next line
we'll add semicolon
and
after that
we'll add end
minimum
cost
variable
and will initialize it to zero
so
okay
what we'll do is
we'll create for loop here
and we'll initialize it with iterator
element
beginning from zero
till
i
less than equal to e
and well
i trade this i element
and
what will do it
will create pattern
for printing the edges the pattern will
go like modulus d
dash dash
modulus d
equal to equal to
modulus
d
slash ends
and
the parameters that will get printed
will be
result
i
dot
source
comma
result
i
dot
destination
and
result
i
dot
wait
okay
so we haven't added
comma here
now this error will get resolved
now after this
what we'll do is
we'll increment this minimum cost
variable by adding the values of edges
to it
so we'll take this minimum cost variable
and
will add
result
i
dot
wait to it
now we'll get outside this for loop
and
we'll printf one more statement
the cost
for
creating
mst
ads
modulus d
and
will print
minimum
cost
okay we have now
successfully
implemented
algorithm function and we have created
code for printing it on console as well
so now moving forward we'll work on our
driver method
and for that let's
get into its function body
here
first we'll
define the number of nodes that we are
going to use for our graph
those number of nodes
are
four
the graph structure that we are going to
pass to this crystals algorithm program
is the same that we have discussed
implementation strategy for
it had four edges
and it also had
six
edges as well
so
we'll add six edges here
now what we'll do is we'll set
struct
graph
star
equal to
gender it
generate
crop
and will pass node
comma
e
and we'll add
semicolon
now next
we'll create graph structure by
implementing the edges
so the for
first h we'll call graph
dot
h
zero
dot source
will be equal to zero
that means
the
first age will begin from zero
and
it will
end at
destination
node
and that will be
one
and the weight
for this
age will
be equal to
2.
now we'll copy this pattern
and
we'll paste it below
okay
and now
the age
will be one
and for this
h1
the source will be 0 and destination
will be 2
and the rate value will be 4.
now
let's copy this again
paste it
and we'll set
age number to 2
will change source
and destination now source will remain
same and destination will be changed
will make it 3
and the weight value will also remain
the same
that means
edge between 0 to 2 and h between 0 to 3
have same
edge weight
now
for next
control v
will remove this indentation
and now
we'll change the node number
age number
here
the source will be 1
and destination will be
three
and the age weight value
will be three
after this
we'll add
new h
the h number will be 4 now
the source will be
and destination will be
and
age weight would be 1.
the last h
will be
h
five
and
the source will be
one here
and
destination will be 2
the age weight will be 2.
now after this what we'll do is
we'll give call to a crystal msd
function
in order to generate minimum spanning
tree and will pass this graph structure
to it
and will add return zero statement
with this we have successfully completed
a programming implementation for
kruskal's algorithm
so let's run it and check if our code is
working fine or not
okay so we are getting three problems
here
the first one
is expected token
oh
so
end node will be equal to
and this node should also be capital
here
okay
so what next error is there
yeah
so now our code is bug free
oh
but
some exception is happening here
we'll jump this exception will try to
jump it
okay but we are not having any errors
into our system so
i think that's the compatibility issue
with our vs code so let's copy this code
and paste it into
the virtual coding environment and we'll
check it if this code is working fine or
not
so
we'll copy the code
and we'll go back to the google chrome
we'll
go to the online compiler tool
and here
we'll paste our code
and we'll run it
okay so here we are getting our output
so there will be only three edges that
will get form in our minimum spanning
tree and the cost for all those ages
will be five
i hope this coding implementation is
clear to all of you out there
if you are concerned about this code
then don't be as we can send it over to
you if you drop your email id in the
comment section below so drop your email
ids in the comments section below in
order to receive this code
hey everyone i am verbo khandelwal and i
welcome you all to simplylearns youtube
channel in this session we will discuss
backtracking algorithm
we shall begin our session by
introducing backtracking
then we will discuss the end queen's
problem to understand the backtracking
in detail
after that we will implement the end
queens problem in the code editor
finally we will sum up what we have
learned from this session
but before we begin make sure you have
subscribed to our youtube channel and
clicked on the bell icon below so you
never miss an update from simply
learnt's youtube channel
so without any further ado let's get
started with an introduction to
backtracking
backtracking is an algorithmic method of
alternately
solving a problem
to explain the issues it employs a
recursive approach
backtracking is required to find every
possible combination to solve an
optimization problem
backtracking is used in solving various
problems like n queens knight store the
rat in the maze problems and so on
now to get better understanding of
backtracking let's have a brief look at
and queen's problem
let's say we have four by four matrix
we have to place four queens in that
every row and column has exactly one
queen and none of them falls under the
same diagonal
we will start with the left most column
then we will check our base condition
that if we have placed all the queens or
not
now we will try every row in this column
if we found a location where the queen
can be safely placed then we will mark
it as a part of an answer
and then we will recursively check if
placing queen here will lead us to the
solution or not
if yes then we will return true
otherwise if false then we will
backtrack and try other rows and repeat
these steps
if all rows have been tried and nothing
worked then we will return false to
trigger backtracking
now let's implement this end queen's
problem in the code rater
we will define a vector
inside a vector
it will be a end vector
result
now we will write a utility function to
check if the queen can be pleased on
board
so
it will be a boolean function
bull is
safe as argument we will place a vector
inside a vector
and
board
comma
and
raw
comma
and
column
will define
and i comma j
and
n
will be equals to board size
now we will check if this row on the
left side
so
for loop
i is equals to zero
i less than column
i plus plus
f
board
at row
i
then we will return
now we will check upper diagonal on left
side
so for
i is equals to rho
comma j
is equals to column
j greater than equals to zero
and
i
greater than equals to zero
i minus minus
comma
j
minus minus
if
board
i
comma j
then return
now we will check lower diagonal on left
side so for
i equals to rho
comma j
is equals to column
i
less than n
and
j
greater than equals to zero
i plus plus
comma j minus minus
now f
code
at i
and j
will return
else we will return
basically what we have done in this
function is we have checked that row and
the right diagonal and the left diagonal
so that no queen can overlap
now
next
we will write a recursive utility
function to solve n queen's problem
so
pull
call
thank you
its argument will be vector
inside a vector
enter
ampersand board
comma and
column
now we will first check our base case if
all queens are placed
so end
n is equals to
board
size
if
volume
is equals to n
then we will define a vector
and
i less than n
and i plus plus
another nested for loop
and
j is equals to zero
j less than n
j plus plus
j
is equals to
then
v dot push
back
j plus one
now
we will print result
start
push back
and we will return
true
now we will consider this column and try
placing this queen in all rows one by
one
so
boolean
plus
is equals to false
now for loop
and i is equals to zero
i less than n
i plus plus
now we will check if queens can be
placed on board i
can call them call
so if
is safe
bored
i
comma call
if it's safe then we
will place this queen at that position
so board
i
call
is equals to
now we will make result true if any
placement is possible
so
res
is equals to
solve
and cube
at
board
comma
call
plus one
or res
now if placing queen in board i call
doesn't lead to a solution then we will
remove the queen from the board i column
and backtrack
board
now if queen cannot be placed in any row
in this column
then we will return false
so
return
plus
now this function solves the end queen
problem using backtracking
it is basically using solvency to solve
the problem
it returns false if queen cannot be
placed otherwise returns true and print
placement of queens in the form of once
now there may be possibility that there
are more than one solution
then this function will print one of the
feasible solution
vector
write a vector
and queen
and
result
dot
clear
now we will call vector
inside a vector
board
and
comma
vector
and
bracket n comma zero
now if
solve
enqueue
at board
comma 0
is false
and we will return
empty set
otherwise
we will sort
result
dot begin
mama
result
dot
and
and we will return
result
now we will write the main block
so end
n is equals to
so for
vector
inside vector
v
will be equals to n queens
at n
so we will write for loop
auto
ar
v
we will call c out
then for loop
auto
atr
here
see out
itr
and see out
and then we will return zero
now let's run this code
as you can see we are getting two
answers
now this end queen can be solved with
both of these answers
now let's get back to our slides
at last let's sum up what we have
learned in this session
first up backtracking is simple to
implement and has fewer lines of code
most backtracking codes are composed of
few lines of recursion function code
next
since we use recursion the function
information is stored on the stack which
has high space complexity
next when the branching factor is
significant it is very time consuming in
many cases
finally many problems such as knight
stewart
and queens rat in the maze subset some
problem and so on can be solved using
backtracking
hello everyone welcome to simply learn's
youtube channel today we will be
discussing about spanning tree in data
structure
but before we begin let me tell you guys
that we have daily updates on multiple
technologies if you are a tech geek in a
continuous hunt for the latest
technological advancements then consider
getting subscribed to our youtube
channel and don't forget to hit that
bell icon to never miss an update from
simplylearn
now let's get started with the agenda
for today's discussion we will start
this discussion by understanding the
importance of spanning tree and with the
help of an application
followed by that we will deal with what
is graph and data structure and their
different types
advancing ahead we will understand what
a spanning tree is and how it works
once we are done with that we will look
into some essential properties of the
spanning tree
and finally we will cover the
applications of a spanning tree to
understand how we utilize this data
structure in our daily lives
now let's get started with our first
topic which is understanding the
importance of a spanning tree
we will have a look at an application of
the spanning tree to understand it
better
meet patrick patrick works as a head of
the network administration department in
an i.t solution company named as gray
solutions being the head of network
administration department patrick is
responsible for managing his team to
keep the organization's computer network
up to date and operate it as intended
network administration department
coordinates and connects multiple
systems in the company to a single
network using multiple routers
this network is called as local area
network or lan which is created for the
sole use of an i.t company
but in the last few days something went
wrong in the network management system
which came to patrick's notice
he observed that the network loop is
formed in a routing system a network
loop occurs when multiple routes carry
information from the same source to
various computing devices
and due to this formation of a network
loop the network connectivity started
slowing down initially after a few hours
the network connectivity completely went
down and all the operations of the
company stopped
abruptly now patrick and his team needed
to do something in order to resolve this
problem permanently
so patrick started brainstorming to find
out an optimal solution to fix this
problem
one of patrick's teammate was good at
data structures and he came forward with
an idea to implement a spanning tree
data structure for managing the routing
connections
he suggested replacing the old naive
routing strategy with a minimal spanning
tree routing
after listening to this idea the whole
network administration team started
working on implementing a spanning tree
while doing that they treated the
network connection as a graph the
routers and end devices like computers
fax machines were treated as the nodes
of the graph where the connecting wires
carrying network signals were treated as
the edges of a graph
but before understanding how patrick's
team was able to solve this problem
using a minimum spanning tree let's
first understand the basics of this data
structure
this will allow us to get a clear
insight into how spanning tree solves
network routing problems
so let's start with graph and its
different types
basically a graph is a structure made of
nodes and edges connecting them and
there are three types of these graphs
based on the types of edges
the first is the undirected graph the
second is the directed graph and the
last is the connected graph
let's understand these types completely
in the upcoming slides
the first type of graph that we are
going to discuss is the undirected graph
it is termed as a graph in which all the
edges does not point to any specific
direction in simpler words all the edges
of this graph will be bidirectional
as you can see in this particular graph
you can move from any node to any other
node and retrieve back as well
next up is the directed graph it is a
graph in which the edges point to a
specific direction
by this i mean in this type of graph you
can only move towards a single direction
for example you can traverse this given
graph starting from a then b
then c
then d and finally e
but here you cannot traverse back from e
to a as this graph is unidirectional
the last type of graph depending on its
edge is a connected graph
it is defined as a graph with a path
from any vertex to any other vertex in
the graph
in this particular type of graph you can
reach any vertex from any other vertex
in a graph for example you can go to
node b or d from node a and arrive back
at a from either vertex b or d
now moving ahead we will understand what
a spanning tree is and how we can create
it
mathematically the spanning tree for any
graph g having vertices v and edges e
can be represented using superscript
notation g dash having vertices v dash
and edges e dash
suppose we intend to create a spanning
tree for graph g then our spanning tree
g dash must follow a few constraints
the first constraint suggests that the
number of vertices for created spanning
tree must be equal to the number of
vertices of a given graph g
further the edges of g dash should also
be similar to the number of vertices in
graph g minus 1.
to understand this mathematical
formulation clearly let's have a look at
an example
now for this given graph g we have to
formulate all possible spanning trees
remember a single connected graph can
have multiple spanning trees until we
fulfill the constraints mentioned
earlier
so for this particular graph g we have
five vertices and five edges
additionally each edge has been assigned
with some cost or weight
let's say this weight represents the
distance between the connected two nodes
to create the spanning tree g dash we
need to ensure that g dash contains five
vertices and five minus one that is four
edges
hence for this graph we can create a
spanning tree like this
you can observe that we have eliminated
one node in the spanning tree to remove
the loop or cycle in a graph
for this spanning tree 1 we have a cost
or value equal to 10
and this cost is nothing but the
summation of all edge weights
now that we have created the first
spanning tree for our graph g i would
like to ask all of you to give this a
try
for that i am going to provide you with
a short moment to generate all possible
spanning trees for the structure that we
are discussing right now
you can also pause this video if you
need more time in order to do that
so now let's have a look at all possible
spanning trees at a glance we have seen
that the value for the first spanning
tree was 10
and for this new spanning tree 2 it is
13. in this spanning tree the edge
between vertices b and c is removed
the next spanning tree looks something
like this with cost 14.
further we have spanning tree number 4
with a value 12. and finally we have the
last possible spanning tree phi with a
value 11.
out of all these spanning trees the
value or cost for spanning tree number
one is the least which is 10.
thus this spanning tree will be called
as minimum spanning tree
i hope you're clear with the creation of
spanning trees but how can we judge the
number of all the possible spanning
trees
well for that you need to check the
structure of your graph if the graph you
have been given with is cyclic then the
number of possible spanning trees will
be equal to the number of vertices
the cyclic graph is a graph in which you
will have the same number of vertices
and edges with a cyclic structure
if the given graph is a complete graph
then the number of possible spanning
trees will be equal to v raised to v
minus 2
where v is the number of vertices in a
given graph you can say that the given
graph is a complete graph if each pair
of vertices is connected by the unique
edge
for this particular graph the number of
possible spanning trees will be equal to
the number of vertices that is 4 to the
power of 4 minus 2 which is further
equivalent to the square of 4. hence the
number of possible spanning trees for
this structure will be 16.
moving forward let's understand some
important properties of spanning tree
we have already gone through some
crucial properties while creating
spanning trees in the previous section
so primarily we will list all of them
here the first property of a spanning
tree conveys that a connected graph can
have more than one spanning tree
the next property states that the number
of vertices in spanning trees must be
equal to the number of vertices in the
given graph whereas the number of edges
is equivalent to the mod of v minus one
the third property of a spanning tree
says that the spanning tree must not
contain any cycle
if the structure that you have created
as a spanning tree includes a loop or
recycle then it's clear that you have
made a mistake because no tree can
contain a cycle
and finally the fourth property is all
about kaylee's formula if the given
graph is a complete graph then you can
calculate the number of possible
spanning trees using the formula v
raised to b minus 2.
the next property of a spanning tree
conveys that a spanning tree can never
be disconnected
for example if you create a spanning
tree for this given graph which is
accurate
and you erase one edge
when you do that the structure will no
longer be a spanning tree it can only be
referred to as a disconnected graph the
next property states that if the graph
contains more than one similar weight
there is a possibility of having more
than one minimum spanning tree for
example in this particular graph there
are more than one edge having the same
weights
thus there will be two possible minimum
spanning trees with the same cost that
is seven
this is all about the properties of
spanning trees
now that you understood what spanning
tree is you would have also understood
how it proves is an effective solution
and that is exactly how patrick from our
story solved his network issue
in a few days patrick and his team
changed the naive routing into the
minimum spanning tree routing now the
routing parts are managed by a minimum
spanning tree to maintain cost
effectiveness and to avoid any looping
activity
as we have already understood and misty
removes all the loops from a given graph
and we also know that the whole network
becomes the graph for which msc will
maintain a minimal routing path
hence the network system will never
experience a network loop again
due to this amazing initiative patrick
and his team were appreciated by the
whole organization
this example clearly illustrates the
importance of a spanning tree and why it
is one of the most important algorithms
in data structures
now we will look into the different
applications of spanning trees
the first application that we are going
to talk about is telecommunication
network building
if we want to build a telecommunication
network for the whole city and we are
putting different connection lines for
each customer then we will have to deal
with a huge cost
this knife ordinary approach is not the
best solution to build a connection line
but no worries this problem can be
resolved using the minimum spanning tree
data structure in this case each
customer will be treated as a vertex
whereas the connection line will be
treated as an edge
the minimum spanning tree will give us
the possible output for generating the
telecommunication network
no matter what type of algorithm you are
building using machine learning
techniques somewhere down the line you
will be using clustering techniques
quite liberally
clustering and data preparation go hand
in hand as many times you'll be working
at least initially with data sets that
are largely unstructured and
unclassified
those data sets cannot be classified
using single neuron or classification
methods so you use a clustering
algorithm which utilizes a minimum
spanning tree to create clusters or
groups by mapping distances between data
points
the next application of a minimum
spanning tree is image segmentation
you must have observed that your face
gets detected with the square shape
while clicking images in selfie mode
this scenario is happening due to the
image detection algorithm developed on
the camera system
at the back end the picture gets
fragmented into tiles of similar pixels
with the help of a minimum spanning tree
the last application of the spanning
tree is its use in calculating the
finance factors
a correlation matrix can be created by
calculating a coefficient of correlation
between any two stocks
this matrix can be represented
topologically as a complex network and a
minimum spanning tree can be constructed
to visualize the relationships
hey everyone welcome to simply alone's
youtube channel we'll talk about breadth
first search algorithm in today's
session before we begin make sure that
you have subscribed to our youtube
channel and don't forget to hit that
bell icon to never miss an update from
simply learn so without further ado
let's get started with our agenda for
today's session
our agenda begins with the explanation
of what exactly is breadth first search
algorithm followed by that we will look
into an example of breadth first search
algorithm for greater comprehension
first we'll build a breadth first search
algorithm which begins by traversing the
root node and then moves on to all the
other nearby nodes the breadth first
search approach repeats the procedure
for all the nodes until the desired node
is found
the queue data structure is the data
structure that is used for breadth first
search algorithm
for a better understanding we look at an
example of breadth first search
algorithm the blue color indicates that
the note has been already explored while
the pink color indicates that the node
has not been explored yet or visited yet
next we'll have our output
we will use a queue data structure to
keep track of all the nodes visited and
all the nodes that are unvisited
so to begin let's look at the algorithm
as a result we'll have node a which is
added to the output and marked as
visited
we must verify all the unvisited
addition nodes of a that is node b and
node c and add b and c nodes to the
output and enqueue to the queue
according to the breadth first search
algorithm
then we'll look at any node between b
and c we'll start with node b node d is
unvisited adjacent to node b so we'll
add node d to the output and q and since
node b is now being visited we'll
dequeue it
when it goes to node b the next
unvisited node is node e add node e to
the output and nq to the dq once node d
has completed its traversal dq from the
cube
now in the case of node e the addition
node is node c
which is already visited thus we will
dequeue node c from the queue
now that the pointer is pointing to node
c and node f is the next unvisited node
after the node c we will set node f to
output and q
here the pointer leads to node f which
has no unvisited adjacent nodes so we
will dequeue f from the queue and q is
empty so we'll come to the halt here
here's what we got that is a b c d e and
f
after understanding all the theoretical
aspects of bfs algorithm let's look at
the code of bfs algorithm in c
programming language
now we are on the practical mode on my
screen you can see an example for bfs
algorithm
we have declared a two dimensional array
with maximum row and column size of 10
and two arrays the first one is a square
of a maximum size of 10 and the second
one which is a visited that stores the
maximum size of 10 as well
some variables n i j and finally we
declared front which is initialized with
0 and rare variables which is
initialized with -1
we perform a loop from index 1 to the
size of an array visited in this
function with the condition that if
two-dimensional array of column 1 and
visited array of index is not one we
initialize variable i to the front of
the queue then one is set as the front
of the queue index of the visited array
and we use the breadth first search
function
with the vertex as the front of the
queue until front is less than or equal
to rare then we enter the main function
where we define the variable x that
stores the graphs vertex and then we use
the printf function to enter the number
of vertex that will be stored in
variable n
then we perform loop from index 1 to
queue size and visited array in which we
initialize 0 to the queue and index 1
with the visited array then after that
we'll enter the graph value in the form
of matrix of 2 dimensional array by
performing the loop with two variables
i for the graph row and j for the graph
column
then we print the source node which is
saved in the variable x
saved in the variable x and we call the
breadth first search function or method
which takes a vertex x as parameter and
we print which nodes are reachable by
looping from index 1 to the size of the
visited array if index 1 of the array is
visited otherwise breadth first search
is not possible so this was the
explanation of the program now let's try
to execute and see the output
there you go the program got
successfully compiled and now it's
asking for the input now it is asking
for the number of vertices let's enter
the number of vertices as 3.
now it is asking for us to enter the
input in the form of matrix so the first
row will be
one
two
and three so these are the first rows
the next rows will be two
three
and four
so the last row elements are three four
and five
so we have successfully given all the
three rows of elements now let us select
the source node so the source node would
be two
now all the nodes that are reachable
from the source node two are one two and
three
so there you go that's how you implement
the breadth first search algorithm
hello everyone welcome to simply learn's
youtube channel in this session we will
learn about depth first search algorithm
but before we begin i would like to tell
you guys that we have daily updates on
multiple technologies if you are a tech
geek in a continuous hunt for latest
technological trends then please
consider getting subscribed to our
youtube channel and don't forget to hit
that bell icon to never miss an update
from simply learn
now without further ado let's get
started with the agenda for today's
discussion
so in this session for today first we
will understand about a brief
introduction to depth first search
followed by that we will look into an
example for dfs algorithm so i hope i
made myself clear with the agenda now
let's get started with the introduction
to depth first search
so what is a depth first search
so basically a depth first search is an
algorithm for traversing or searching
the tree or graph data structures the
algorithm starts at the root node
selecting some arbitrary node as the
root node in case of graph and explores
as far as possible along each branch
before backtracking
so dfs starts with the initial node of
the graph then goes deeper until it
finds the goal nodes or the leaf nodes
or the nodes that have no children that
is the end part here you can see 4 and 7
are the leaf nodes so the depth first
search algorithm runs till the end of
all the nodes that is 8 10 all these are
the
leaf nodes or the last gold nodes
in dfs the backtracking starts once all
the nodes are explored
and the dfs algorithm uses stack data
structure for its traversal now that was
a brief introduction to the dfs
algorithm now for a better understanding
let's go through a practical
example so here we have a graph data
structure with elements a b
c
d
e and f so we will be running the dfs
algorithm and we will be traversing
through all the nodes of this particular
graph and the traversal will be recorded
using a stack data structure and we have
two different colors which will be used
to indicate the element's color
so the black color is for the nodes
which are not visited yet and the blue
color will indicate
the nodes which are being traversed
already
now this is the stack data structure
that we will be using for the traversal
and we have another part which declares
or which gives out the output of the
traversal of the nodes of this
particular graph
now we will begin with the first one
that is a now followed by that we will
move ahead to b
then after b we will go through d
then after d we have e
next we have c and last we have f
so that's how we traverse through the
graph using the dfs algorithm
now for a little more understanding
let's go through a practical example
where we will be executing a program for
implementing the dfs algorithm
so this particular program on my screen
is an example for dfs algorithm so here
we have the structure node
so followed by that we have also the
methods which will create the edge
and which will also print the graph
elements and finally we have the main
class now don't worry about the code
this particular code segment or the
complete code document will be added in
the description box below and you can
have access to it and try to run it on
your local system and have a better
learning experience now without further
ado let's try to run this program and
get the output and see how the dfs
algorithm gets implemented and traverses
through the graph
there you go the program got
successfully executed and we had the
graph elements that is 0 1 and 2
and 3 so it has visited all the elements
that is 2 3 1 and 0 according to the
stack data structure and we have found
the output over here
so with that we have come to an end of
this tutorial on a dfs algorithm
hello everyone welcome to simplylearn's
youtube channel
today we will be discussing about greedy
algorithms in data structure
but before we begin let me tell you guys
that we have daily updates on multiple
technologies if you are a tech geek in a
continuous hunt for the latest
technological advancements then consider
getting subscribed to our youtube
channel and don't forget to hit that
bell icon to never miss an update from
simplylearn
now without any further delay let's get
started with the agenda for today's
discussion we will start this discussion
by understanding the real-life example
of greedy algorithm
following which we will deal with the
introduction to greedy algorithm
advancing ahead we will understand
example of the greedy algorithm once we
are done with that we will look into the
demerits of using greedy algorithms
and finally we will cover the
applications of greedy algorithm to
understand how we utilize it in our
daily lives
now let's get started with our first
topic
here we will look into the real life
example of greedy algorithm in order to
understand it better this is alex he's
quite wealthy and intelligent as he
works for one of the most reputed it
firms and this is alex's best friend
rachel rachel is in dire need of 85
right now
however she needs money in such a
quantity that the number of coins is
kept to a minimum so rachel shared this
issue with alex and asked him for help
now alex is thinking about rachel's
issue which he can easily fix because he
has a limitless supply of fifty dollars
twenty dollars ten dollars and five
dollar coins stashed in various bags
although this being said alex needed to
think about the constraint rachel told
him about he needed to give her money
such that the number of coins utilized
must be minimal to do so alex began
making a list of the various coin
combinations in which he could present
money to rachel
however after a while he became confused
due to the vast number of conceivable
combinations
so he decided to use his programming
ability to solve real life problems
alex developed a program that will
provide him with the optimal number of
coins that he can present to rachel
this generated program was iterating
through the different possibilities to
choose the best solution
at each iteration the program added the
coin of the largest value that was not
taking alex past the amount to be paid
which is 85 dollars in this case
for 85 dollars the largest denomination
id can start giving is 50 dollars
now id is still short of 35 to reach the
amount so that the next largest coin
program can take in as 20
but since the program still requires 15
dollars to meet the threshold the next
highest denomination it can accept is
ten dollars
followed by five dollars
the best part about this program was
that it allowed alex to present 85
dollars in just four coins which is
fairly incredible
the vital thing to note here is that
after each loop the program makes a
greedy choice providing the coin with
the highest potential value what i mean
here by greedy is that locally optimal
choice is picked at every step to reach
the global optimum solution now moving
ahead we will formulate the idea of
greedy algorithms
basically a greedy algorithm is based on
a problem-solving method that involves
making locally optimal decisions at each
stage in the hopes of achieving a global
optimum
that means at each stage we choose a
locally optimal value in the hopes of
arriving at the optimum possible end
result
furthermore this algorithm is an
optimization technique that can find
either minimum optimum result or maximum
optimum result
the best part about this algorithm is
that it is simple to understand and
implement as well additionally the
runtime complexity for this algorithm is
pretty reasonable however the
fundamental disadvantage of this
strategy is that we only receive the
globally optimum value in a small
percentage of cases
having said that you must be thinking
about when to implement this algorithm
for solving particular problems as it
does not always produce globally optimum
results
well let me tell you guys that we have
two conditions to judge our problem for
implementing greedy algorithms
the first condition is the greedy choice
property this notion states that making
locally optimal judgments can lead to
the global optimum solution for a given
problem
the second condition is about optimal
substructure
the problem has an optimal substructure
only if an optimal solution to the
entire problem comprises the optimal
solutions to the sub problems
in simpler words that means the problem
can be split down into multiple
subproblems and the solutions to these
subproblems can collectively lead to a
solution for the entire problem
if both the above-mentioned properties
are satisfied by the problem then we can
create a greedy solution for that
particular problem
moving forward we will look into the
steps for constructing a greedy solution
finding the substructure or sub problem
that can lead us to the final answer is
the first step in building a greedy
algorithm
because in this algorithm we are just
trying to operate with local optima to
reach the global optimum solution
the second step is about determining the
type of solution the given problem can
result into that can be either the
largest sum or minimum path
the final step for creating the greedy
solution is about creating an iterative
process for traversing through local
stages and making decisions to reach a
globally optimum solution
now you might be confused about how we
can do that
well let's go through an example to
understand the approach to implement a
greedy solution
the example that we are going to deal
with is called the traveling salesman
problem in which a salesman is supposed
to reach the destination from a given
current location
the representation of cities and parts
connecting them is done using graph
structure that each node is considered
as a city and edges connecting them as
parts having edge weight as the distance
between the two cities
now in this case we are supposed to find
the minimum path between two cities so
to do that we will begin from the
current arbitrary position
from this node called as starting
location there are three possible paths
but the path towards city b has less
distance hence we will traverse this
edge primarily as it is an optimal local
route
we have reached city b now and from this
node we have two possible parts out of
which one bar directly leads us towards
the destination city having distance 20
but the other path leading towards the
city f has edge weight value or distance
value as 2.
hence according to the local optimal
decision we will choose the edge
connecting cities b and f for traversal
we have reached the city f now from this
nodal city there is only one path
leading us to our destination
hence we will traverse it now we have
reached the destination city the path
highlighted in the green shade is the
global optimum for this tsp problem you
can verify that by calculating the edge
weights for all other possible parts
since the solution allows us to reach
the global optimum by making optimal
decisions at the local stage this
strategy to solve the problem will be
considered a greedy approach
now moving ahead we will look into the
demerits of using greedy algorithm
we have learnt that the greedy algorithm
makes decisions based on local optimum
instead of analyzing the broader picture
of the whole data hence there is a
possibility that the greedy solution
might not be the best optimal solution
for some problems
for example consider this travelling
salesman problem
in this problem the highlighted part is
a created solution to reach the
destination city from the current
location using a greedy algorithm
but if you observe this graph the
selected solution is not the global
optimal solution for this problem in
contrast it is the worst generated
solution to reach the destination
that is why the greedy algorithm is
considered to be prone to correctness
issues
even if the algorithm is correct proving
why it is correct is difficult thus it
is deemed to be trickier to solve
specific issues
now we will discuss about applications
of greedy algorithms to understand their
importance the first application of a
greedy algorithm is its use for
constructing minimum spanning trees
the coring approaches that we use to
generate msds is based on the greedy
algorithm
both prim's algorithm and kruskal's
algorithm are known as greedy algorithms
as they make decisions based on locally
optimal decisions
the next application of the greedy
algorithm is its used to implement
huffman encoding and decoding algorithms
the huffman coding technique is a
lossless data compression method
the concept is to give variable length
codes to input characters the lengths of
which are determined by the frequency of
the related characters
the smallest code is assigned to the
most frequently occurring character
whereas the largest code is assigned to
the least frequently occurring character
this process is carried out by making
local optimum decisions
hence it is also considered to be a
greedy algorithm
the final application of the greedy
algorithm is its use for developing
solutions to well-known coding problems
those problems are the activity
selection problem job selection problem
and fractional knapsack problem all
these problems generate solutions by
making decisions at each local stage so
the solutions for these problems can be
developed quite easily using the greedy
approach
hello everyone welcome to simply learns
youtube channel today we will be
discussing about prim's algorithm in
data structure but before we begin let
me tell you guys that we have daily
updates on multiple technologies so if
you are a tech geek in a continuous hunt
for latest technological advancements
then consider getting subscribed to our
youtube channel and don't forget to hit
that bell icon to never miss an update
from simplylearn
now without any further audio let's get
started with the agenda for today's
discussion
we will start this discussion with a
brief introduction to prim's algorithm
in data structure followed by that we'll
deal with finding mst with prim's
algorithm and finally we'll cover the
coding implementation of prim's
algorithm using c programming language
i hope i made myself clear with the
agenda now moving ahead let's get
started with our first topic which is
introduction to the prem's algorithm
the prims algorithm is used to find
minimum spanning tree for a given graph
but what exactly is a minimum spanning
tree or mst
well a minimum spanning tree is a subset
of graph g having the same number of
vertices as of graph g and edges
equivalent to a number of vertices minus
1.
along with these properties it also has
a minimum cost for summation of all age
weights included in a spanning tree
prim's algorithm starts with a single
node and explores all the adjacent nodes
at every state
the edges with minimal edge weights
causing no cycles in the graph gets
selected hence we can say that prim's
algorithm makes a locally optimal choice
intending to find global optimal choice
that is why it is called as greedy
algorithm
moving ahead let's understand how we can
find out the minimum spanning tree using
prim's algorithm
now given a graph g consisting of
vertices v and edges e we need to
construct a minimum spanning tree g dash
with vertices v dash equal to v and
edges e dash equal to v minus 1
having the summation of edge weights
minimal this particular graph g contains
9 vertices and 12 edges that means our
msd g dash will have 9 vertices and 9
minus 1 edges that is eight edges so
with this in mind let's create an msd
for this graph g using prim's algorithm
the first step in prim's algorithm is to
choose an arbitrary starting vertex
here we'll select node a as our starting
vertex
now the next step in prim's algorithm is
to add new vertices with a minimum age
weight
in this case from vertex a we have two
possible edges for traversal
the age weight for age a b is 1 whereas
the age weight for age ac is 6 so
obviously we'll choose vertex b here
since we have reached vertex b we'll
look into the possible ages for adding
an age with minimum weight to our msd
hbd have the minimum age weight so we'll
add it to our mst
now from vertex d there is only one edge
hence will directly add that edge dh
into a spanning tree
now from vertex h there are two possible
paths out of which the path hi has
minimum cost thus we'll add it to our
msd from vertex i there is only one edge
so we'll directly include it now mst now
that i have included vertex g i am going
to check what connected edges i have
from vertex g but since there is only
one edge from vertex g we'll just insert
it on our msd from vertex e two edges
are going to different vertices so we
will choose the one with least age
weight and that age is h e c
now that i have included node c i am
going to examine what connected edges i
have to consider from vertex c
currently out of these two highlighted
edges i want to pick that edge which has
not yet been included in mst and has the
minimum edge weight but the question
that arises here is can i add this edge
ac into our msd
well we cannot if we add h ac to our mst
then it won't remain a tree structure
due to the creation of cycle or a loop
which we cannot allow to happen
according to the prim's algorithm thus
in this particular case we'll choose h
cf for insertion in rmst and finally the
summation of age weight for this mst
will become 30.
also till the time you must have
observed that this algorithm chooses the
next vertex that offers the most
prominent or immediate benefit
it started with an empty spanning tree
for maintaining two sets of pertussis
the first site was for the vertices
included in the msd and the other one
was for the vertices that haven't been
included in the msd at every step this
algorithm considered all the edges that
connected the two sets and picked the
one with minimum age weight from the
adjacency matrix a group of edges that
connects two sets of vertices in a graph
is called cut in graph theory so at
every step of prim's algorithm we find a
cut of two sets one contains the
vertices already included in mst and the
other containing this rest of vertices
after that we pick the minimum age
weight from the cut and include that
vertex to our msd set that is why this
algorithm is called as greedy algorithm
having said that let's dive into the
implementation strategy for developing
code for prim's algorithm
the idea behind prim's algorithm is
simple all the vertices of a spanning
tree must be connected hence the two
disjoint subsets of vertices must be
connected in order to create a spanning
tree and further this vertices should
only be associated with the minimum age
weight to make it a minimum spanning
tree
in order to store these vertices and
edges will create an adjacency matrix
using 2d array in c programming language
well the indexes of this 2d matrix will
be the vertices where the values other
than 0 will be the edge widths
for indexes 0 1 and 2 you can clearly
see that the adjacency matrix is having
value 0
that means there is no recurring
connection or loop for these vertices so
primarily let's add them to our graph
structure
for age one to two
we have the weight value two so we will
add edge between
vertex zero and one
after that
we have
age between two and one the value for
this edge weight is three so we'll add
edge between one and two and ascend
three as its age rate
finally the age weight for connecting
zero to two is 4 so we'll insert it in
our graph as well in the next slide
we'll discuss the strategy for
implementation of a prim's algorithm
from this example i hope you are clear
with how we are going to maintain a
structure of a graph using 2d matrix in
the next slide we'll discuss the
strategy for the implementation of
prim's algorithm
the first step of this algorithm is to
maintain a set for keeping track of
vertices included in an msd once we
create the set we'll assign a key value
to all vertices in the input graph
initially we are going to set all key
values as infinite and at the runtime
we'll assign weight 0 to the first
vertex by doing that we choose it as an
arbitrary starting vertex
once done with that we'll start adding
vertices to our minimum spanning tree
for that we'll pick up a vertex u with
minimum weight to insert it into our set
after that we'll also update the key
values for all adjacent vertices of u
on that node let's visit a code editor
to implement prim's algorithm using c
programming language
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free
visit skill up by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
now in order to begin with coding
implementation we'll need to load some
dependencies for this implementation
process we are going to need a boolean
set in order to keep track of vertices
included in our msd that is why we will
include a standard boolean library in
our program
so
hash include
std
dot h
once done with this addition we'll
define a number of vertices that we are
going to use in our graph
i am going to set the number of vertices
to 5
so let's do that
hash
define
vertices
file
and if you want to implement mst for a
larger graph then you must set the
number of vertices to a more significant
number now let's move to the main
function
the graph that i am going to use for
generating a minimum spanning tree is
supposed to be stored inside a 2d matrix
so first let's have a look at that graph
this is the graph for which we want to
develop a minimum spanning tree the
first step that we must take to do that
is converting this graph into 2d matrix
as discussed earlier the diagonal values
will be null or zero and other values
will be the edge weights between two
nodes so without wasting any time on
this i will directly create adjacency
matrix for this graph inside our code
editor
this part is about maintaining our graph
in form of 2d matrix
now after this
we are calling prim semester function
which is responsible for generating a
minimum spanning tree so
let's do that here
rims
underscore mst and will pass this
graph
to this function
but we haven't developed any code for
this prim mst function but we'll do that
now
so let's create
prim's msd function
void
prims underscore mst
and will pass graph as an argument
should be for dices
and vertices
to make it a 2d matrix
now inside this function will create an
array named key to store key values of
all vertices
and key
vertices
along with that we'll also initialize
the parent in which will store our
actual mst and boolean set to keep track
of each and every vertex of our graph
so let's create that parent
array
and we'll create
boolean
set
for maintaining track of all vertices
now after this what we'll do is we'll
set the key values of all vertices to
infinity and we'll also make sure that
these vertices are not part of our
minimum spanning tree set so for that
we'll create a for loop
and inside this for loop we'll use
iterator element i
and we'll initialize this element to 0
till
vertices
and will increase the iterator element i
for each loop
and set this loop
we will set
key i
to the
possible integer maximum value
and in order to
use this value we'll need to add one
library which is called as limits dot h
so
we'll add it here
hash include
limits
dot h
okay
after this
we will also make sure that these
vertices are not part of our minimum
spanning tree set or boolean set so for
that we'll write statement mean
underscore span underscore tree
i
should be false that means empty
and we'll add indentation
okay
now in order to choose the arbitrary
index we'll set the key value of our
first vertex to 0 so that it will be
chosen first in our minimum spanning
tree for that we'll write statement key
should be equal to
0.
and as we have chosen vertex 0 as our
first arbitrary vertex so we'll also set
the index 0 of the parent array to minus
1.
by doing this we are ensuring that the
index 0 is the root node of our minimum
spanning tree
now to choose vertices with the minimal
key value we'll create a new function
named list key
so let's do that
end
list
underscore key
and inside it will pass arguments end
key
boolean set
and inside this function body we are
going to set all key values to infinity
so let's do that
in
list will be equal to end
underscore max
and
we'll also initialize
minimum underscore index as new variable
now using a for loop will traverse
through all vertices if the given vertex
is not present inside the minimum
spanning tree set and the key value is
also smaller than the least value then
we'll set the list variable to the key
value and minimum index to that
particular index fee
so
let's create that for loop
and inside it end v as iterator element
and we'll initialize
it to value zero
and
the maximum limit for this v
will be
vertices
and
we'll increase the value of this small v
variable
plus plus
now
if the chosen vertex
is not present inside minimum spanning
tree set
and and
the key value
for that vertex
is also smaller than list
then
we will set list
equal to
key of
v
and minimum index
to
v
and we'll get out of this for loop and
will return
the minimum index value
on that node let's arrive back at our
prims mst function
here using a for loop we'll fetch the
minimum index that we have generated
inside a list key function
so let's create for loop
we'll use count variable here
and we'll initialize it to 0
and we'll
move this count variable
till vertices
minus 1
which is nothing but the number of
vertices in our minimum spanning tree
next
we'll increase this count variable
now we have arrived inside this for loop
body
now we will store that fetch minimum
index value in variable u
so into u
will be equal to least
underscore key
and will pass
key
and
boolean set that is min
underscore span underscore tree
and
we will include this list node that is u
to our minimum spanning tree set
or boolean set
equal to true
here we'll use a nested loop in order to
insert a complete edge which is
initiating from node 0.
inside this loop we'll further call f
log to validate some conditions
so let's create that nested for loop
first
and
v
is equal to zero
plus plus
and inside this for loop
we'll add
if lock
and we'll check
graph
u
to v
and and
mean
span tree
v
is equal to equal to false
and and
graph
u
v
its
minimum than
key of v
then what we'll do is
we'll set
parent
of v
to u
and key
of v
to graph
you
read
so now you must be thinking about what
exactly is this code is doing
so actually what we are doing is we are
inserting node u into our minimum
spanning tree and once we include node u
into our minimum spanning tree then we
check if there is any age between u and
v
v is nothing but all the vertices inside
the graph if there is h with between u
and v then we check if that v is
included in our spanning tree or not if
it is not included then we check the
value key value of v
if the key value of v is greater then
what we do is we set parent of v is
equal to u
and key value of v is equal to graph u v
which is nothing but the weight between
h u and v
so that's what this code is doing
after this what we'll do is we'll write
one printf statement so for that we'll
need to get out of this for loop
and we'll write printf statement
print f
created
spanning
tree
for
given graph
is
backslash n
so that this next part comes inside the
next line
and
will also
make a call
to
print
underscore
prim's
mst
function which is not created yet but
we'll write code for it
once done with this call and will pass
parent and graph to it
well
now let's
create a code
for this print frames msd function
and
print
underscore prims
mst
and will pass
and
parent
will pass end
graph
with
vertices
and
now inside this function
what we'll do is we'll write one printf
statement
to
show the pattern of printing
edge
slash t
weight
slash
and
semicolon
and in next slide
we'll create iterator element
and we'll initialize it to 1
and we'll extend this
till
vertices
and i plus plus
printf
modulus d
dash
slash
d
backslash d
modulus d
and backslash n
and will pass
parent
i
comma i
comma
graph
i
and
parent
of
i
this statement will print a graph on our
screen
but here is one mistake
that i have made i haven't added the
indentation for this for loop
okay
i think this should be fine now
we can say that our coding
implementation is finished now let's run
our code and check if it is working or
not
well we have received output on our
console here that means our code is bug
free and it works fine
you can verify this result by drawing
the spanning tree of output on your
notebook and further you can compare it
with the graph that we have shown
previously
furthermore if you are concerned about
this code then don't be as we can send
it over to you if you drop your email
ids in the comment section below
additionally you can also try to run it
on your local system to understand its
minute implementation details and
implications
so with this successful coding
implementation we came to the end of
this video and with that we have come to
an end of this tutorial on data
structures and algorithms if you have
any queries regarding any of the topics
covered in this session or if you need
the quotes that we executed in this
particular tutorial then please feel
free to let us know in the comment
section below our team of experts will
be happy to resolve all your queries
until next time thank you stay safe and
keep learning
you